TO THE.
WEDNESDAY.
MAY SIXTEENTH.
SEEMS LIKE ONLY YESTERDAY WE
WERE MEETING.
IT WAS YESTERDAY THAT WE WERE
MAILING.
A WELCOME TO THE WHERE ARE
WEDNESDAY MAY SIXTEENTH MEETING
OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE.
WE ARE.
KNOCKING A VOTE ON THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR YET.
WILL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS HERE TO FORM A QUORUM AS
WILL SKIP OVER VOTE ONLY. AND TO
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF ONE.
WITH OUR PRESENTATIONS ON.
.
THE AIRFORCE CARBON PLAN.
LIMITATION I KNOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS OF THE
PRESENTING ON THAT.
ON THAT ITEM.
EVERYTHING ON OUR ITEMS TO BE
HURT.
AGENDA THIS MORNING.
OF WILL BE HOLD OPEN.
SOME WON'T ANTICIPATE TAKING ANY
ACTION TODAY.
AND. WELCOME EVERYONE.
THANK YOU THAT WAS LIKE IF YOU
KNOW ABOUT.
FORCE CARGO PLANE MY NAME'S QUE
LEAVE RIGHT IN WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCY AND.
I WAS GONNA SUMMARIZE A
PROPOSALS TODAY THEIR SET UP TO
IMPLEMENT FORCE CARBON PLAN BUT
WE HAVE.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES IN THE BCP IN THE CROWD
THAT WE CAN.
BRING UP FOR QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT DEPEND WHAT IS TO THE
LEFT ME WE CAN. DO OUR BEST TO
COVER A LOT OF CONTENT IN A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME GIVEN YOUR.
YOUR HEAVY AGENDA TODAY SO THAT
THOSE DUAL GOALS. LITTLE TOWN TO
A RIGHT ON TARGET THE.
.
SO LAST WEEK THE GOVERNOR.
ANNOUNCED A PACKAGE OF ACTIONS
STARTING WITH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND.
THAT WAS REALLY SET UP TO
IMPLEMENT THE FORCE CARBON PLAN
IN THE GOALS WITHIN THE FORCE
CARBON PLAN.
HEADLINE GOAL OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER WAS TO DOUBLE THE STATE'S
INTERVENTIONS INTO THE IN THE
DOUBLE THE DOUBLE THE STATE'S
TREATMENT OF FORESTS.
SO THAT WE CAN BUILD A RESILIENT.
STATEWIDE FOREST ECOSYSTEM THAT
CONVEYS ALL OF THE.
BENEFITS THAT WE DEPEND ON FROM
THE FOREST INCLUDING CARBON
SEQUESTRATION WATER SUPPLY.
ECOSYSTEM.
BENEFITS ETCETERA.
THE THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE.
BEFORE YOU TODAY NEAR STAFF DID
A GREAT JOB SUMMARIZING I'M
REALLY CAPTURES.
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME BEFORE
THE FORCE CARBON PLAN BUT WE'RE
ALSO EMBODIED IN THE PLAN.
THERE WERE.
CAPTURED IN REPORTS FROM THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THERE WERE MANY MANY
OTHERS UP UNTIL THE DAY WE
RELEASED IT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
COMING OUT WITH WITH SEEMINGLY A
CONSENSUS AROUND THE TYPES OF
ACTIONS WE NEED TO TAKE. ACROSS
BOTH TREATMENT AND AND AND USE
OF THE WORD TO TO REALLY RAMP UP
OUR EFFORTS AND OUR STATE
FORESTS.
WE ORGANIZE THIS PROPOSAL.
IN IN FOR THEM THREE GENERAL
CATEGORIES
AND THE FIRST CATEGORY WAS TO
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
FORCE MANAGEMENT IN RESTORATION
EFFORTS.
.
THAT'S ALL GO THROUGH THESE
PROPOSALS BUT BUT.
AT THE TOP OF IT IS CAL FIRES
PROPOSAL TO DRAMATICALLY RAMPED
UP ITS.
ON GOING STAFFING TO CONDUCT
PRESCRIBED BURN OPERATIONS AND
FEEL REDUCTION OPERATIONS AND.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IS THESE WOULD BE NEW
STAFF THAT WOULD NOT BE.
FIREFIGHTER CLASSIFICATIONS ID
BE DEDICATED TO FORCED YOU WORK
AND THEY WOULD.
REALLY BE THERE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR TO SET UP THAT PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS THAT YOU NEED SET UP.
TO TO TO ACTUALLY MAKE ALL OF
THIS WORK THESE ARE REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROMOTION OF
THAT INTO THE DEPARTMENT AND
COULD SERVE AS.
YOU KNOW THE DOORWAYS FOR FOR.
CONSERVATION CORPS MEMBERS ARE
OTHER OTHER OTHER FOLKS WITH
WITH WITH WITH FORESTRY
EXPERIENCE BUT NOT FIRELIGHT
CERTIFICATIONS SO. WE SEE THIS
IS A GREAT JOBS TRAINING KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO ONE WAY TO
STABILIZE OUR OUR PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS THAT WE NEED TO.
CONDUCT OVER TIME
THE.
THE CINEMATIC CONSERVANCY
THAT'S THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE M. FOR PROP SIXTY EIGHT.
IS DIRECTED THAT.
IMPLEMENTING THEIR WATERSHED
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS
REALLY THE MODEL FOR HOW WE WANT
TO ADDRESS FORESTRY ISSUE
STATEWIDE IT IS A. IT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ACROSS THE
JURISDICTION OF THE CONSERVANCY
THAT'S FOCUSED AT MAXIMIZING
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING THESE PROJECTS BUT
ALSO FORGING. KIND OF.
BINDING COMMITMENTS WITH WITH
OUR WITH OUR LEATHERLANDOWNING
PARTNERS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR PRIVATE LAND
OWNERS IN THEN. MAXIMIZING THOSE
COMMITMENTS FOR.
LANDSCAPE WIDE PROJECTS.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY WE
HAVE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
YOU TARA FUNDS PROPOSED HERE.
THAT FUNDING IS REALLY INTENDED
TO BE.
.
CATALYST FUNDING TO TO REPLICATE
THE WATERSHED IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM OVER DIFFERENT REGIONS
OF
STATE SO IN IN IN THE SIERRA
REGION WE HAVE THIS YEAR NEVADA
CONSERVANCY. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE MANY WE HAVE MULTIPLE
STAY CONSERVANCY IS IN THE
NORTHERN PARTS OF OUR STATE WE
DON'T HAVE THE CONSERVANCY'S TO
SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF. REGIONAL
LANDSCAPE ECOSYSTEM Y. TYPE OF
RESPONSE.
NOW TO RESOURCE AGENCY WE HAVE
A LOT OF WE WE HAVE. GREAT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
STATEWIDE AND WE WANT TO USE
THIS FUNDING TO PLAY A ROLE AND.
IN A BRING TOGETHER THESE
COLLABORATIONS AND.
YOU KNOW
FORCING A A A LARGER COORDINATED
EFFORT. THEM WHERE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE GUIDANCE ALREADY.
PARKS AND RECREATION LEGACY
FORESTED STATE PARK THAT'S
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP
SIXTY EIGHT FROM THE FUNDING THE
WRIST THEY HAVE ALLOCATED IN THE
BOND. THIS IS.
OUR CHANCE TO SHOWCASE TO THE
PUBLIC WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE FROM OUR FORCE
RESTORATION WORK.
THE STATE HAS MADE.
MANY MANY MANY MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IN ITS NATURAL ECOSYSTEM THE
STATE PARK WE CARE ABOUT.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE STATE PARK BUT
THIS IS ALSO ONE OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE THERE HAS NOT BEEN.
.
BUT ENOUGH INVESTMENT TO KEEP UP
WITH THE NEED IN OUR IN OUR
NATURAL LANDS.
AND THE PARKS WILL.
.
LOOK AT THEIR LEGACY FOREST DO
THIS WORK BUT THEN THIS IS OUR
CHANCE TO SHOW SHOWCASE PUBLICLY
AND PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO.
THE NEXT CATEGORY IS BUILDING
LOCAL CAPACITY AND STRENGTHENING
REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS THIS
REALLY THEN OVERLAY OF.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU GET THIS
WORK DONE IF IF THE IF THE SCALE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO? AND
ALSO ACHIEVE THE BENEFITS THAT
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE.
MOVING AWAY FROM FROM FROM.
FROM
SMALLER COLLECTED.
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
TRYING TO TO LOOK AT PROJECTS IN
A MORE HOLISTIC FASHION ACROSS
LARGER LANDSCAPES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
HERE HAS A PROPOSAL FOR ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUND. THAT WOULD FUND THE THAT
THE ACTORS ON THE GROUND THE
WATERSHED COORDINATORS WHO ARE
THERE TO REALLY BRING TOGETHER
THE LOCAL. THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL.
GRASSROOTS.
NONPROFITS BUT ALSO INDIVIDUAL
AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS WHO ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING AND LARGE
COLLABORATIVE FORESTRY EFFORTS
BUT DON'T HAVE THAT. KIND OF
ORGANIZATION AND THEY ARE ALSO
THEY ARE ALSO THE ONES THAT
DRIVE. THE.
.
YOU KNOW GRANT GRANT WRITING
ACTIVITIES PROJECT READY NESS
RELIEF TRYING TO SERVICE THE
GLUE BETWEEN ALL THESE DIFFERENT.
GOODWILL BUT SOMETIMES DESPAIR
PARTIES AND BRING THEM TOGETHER.
THE THIRD IS.
INNOVATION AND AND AND
INCREASING ECONOMIES AROUND THE
USE OF MATERIALS FROM POOR SELF
PROJECTS. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IF YOU.
HERE RIGHT NOW IF THE SCALE OF
OF RESTORATION THAT WERE
OPERATING THAT WE HAVE A HARD
TIME MANAGING. THE.
THE PRODUCTS FROM FORCE
RESTORATION ACTIVITIES.
MOST OF THOSE THOSE PRODUCTS GO.
.
I'M USED ESSENTIALLY AND AND AND
BURNT IN PILES ON THE FLOOR ONCE
FOREST. THINNING ACTIVITIES
COMPLETED SO THERE'S A REAL.
.
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO FIND NEW
WAYS TO USE THOSE MATERIALS THAT
CAN ALSO THEY CAN THEY CAN
REDUCE OUR JUST BURNING OF THESE
MATERIALS ON THE GROUND IN
CREATING THAT. THEY ARE QUALITY
IN CARBON EMISSIONS AT THAT HAS
BUT ALSO CREATE ECONOMIES AROUND
THE USE OF THESE MATERIALS IN A
WAY THAT.
WILL HOPEFULLY INCENTIVIZE IN A
WHIRL.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND SO
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING HERE IS
THEM BY THREE PROPOSALS THE.
BOARD OF THE FIRST ONE WOULD BE
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET YEAR. AND
THEN SOME FUNDING ON GOING TO
ESTABLISH A.
JOINT INSTITUTE FOR WOOD
PRODUCTS INNOVATION WE HAVE
INCREDIBLE CAPACITY IN OUR UC
AND CSU AND.
OTHER ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS TO.
TO REALLY PUSH THE NEEDLE
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
ON AND WOOD PRODUCTS.
ENGINEERING AND DESIGN AND.
THOSE EFFORTS ARE ARE SOMEONE
ONGOING RIGHT NOW ON THE IN THE
IN THE INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS
AND DIVISIONS OF OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BRING THOSE
TOGETHER AND TRY TO CREATE AN
INSTITUTE THAT COULD LEVERAGE
BOTH THE.
KIND OF TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
AROUND DESIGNING THESE PRODUCTS
BUT ALSO THE.
THE KIND OF TESTING EXPERTISE
AROUND ENGINEERING ARCHITECTURAL
EARTHQUAKE.
RESILIENCY AT CETERA.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A IT'S AN
ADOPTION OF A OF A NEW BUILDING
CODE IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO I
BELIEVE. THAT COULD EXPAND THE
USE OF THESE ENGINEERED WOOD
PRODUCTS TOO MUCH TALLER
BUILDINGS AND ARE CURRENTLY
ALLOWED SO THIS WOULD PUT US IN
THE POSITION TO.
LEVERAGE AND EXPERTISE TO.
GET THOSE PRODUCTS RATING ALSO
GET THAT INDUSTRY REDDING
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IT IS IT IS.
.
BEING DEVELOPED ALONG THE WEST
COAST IN OREGON AND WASHINGTON
AS WELL. CAN AND YOU SAID THE.
BUILDING CODE IS INTENDED TO GO
INTO EFFECT.
OF THE REVISIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THINGS TWENTY TWENTY
IF I'M REMEMBERING WAS TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHEN THE
INTERNATIONAL BUILDING CODES.
WOULD COME INTO EFFECT AROUND
MASS TIMBER SO THAT THE. THE THE
STRUCTURAL BEAMS MADE OUT OF
WOOD THAT COULD REPLACE
STEEL BEAMS.
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
ADOPTED IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
THEN.
IT'S A STATE WE ADOPT THOSE
INTERNATIONAL CODES.
AND THAT'S FOR TALLER BUILDINGS
IN THE CURRENT THRESHOLD.
SELECT SOME PUT A PIN IN THAT
BECAUSE I AT SOME.
FUTURE POINT IN THE NEAR FUTURE
I'D LIKE TO GET MORE INFORMATION
WRITE LA UP ABOUT THAT.
SO THE NEXT. BUT THAT SOUNDS
GOOD IN THE NEXT PROPOSAL WAS
FROM THE CINMATIC.
SERMON SEEKING A BUILDING ON THE
SAFETY OF THAT.
WE HAVE.
.
CAPACITY IN OUR ROOM WORLD
FORCED ECONOMIES TO BUILD THESE
TYPES OF INDUSTRIES.
IT'S ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE TIMBER RESTORATION AND TEAR
FOR FUND. AND IT IS INTENDED FOR
GRANTS TO SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT. WOOD
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURING CAPACITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ENFORCED IT
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA SO
THIS FUNDING IS IS IS REALLY
MEANT TO DRIVE.
YOU KNOW TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE
TRYING TO DEVELOP THESE CAMPUSES
AND REOPEN THEM WE OPEN MILLS.
TOGETHER WILL HELP THEM GET TO
THE BAY AREA FACING THE GET TO
THOSE AMERICA.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM MANY LOCALS ON THAT
THEY NEED THEY NEED SUPPORT BUT
THEY ALSO WITH THEY WILL ALSO
NEED ALONG WITH FUNDING IS JUST
HELP FROM OUR DEPARTMENTS IN
GETTING THROUGH THE. IN THE MANY
DIFFERENT REGULATORY AND.
AND OTHER BARRIERS THAT WE CAN
ASSIST THEM WITH.
THEN THE FINAL PROPOSAL BACKED
THE MASS TIMBER IS A IS A
BUILDING COMPETITION THAT WE WE
HONESTLY YOU KNOW COPY THIS IDEA
FROM OREGON AND WASHINGTON. THEY
CONDUCTED SIMILAR.
OREGON I CAN'T REMEMBER
WASHINGTON AND OREGON DID ONE.
BUT THE IDEA IS THAT YOU IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO PUSH FOR THESE
MASS TIMBER. BUILDINGS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND BECAUSE LOCAL
PERMITTING IS NOT ACCUSTOMED TO
DEALING WITH. HAVE NEW WAYS TO
BUILD BUILDINGS CITIES THESE
FUNDS WOULD BE.
DIRECTED PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN.
LOCAL DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CAN OF SERVICE
PILOT PROJECTS
SHOWCASE HOW YOU CAN BUILD THESE
BILLS BUILDINGS.
WE'VE SEEN A FEW.
BUILDINGS.
GOING UP ACROSS STATE BUT
RECENTLY PLUMAS COUNTY.
CAN
DESTRUCTIVE.
AND IT WAS MAGIC TO THE
COURTHOUSE BUT IT WAS.
IT WAS NOT AN EASY UNDERTAKING
AND IT'S NOT EASY TO CONVINCE
THE LOCALS TO JUST TO ALLOW
SIMITIS BUT WITH A LOT OF. KIND
OF PUSHING AND AND HARD WORK
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET THEIR
BUILDINGS BUILT.
THAT WE WANT TO CREATE MORE
BORER MORE MODELS OF THAT AROUND
THE STATE AND THAT WOULD BE AT
THE. GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY SO. YOU WITH THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF.
LOT OF INFORMATION WE CAN
DISCUSS AROUND THE FORCE CARBON
PLAN ITSELF.
BUT THOUGHT WE COULD WE COULD
JUST PAUSE FOR QUESTIONS.
AND THEN I GUESS THAT EVERYONE
WE HAVE PEOPLE THE CROWD FOR THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS.
RESPOND
THANK YOU.
IT IS THERE.
HOW DO ALL THESE PIECES LE A
BECOME COORDINATED TO?
WHAT AGENCY IS SIR RESPOND RIGHT
OFF THAT HOW THAT HAPPENED FIFTH
OF?
NO HAS A LOT OF PIECES IT IS A
LOT OF PIECES GREAT QUESTIONS SO
I CAN TIM WHAT A DIRECTOR CAL
FIRE. OUGHT SO.
CENTER TO ALL OF THIS IS
ENGAGING.
A FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE
THAT WILL. ESSENTIALLY INVOLVE A
A PIVOTING OF THE EXISTING TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE THAT HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL. IN
DEALING WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
HUNDRED TWELVE TWENTY NINE
MILLION. TREES DEAD IN THE
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN SIERRA
PRIMARILY. UP BUT THE ISSUE IS
OBVIOUSLY BROADER IT'S TAKING OF
THE DEAD TREES ARE A SYMPTOM OF
THIS BROADER FOREST HEALTH
FOREST RESILIENCY.
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO IT'S PART OF THE ROLL OUT
LAST WEEK AND WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS PIVOTING THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE.
HERE IN THE COMING WEEKS TO A
BROADER FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE THAT WILL ENCOMPASS.
COORDINATING ALL OF THE EFFORTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE FORCE CARBON
PLAN WELL AS WELL AS OTHER PLANS
THE STATE'S OF STRATEGIC FIRE
PLAN. ARE AND BRING AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
TOGETHER MEAN THAT TREE
MORTALITY WILL STILL BE AN
EMPHASIS WITHIN THIS BUT WILL BE
A MUCH BROADER FOCUSING ON.
MIA WOULD PRODUCTS MARKETING
FUELS TREATMENT PRESCRIBED FIRE.
AT ALL OF THIS GETTING US TO
THIS GOAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES TREATED TO
ANNUALLY ON PRIVATE LAND SO THAT
WILL BE.
HERE COMING IN THE COMING WEEKS.
AS WE.
FORMULATE THAT THAT TASK FORCE
AND IT WILL BRING TOGETHER THESE
AGENCIES TO COORDINATE NOT JUST
THE EFFORT BUT.
TO IDENTIFY AND HELP STREAMLINE
FUNDING AND A TARGET REGIONAL.
PROJECTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THIS
TASK FORCE WILL NOT BE ANOTHER
LAYER OFBUREAUCRACY IT'S
DESIGNED ACTUALLY TO SUPPORT.
REGIONAL LOCAL EFFORTS ON THE
GROUND THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL TO
REALLY LEVERAGE MAXIMUM BENEFIT
AND AGAIN WOULD HELP THE LOCAL
SUPPORT. ARE GETTING THIS WORK
DONE.
THANK YOU.
.
WHEN THE.
PART PART OF THE SET UP PLANNED.
WHICH SHOWED EVEN SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON HIS HAS TO DO WITH
REFORESTATION CORRECT.
BOB CAN YOU JUST STOOD DESCRIBED
WHAT IS.
ENVISIONED.
SO ARE AT SEVERAL THINGS ARE
OBVIOUSLY REFORESTATION IS A
BROADER COMPONENT.
IT'S ONE OF THE MANY COMPONENTS
IN IN TREATING OUR FORCE LANCE
AND SO WE ONE.
DUBBED HILLS RIGHT INTO A CAL
FIRE RE ESTABLISHING OF THE
DAVIS NURSERY TO GROW SEEDLINGS
WE ARE REALLY TARGETING.
THE OF THE.
HERE ONE MILLION ACRES OF
FOREST LAND IN THE STATE ALL
LANDS COMBINED NINE MILLION
ACRES OF THAT ARE SMALL. FAMILY
FOREST LAND OWNERS OFFIFTY TO
TWO HUNDRED ACRES IN SIZE. OUT
WE ARE REALLY FOCUSING THIS
EFFORT TO HELP SUPPORT CAPACITY.
FOR THOSE LANDOWNERS TO BE ABLE
TO REFOREST.
AFTER THE INSECT AND DISEASE
I'M CAUSE MORTALITY DEVASTATING
FIRE O. OR LANDS THAT ARE JUST
UNDER.
FORESTED BECAUSE OVER TIME.
THAT INVASIVE SPECIES AND OTHER.
.
SPECIES HAVE COMMANDED AND
DISPLACED ACCOUNTED FORRISEN
AND ANOTHER.
TREE SPECIES AND SO THIS EFFORT
WILL INCLUDE A VERY.
EXTENSIVE AND ROBUST COMPONENT
IN WORKING TOWARDS THAT WE FOR
STING LANZA THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND AS WE RESTORE FOR
US.
.
I PRESUME THAT WERE OUT NOT ONLY
LOOKING AT.
VALUE OF FLAT CARBON
SEQUESTRATION BUT ALSO.
OF THE VALUE IN THAT.
STORING WATER.
THAT THEN GETS CLEANED AND
CIRCULATE SO. YEAH A DOWN SO
THAT THE CORRECT
FORCE CARTON PLAN WAS.
MAYBE MAYBE TO NARROW THE TITLE
FOR THE PLAN BECAUSE THE FOCUS
OF THE PLAN WAS REALLY TO.
LOOK AT OUR FORCES ECOSYSTEM Y.
SYSTEMS THAT WE WOULD YOU KNOW
SEEK TO RESTORE TO ALL OF THE
AND TO PROTECT ALL OF THE
BENEFITS THAT WE DEPEND ON FROM
US FOR SO. NOT ONLY THE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION BUT.
THE ECOSYSTEM THE HABITAT THE
WATER YOU KNOW
QUALITY AND WATER SUPPLY AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THANK THANK YOU.
YOU'RE DESCRIBING IT MUCH MORE
ORPHALI THAN I DID. TIME.
WHICH
SHOULD BE THE CASE.
.
BUT TO OF THEM.
THERE ARE ALL ARE ALL OF THOSE.
AT BENEFITS AND INTENTIONS
WRITTEN INTO THE PLAN YES.
I'VE ARE THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO MENTION IS SOMETHING
THAT I I REALLY WAS JUST A BRIEF
DON. AS RECENTLY AS LAST FRIDAY
BY A SOME SCIENTISTS AT UCLA.
AND THAT IS THE ISSUE OF HOW WE
THINK ABOUT. OUR RESTORATION OF
FORCE
OF ARE WE RESTORING FORESTS TO.
.
THE CONDITION THAT WE FOUND THE
MEN TODAY ARE CONTEMPORANEOUSLY
OR ARE WE LOOKING FORWARD.
THROUGH THE LENS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND RESTORING FOREST SO THAT
THEY WILL BE RESILIENT.
TEN YEARS TWENTY YEARS AND FIFTY
YEARS FROM NOW.
IT'S VERY GOOD QUESTION AND WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO.
THE FORESTS A OF TODAY OR
YESTERDAY ARE NOT WHERE THEY
WILL BE.
TOMORROW AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT THIS.
AND IT WOULD WOULD NEVER BEEN
CHALLENGED BY A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION TREES DYING.
AND REALLY WHAT'S ONE EPISODE
IT'S CHANGING THAT THE LANDSCAPE
FOR THE CENTRAL.
AND SOUTHERN SIERRA BUT IT'S
REALLY STATEWIDE IMPACTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING AND SO THIS
INVOLVES LOOKING AT WHAT ARE THE
APPROPRIATE TREE SPECIES.
AND AND OTHER SHRUB AND PLANT
SPECIES ARE AT ELEVATION AND
LATITUDE THAT'S DIFFERENT GOING
FORWARD AND THAT'S LOOKING AT
CHANGING WEATHER PATTERNS
TEMPERATURES ARE. LITERALLY THE
CHANGING CLIMATE IS IMPACTING
WHAT WILL GROW AT DIFFERENT
ELEVATION AND IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND SO IT'S TRYING TO
MODEL WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IN
THE DESIRED STATE INTO THE
FUTURE AND ENGAGING IN. WHAT WE
NEED TO DO NOW TO TAKE TO GET
THERE AND MAKE UP SURVIVABLE?
AND THIS IS AND THIS IS REALLY
WHERE WE'VE.
WE'RE IN A GREAT POSITION
BECAUSE WE AS A STATE OF
INVESTED IN. CLIMATE SCIENCE SO
WE HAVE.
NOT ONLY NOT ONLY STATE FUNDED
BUT ALSO IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS WE HAVE REALLY GOOD DATA
ON WHAT. TO EXPECT ACROSS OUR
DIFFERENT LANDSCAPE AND HOW
ECOSYSTEMS WILL MOVE.
FOR GOING TO BE RELEASING A OF
THE BIG TRUNKS OF THAT RESOURCE
THIS SUMMER IN THE FOURTH
CLIMATE CHANGE SETTLEMENT AT ALL
REALLY SHOWCASE WILDFIRE. NO WE
SHOULD EXPECT WILDFIRES BUT ALSO
WE SHOULD EXPECT FROM
TEMPERATURE INCREASES AND
HABITAT MIGRATION AND EVERYTHING
ELSE SO.
IF TRIPS TOGETHER NICELY GREAT
PATH I THANK YOU AND.
FINALLY.
WITH MY A SUB THREE AND MY
HOUSING HATS ON AT THE SAME TIME.
AYE AYE AYE WHAT'S TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE.
OF FORCED PRODUCT INNOVATION.
OF A PROPOSAL WHICH I THINK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US. AND
WE CERTAINLY HAVE THE THE
RESOURCES HERE FOR IMPLEMENTING
AT A VERY ROBUST INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
ONE OF THE CENTERS.
GIVEN THE THE AMOUNT OF FOR.
THAT THE SIZEABLE FORCE THAT WE
HAVE IN THE IN THE STATE.
BUT IT OF STRIKES ME THAT.
OF THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE.
SOME NEW INDUSTRIES.
THAT OUR OWN HOUSING AND
BUILDING INDUSTRIES CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE FACE IN THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. IS THE
EXTRAORDINARY COST OF
CONSTRUCTION.
TO BUILD A.
AREA MULTI FAMILY HOUSING UNIT
A SINGLE UNIT A IS COSTING
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
IN SOME CASES.
OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT I'VE AND. UP
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO DE
RESTRICTED HOUSING BUT REALLY
ANY HOUSING THE HIGHER THE
UNDERLYING COSTS ARE THE MORE
PRESSURE THERE IS ON THAT ON
RENTS AND TO. A PURCHASE PRICES.
THERE IS AT THE SAME TIME THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING.
A THE STUFF FORCE PRODUCT
INNOVATIONS THERE'S ALSO A
BUDDING INDUSTRY AND
PREFABRICATED TO.
UP PANELS OFFER HOUSING THIS
ISN'T OLD STYLE PREFAB IT'S NEW
AND INNOVATIVE AND I DON'T NEED
TO GET INTO DETAILS HERE. BUT IT
STRIKES ME THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE AN ENTIRELY NEW.
INNOVATIVE INDUSTRY THAT WILL
BENEFIT NOT ONLY OUR FORESTS BUT
ARE HOUSING ISSUES.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU AND
SUGGEST THAT.
YOU LOOK INTO THAT AND A
COORDINATE THIS PROJECT AROUND
THAT AS A A AS AN ULTIMATE GOAL
ONE OF MANY GOALS BUT.
ABOUT WHAT COULD BE A VERY
IMPORTANT GOAL.
AND NOW.
IF THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM
THE DICE.
WE'LL HEAR FROM ALEJO. GREAT. I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MONEY
MEMBERS ACTUALLY ENDS WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I THINK WE.
AGREE WITH A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ARE EVEN SAID.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING APPROVING
MOST OF THE PROPOSAL WE. AGREE
THAT BRIGHTENS OF THOSE EXIST
ABOUT THE PROBLEMATIC CONDITIONS
OF THE STATE'S FORESTS.
IN THAT THE PACE AND SCALE HAVE
NOT BEEN ENOUGH TO KEEP UP WITH
THOSE PROBLEMS.
WE ALSO FIND THAT THIS PROPOSAL
HAS A LOT OF. ITEMS IN IT THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE
RECENTLY AND THE ANALYST'S
REPORT REGARDING PERSON
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT. AND THERE
WAS ONE COMPONENT OF THE PACKAGE
THAT WE DID HAVE SOME
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS ON AND
THAT WAS THE TWENTY MILLION AND
YOU ARE OF MONIES. A FOR
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR THE
REGIONAL FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS.
ISN'T A REVIEW IT SEEMS LIKE
ABOUT HER THE PROPOSAL JUST OR
CONCEPTUAL PHASE RIGHT NOW AND
DEMONSTRATION IS STILL
DEVELOPING EXACTLY WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND HOW IT WOULD
WORK. AND SO WE HAVE RECOMMENDED
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ASKING SOME QUESTIONS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION
SPECIFICALLY ON WHAT STEPS WERE
LEFT TO. A BE ABLE COMPLETELY
DEVELOPED THIS PROGRAM AND HOW
LONG THAT WOULD TAKE.
WHEN SHE EXPECTS
OF THE TIMING OF THE GRANT MONEY
INTO IT TO GO OUT AND WHICH WE
START SEEING PROJECTS HAPPEN HOW
MUCH OF THAT WOULD BE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND FINALLY A HALL
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF VISION
PRIORITIZING VARIOUS WATERSHEDS
ON AREAS OF THE STATE'S FOR
THESE PROJECTS AND THIS FUNDING.
THEY DID PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO US
REGARDING THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THAT AND.
MIA HAPPY TO UPDATE THE
COMMITTEE LATER AS WE AS WE DO
THAT BUT THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
ASK AS WELL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALPHA YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
BELIEVE THAT.
ALL OF THAT SORT OF FUNDING
PROPOSED INCLUDING AND THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FOR AGENCY WILL REALLY HELP US.
AND TO MEET OUR STATEWIDE
TARGETS IN TERMS OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS
AND OVERALL FORCE HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU IF THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM AT
THIS TIME AND THEN.
AS WE GO FORWARD THROUGH THE
AGENDA WE WILL I TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF EACH SHOT
DEPARTMENTS PRESENTATION ON ALL
OF. THEIR ISSUES.
AND BEFORE YOU BEGIN. WERE
INTEGRAL.
SO. HERE FALL HERE KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RIGHT AND DOUBLE DO THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR.
.
WHEN. WE'RE DONE WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT.
MIKE GERMAN BLOOM MEMBERS MANY
PAUL MASON FOR PACIFIC FOR A
STRESSED HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS YOU KNOW THOUGHTFUL AND
MULTIFACETED PROPOSALS
AUGMENTATION IN THE MAY REVISE.
I DO I PARTICULARLY.
SUPPORT THE.
PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE RESOURCES AGENCY
TO HELP CATALYZE SOME PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION. OF ACTUAL
FOR WATERSHED AND REGIONAL PLANS
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
THEN THE FEAR NEVADA WHICH IS
AHEAD OF THE GAME ON THAT.
YOU KNOW HAVING SOME RESOURCES
TO HELP. INSTIGATE SOME OF THAT
COLLABORATION AND PLANNING IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL BECAUSE THESE
THINGS JUST DON'T COME TOGETHER.
ON THEIR OWN OR WITHOUT SOME
LEVEL OF RESOURCES TO HELP ARE
CATALYZE THAT SO THAT THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
BETWEEN THE CURRENT.
BUDGET YEAR WHERE CAL FIRE GOT
A REALLY SUBSTANTIAL ALLOCATION
AND THIS ALLOCATION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REALLY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE FOREST AND.
THANKED ME VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ACHIEVING
THOSE SORT OF MULTI BENEFIT.
OUTCOMES OF THE CHAIR VIOLATED
FOUR WATERSHEDS FOR WILDLIFE FOR
FOR SELF AND FOR FIRE BEHAVIOR.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
SOME INTERDISCIPLINARY INPUT
INTO HOW WE'RE DESIGNING IN
SELECTING THOSE PROJECTS I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY CRITICAL.
AND SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROBABLY WANTS TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
ON.
BUT IN GENERAL I THINK IT'S
REALLY A FANTASTIC PROPOSAL VERY
SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU.
GOING TO MISS YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIE MALINOWSKI BALL THE HAVE
TO CALIFORNIA BY A MASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE WANNA EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL. WE
ACTUALLY WANTS HIM TO COVER HER
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THE FUNDING AND THIS WILL GO A
LONG WAY AND IN PARTICULAR THE
BIOMASS INDUSTRY STANDS UP BY
READY AT TO ASSIST WITH ANY FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE WASTE.
OF FROM THAT FROM THOSE PROJECTS
I GET BENEFICIAL REUSE PROJECTS.
WITH BIOMASS FACILITIES THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING ELENA ORTIZ ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS A VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS ITEM.
SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
WATERSHED COORDINATOR GRANTS.
AND OUR CITIES HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
EMPLOYED WATERSHED COORDINATOR
GRANTS IN THE BENEFIT THESE
POSITIONS SERVE CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED. BUT TO TRULY GET THE
MOST BENEFIT FROM THESE GRANTS
THIS FUNDING NEEDS TO BE CARRIED
FORWARD IN FUTURE YEARS. YEAR
AFTER YEAR FUNDING AND NOT A ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION IS NEEDED TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT THAT
WATERSHED COORDINATOR CRACKS
PROVIDES YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT TO HAVE BRING SELF PUBLIC
COMMENT TO CLOSE ON THIS ITEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING GO
WILL BE TAKING NO ACTION TODAY
BUT TO THINK WE'LL COME BACK.
TO THE.
OF PLANNED.
IN THE THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
WE'RE GOING TO.
PAUSE AND TAKE THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR NOW IF THERE'S A MOTION
ó I DID WANT TO I MAKE ONE.
COMMENTER ROCK.
.
CALL OUT AT AN ERROR IN THE
AGENDA.
ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE OF THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR THE REPORT
INCORRECTLY.
AND SAYS SIR.
HOLD OPEN AND IT. SHOULD HAVE
FOR REFERENCE TO VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR IT WOULD.
THAT THAT.
WE WOULD BE VOTING TO APPROVE IT.
I AM SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING
IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH ELEVEN ON THE
VOTE ON THE COUNTER AND MAKE
THEM SECOND.
VOTE MOTION BY PATTERSON AND A
SECOND BY FONG AND LOOK.
BLOOM. AYE. FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
AHEAD OF A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
YES WILL OVERHAULED LISTA OPEN
SO THAT TO MISTER MILLIKEN AND
ON WHEN HE GETS HERE. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WE'VE GOTTA TWO
ISSUES WITH THE ARMY
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN WOMEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
EASY CHIANG A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND I'LL START WITH A
FARMER ITEM.
SO EMISSIONS FROM AGRICULTURE
EQUIPMENT ARE A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION
PARTICULARLY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WERE OVER TWENTY PERCENT
OF THE SMOG FORMING KNOCKS IN PM
EMISSIONS COME FROM AGRICULTURAL
ENGINES.
REDUCING THESE EMISSIONS OF
NECESSARY TO MEET OUR HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY STANDARDS AND
OUR STATE GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS.
AND WE'VE ADOPTED STANDARDS SO
THAT NEW ENGINES ARE CLEANER BUT
THE TURNOVER OF ENGINES IN AND
THE VALLEY IS SLOW AND MANY
AGRICULTURAL PIECES OF EQUIPMENT
ARE USED FOR DECADES.
ON BECAUSE OF THE AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESSES SUBJECT VOLATILITY.
UNPREDICTABLE WEATHER LIKE WE'RE
EXPERIENCING TODAY VARYING
COMMODITY PRICES AND GLOBAL
COMPETITION. AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESSES ARE OFTEN RELUCTANT
TO PURCHASE NEW EQUIPMENT UNTIL
IT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE NATURAL
TURNOVER OF AG EQUIPMENT IS VERY
VERY SLOW AND IT'S REALLY TOO
SLOW O MEET THE STATE'S CLEAN
AIR NEEDS. INCENTIVES HAVE BEEN
ONE WAY THAT WE'VE SUCCESSFULLY
ENCOURAGED TURNOVER. BEFORE THE
END OF THE USEFUL LIFE OF THIS
EQUIPMENT AND MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT FIND AG ENGINE
REPLACEMENT ARE OVERSUBSCRIBED
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
I'M OUR BOARD RECENTLY APPROVED
GUIDELINES TO IMPLEMENT WHAT WE
CALL THE FARMER PROGRAM. ON THAT
WOULD EXPAND FUNDS AT THAT WERE
PROVIDED A LAST YEAR THAT WAS
DONE AT THE MARCH BOARD MEETING.
PROVIDE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDS ON IN THIS FISCAL IN NEXT
FISCAL YEAR WILL HELP SPEED AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS AND ALSO
HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THANK
THANK YOU.
LA OWE ANY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RICH
ROSS BROWN WITH THE ALEJO AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES THIS THE.
THIRTY MILLION GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO A ONE ONE HUNDRED
TWO MILLION. GIGI R. F. PROPOSED
APPROPRIATION BY THE GOVERNOR.
WE.
.
* WOULD RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING SOURCES THAT THIS IS A
HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THEN IT COULD
CONSIDER REALLOCATING GTR UP
FUNDS FROM OTHER. ACTIVITIES FOR
THIS PURPOSE UP FOR EXAMPLE.
IF OF MYTH IF PRODUCING
AGRICULTURAL MISSION FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE HIGH PRIORITY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REALLOCATE
THOSE FUNDS NOW THAT WOULD.
LEAVE LESS MONEY FOR OTHER
CLIMATE RELATED ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD FREE UP GENERAL FUND FOR
OTHER LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU WOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THANK MONNING JULIANA MORRISSEY
ME WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THIS IS.
THIS IS A ONE TIME.
FUNDING FOR THE GENERAL FUND AND
IT'S APPROPRIATE SO IT'S IT'S
NOT GOING TO CREATE ONGOING
PRESSURES.
IT ALSO SUPPORTS IT HASSAM CHO
CHO BENEFITS
SO IT NOT ONLY REDUCES THE GHG
EMISSIONS. IN THE VALLEY BUT IT
ALSO.
.
IT ALSO.
WILL REDUCE THE AIR POLLUTION
ESPECIALLY. COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AT.
AFFECTED.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION IS HIGHLY
ALLERGIC TO.
OUR.
VIA USE OF GENERAL FUND
TYPICALLY
WHY IS THIS DIFFERENT.
WELL THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND.
BUT THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE.
WELL THAT WOULD. MAKE THAT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR JDRF.
THEY ALSO THE DEPARTMENT IS ALSO.
RECEIVING A HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION. IN JGR OTHERS THIS
DIAGRAM.
SO.
WHY?
REACH INTO GENERAL FUND AS
OPPOSED TO ALLOCATE. TO.
JDRF FUNDS.
MAYBE.
EITHER OF YOU CAN TAKE A STAB AT
THAT.
RIGHT THE ADDITIONAL WOULD TALK
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
I.
MATT ONLY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THAT KIND OF
THE MAY REVISION FRAMEWORK.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A LOT OF
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS ACROSS A
BROAD SERIES OF PROGRAMS THAT
INCLUDES DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
INCLUDES FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WILL BE
HEARING.
AND.
.
THIS PROGRAM IS ALSO AS.
MISS MERCYME A MENTION IT IS
ONE TIME MONEY AND SO.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
OVERALL FRAMEWORK OF HOW WE'RE
GONNA SPEND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR ONE TIME. TYPE PROGRAMS.
IN IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE.
ADMINISTRATION'S CLIMATE POLICY
GOALS.
AS WELL AS THE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS IN TERMS OF REDUCING
AIR POLLUTION IN AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. IT KINDA CHECKED
ALL THE BOXES FROM OUR OF INTO
EACH POINT.
SO I I I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
.
BECAUSE.
AT ON ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE OF
THE BUDGET HERE AND I'M SURE
THIS IS TRUE IN THE SENATE TO
WE'RE. TRYING TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ACHIEVE MUTUAL OUTCOMES.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE CRITERIA ARE FOR I'M
REACHING AND TO THE GENERAL FUND.
OF ONE KIND OR ARE WE TO HOW WE
WILL HOW ARE WE TO LOOK AT
GENERAL FUND MONEY IN THESE
MATTERS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE.
UP FOCUS ON A ONE TIME.
EXPENDITURES FOR PROGRAMS THAT
ACHIEVE US SOME OF THE.
BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERARCHING POLICY
GOALS RELATED TO.
VARIOUS ISSUES BUT CLIMATE
WOULD BE ONE OF THEM.
AS WELL AS.
.
PROGRAMS THAT ACHIEVE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS BEYOND CLIMATE SUCH AS.
.
HELPING.
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
ó IT WOULD.
THIS IS.
QUESTION THAT WOULD APPLY
OUTSIDE OF SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TOO BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE.
A POTENTIAL USE OF GENERAL FUND
MONEY CUTS ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS IN ALL THE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEES.
.
LET SAYS IF FOR SOME PUBLIC
COMMENT DEFICIENT.
DR.
ISSUES TWO AND THREE.
WE CAN DO THAT'S RIGHT WHAT I'M
I'M SORRY DE MINDED WAY FOR.
TRY TO BE CONSISTENT THANK YOU
I'M SORRY TO GET ISSUE NUMBER
THREE.
SIDETRACKED WITH THE GENERAL
FUND.
OKAY A SEPARATION THREE ADVANCE
PAY ON IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
BUSTERS BUDGET ACT AUTHORIZED
CARD TO MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
THIS PURPOSE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY WOULD AUTHORIZE
CARP TO MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS ON
A PERMANENT BASIS.
I'M ALL OF THE CONDITIONS THAT
EXISTED LAST YEAR THAT MAKE
ADVANCE PAIN NECESSARY STILL
EXISTS TODAY FOR THOSE PROJECTS.
I'M OUR GRANTEES OFTEN NEED
ACCESS TO CAPITAL TO TAKE ON
PROJECTS
I'M ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT WE
HAVE IS A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM GRANTS THAT WE HAVE
UNDER THE SIX ONE SEVEN. ON
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM
UNDIES TECHNICAL GRANTS PROVIDE
EDUCATION OUTREACH AND ALSO FINE
CITIZEN SCIENCE ON COMMUNITY
BASED MONITORING AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. ON
THE GRANTEES ARE SMALL AND NON
PROFITS THAT OFTEN DO NOT HAVE
THE UP FRONT RESOURCES TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM. UNLESS THEY CAN RECEIVE
UP BOND FUNDS UP FRONT. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS SMALL AIR DISTRICTS
ON SMALL I'M AIR DISTRICTS
IMPLEMENT ON THEIR THE ON TO
ROUND IMPLEMENTOR OF MANY. OF
OUR PROGRAMS ON SMALL DISTRICTS
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS LIKE
THE CLEAN SCHOOL BUS PROGRAM. IF
THEY CAN GET FUNDS UP FRONT.
I'M HAVING SPECIFIC AND
PERMANENT STATUTORY AUTHORITY
WOULD RELIEVE ANY CONFUSION
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO PAY IN
ADVANCE
ON THE PROPOSED STATUTORY
LANGUAGE INCLUDE SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE THAT ADVANCE PAY IS ONLY
PROVIDED TO GRANTEES IN GOOD
FINANCIAL STANDING. THAT
PROJECTS WILL BE SUCCESSFULLY
DELIVERED AND THAT IF THE
GRANTEE DOES NOT PERFORM THAT WE
CAN RECOVER THE UNSPENT FUNDS.
I'M THERE WILL ALSO BE
PROGRAMMATIC IN FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS IN THE GRANTS
THEMSELVES THAT SAFEGUARD THE
TAKE TAXPAYERS MONEY WITH REGARD
TO ADVANCE PAYMENT AND
SUCCESSFUL DELIVERY OF PROJECTS.
THANK YOU.
ALEJO NO CONCERNS BERMAN FINANCE.
NOW WE'LL HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS IS TWO OR THREE.
AND THEN THAT WHEN WE WERE DONE
LAST MISTER MONA FEWEST AT ON
THE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KNOW
WELL KRAMER'S OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION ON I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR QUICKLY
IMPLEMENTING THE FARMER PROGRAM
AND ALSO GIVE THEM A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR THEIR CREATIVITY IN
COMING UP WITH. THE ACRONYM
FARMER.
IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE. A.
ALTHOUGH THE ACRONYMS AND.
EQUIVALENT.
SO. UN.
THERE WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AND AN EXPLANATION AS TO WHY
FARMERS DON'T REPLACE THEIR
EQUIPMENT AND.
ON A A A REGULAR BASIS THEY
REALLY GET THE MOST THEY CAN OUT
OF THEIR TRACTORS AND TRUCKS.
AND DIESEL PUMPS AND SO THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL IN GETTING THEM TO
REPLACE.
BUT THOSE ENGINES IT WILL
BENEFIT NOT ONLY GREENHOUSE GAS
BUT ALSO CRITERIA POLLUTANTS.
AND I NO THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN NYC AND
EXPECT THAT THAT PROGRAM THE
CURRENT FUNDING WILL BE
OVERSUBSCRIBED IN AND THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY I GET CALLS AND EMAILS
DAILY FROM MY MEMBERS ASKING
ABOUT HOW.
TO APPLY FOR THIS PROGRAM AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE SOME AIR
DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS. AND SO THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AND I'M WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION NO AND
HE TO COME BEHALF OF WESTERN ART
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS IN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA TOMATO
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND VARIOUS
OTHER AG AGENCIES.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER TO ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM AND FOR
THESE I DIESEL ENGINE TRADE UPS.
AS FARM BUREAU SAID THIS IS
BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THROUGH THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM. AND WERE VERY POSITIVE
WITH THE FARMER PROGRAM IN THE
GUIDELINES BECAUSE ACTUALLY WE
THINK THAT MORE DIESEL ENGINES
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR FOR FUNDING.
WHICH IS A HUGE DEAL FOR FARMERS
WHO MAY ONLY USE THEIR TRACTOR
YOU KNOW THREE MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR FOR SPECIFIC THINGS SO.
TRADING THAT AND TRYING TO GET
THOSE BETTER QUALITIES IS A VERY
VERY BIG BEST MEN. AND FOR A LOT
OF SMALL AND EVEN MEDIUM SIZED
FARMERS THE COST OF TREATING UP
THOSE TRACTORS MAY NOT BE COST
EFFECTIVE AND THEY MAY DECIDE
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DO
THAT BUSINESS ANYMORE JUST
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF UPDATING
THEIR EQUIPMENT.
AND SO THIS FUNDING IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
.
AS WAS SAID TO YOU WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE FUNDING FROM LAST YEAR
THAT'S GOING TO GO OUT TO THE
FARMER PROGRAM IS ALREADY
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AND THAT WITH
THE FUNDING THROUGH THE GDR F.
PLAN PLUS THIS FUNDING TO THE
GENERAL FUND. WILL AGAIN BE OVER
PRESCRIBE BECAUSE THERE IS JUST
SO MUCH INTEREST IN USING THESE
PROGRAMS AND GETTING. THOSE.
EMISSION REDUCTIONS EXPRESSLY
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM UP ON BEHALF
OF THE AGRICULTURE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION
AND SUPPORTIVE ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
JUST ONE ECHO THEIR POINTS THAT
OUR COLLEAGUES MADE IN EMPHASIZE
HOW IMPORTANT THIS FUNDING IS
FOR OUR MEMBERS TO MEET THE
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS OF THE STATE
WHILE REMAINING COMPETITIVE WITH
OUR DOMESTIC AND GLOBAL PARTNERS
EXCUSE ME OUR DOMESTIC AND.
.
GLOBAL COMPETITORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
THROUGHLY UP A LITTLE MORE OF A.
COMMENT THAN A QUESTION A COUPLE
OF YEARS IT IS RELATED TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
WAS AT A MEETING IN OREGON.
WITH SOME OF ORGAN STATE
LEGISLATORS AND WE WERE.
BEING GOT COMPLEMENTED. ON OUR.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ONE STATED
CONCERN AND THAT IS THAT MANY OF
THE VEHICLES THAT WHERE.
TAKING OUT OF COMMISSION AND
CALIFORNIA.
AYE AND AND PARTICULARLY IT WAS
SAID DISCUSSED I THINK TO
DISCUSS WAS AROUND DIESEL
VEHICLES.
WERE ENDING UP ON THEIR
HIGHWAYS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BEING CRUSHED AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE ARE BEING RESOLD INTO AND
AND TO THE MARKET.
THIS IS A LONG TERM ISSUE THAT
I THINK.
WE NEED TO GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO
BECAUSE IT IT DEFINITELY IS A
POSITIVE THAT WE ARE.
CYCLING OUT OF.
THE DIRTIER VEHICLES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IF THEY REMAIN ON
THE ROAD THERE STILL
CONTRIBUTING TO.
A CARBON EMISSIONS SOMEWHERE
AND WILL GET FAR MORE BENEFIT IF
WE FIND A WAY TO TAKE THOSE
VEHICLES OUT OF COMMISSION.
ENTIRELY.
I'D ASK YOU TO. GIVE THIS SOME
THOUGHT AND DATA.
OF PERHAPS INCORPORATE SOME.
A WAY OF DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE
IN THAT ARE IN THE IN THE FUTURE.
NOW IF THAT DEFINITELY POINT
TAKEN THERE ARE SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS IN WHICH ON THE VEHICLE
THAT ARE THE ENGINE THAT IS
REPLACE HOUSE TO BE DESTROYED
AND THEIR HOUSE ACTUALLY BEAT
SORT OF A VISUAL INSPECTION TO
ENSURE THAT INVITE DRILL HOLES
THROUGH THE ENGINE BLOCKS AND
THINGS LIKE. THAT BUT DID
PROGRAMS YOU VERY SAID THAT IT
WILL BE THE POINT TAKEN IF
YOU'RE THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT AND FTA WITH THAT WILL MOVE
ON. TO OUR.
NEXT DATA.
SUBJECT AREA BEFORE BUT BEFORE
WE DO THAT WE'RE GONNA CALL VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR FOR ADD ONS.
AND WILL DO DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE CURRENT VOTE
FOUR ZERO.
MULLIN.
TALK SORRY.
ON THE.
I.
GREAT WE HAVE A UNANIMOUS VOTE
ON ALL OF THE VOTE ONLY COUNTERS
WITH A.
A MOTION AND A SECOND MADE.
BY THE GENTLEMAN TO MY LEFT AND
I THINK THAT'S A HISTORIC.
BIPARTISANSHIP AT ITS BEST
ABSOLUTELY.
WHO HAVE WILL CALL UP DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE ARE
PATIENTLY WAITING EFFORTS TO
STOP GIGGLING UP HERE?
IT'S GOOD TO GIGGLE BEFORE I
BRING UP THE MENTION OF THIS
REALLY NASTY CRITTER THAT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IN THE FIRST
BE CP THAT AS PART OF THE ACT.
MAY REVISE.
THIS IS FOR AND I I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISPRONOUNCE.
NUTRIA BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE A
FOOD SUPPLEMENTS MAY NOT A
RODENT BUT IT'S NUTRIA. OF THIS
IS IS A RODENT THAT ACTUALLY IS
CLASSIFIED AS AN EIGHT RATED
PASSED FOR THE DAMAGE THAT IT
CAN CAUSE TO GROW CROPS TO
ORCHARDS TO VINEYARDS INTO THE
FIELD INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT IT'S EQUALLY FRIGHTENING THE
DAMAGE THAT IT CAN TO TRY LEVY
SYSTEMS AND WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THIS GETS INTO THE SAN JOAQUIN.
DELTA WHICH IT'S A PERILOUSLY
CLOSE
ON THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND ONE POSITION.
FOR TWO YEARS IT'S LIMITED TERMS
SO THAT WE CAN AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE GET INTO THE FIELD TO
HELP WITH CERVANTES DETECTION
WORK TO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. TO ERADICATE NUTRIA.
WE'VE HAD EXPERIENCE WITH THAT'S
PASSED BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN
RECENT EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MOST RECENT EXPERIENCE ON A
NATIONAL BASIS WITH IN THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY. AND IT TOOK OVER
A DECADE FOR THEM TO ACHIEVE
ERADICATION OF THAT PASSED.
THIS WILL BE A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE'S THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
I HAVE WITH ME DEPUTY SECRETARY
KEVIN ASAHARA WHO'S BEEN IN
CLOSE COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
ON AND I AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
SOME MIGHT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO WE DON'T
HAVE IT TAKING ISSUE WITH THE
PROPOSAL IN CONCEPT TO DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
TO THE DEPARTMENT. WE GET
RESPONSES WILL COMMUNICATE ANY
CONCERNS WITH YOUR STAFF.
CARMEN FINANCE ANNIE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT YOU HAVE A.
SECOND ISSUE YES.
AND I.
WE'RE GONNA DO PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER THE.
FUTURES UP FOR THE SECOND ITEM
I HAVE WITH ME.
CHAIRMAN FEET OKAY SAYS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY PORT THAT CORRECTORS AND
HE'S ALSO THE CURRENT CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THE MAY REVISE ALSO INCLUDED
INCLUDED A ONE TIME REQUEST FOR
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
TO FUND THE PARTNERSHIPS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF IT SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING PLAN.
THAT PARTNERSHIP WAS CREATED
ALMOST TEN YEARS AGO.
AT A TIME WHERE THERE WAS
RECOGNITION OF THE SIGNIFICANT
POVERTY AND DISADVANTAGE.
COMMUNITY ISSUES AND THE NEED
FOR I'M TRYING TO DIVERSIFY THE
ECONOMY OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IT'S A UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP
IN THAT IT HAS EQUAL
REPRESENTATION FROM STATE
GOVERNMENT WITH SEVEN AGENCIES
REPRESENTED ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IT'S DONE AN OUTSTANDING
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT'S BASED
AROUND THE TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE OF
ECONOMIC VITALITY. ENVIRONMENTAL.
THAT A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
WHILE AGRICULTURE WILL ALWAYS
BE THE FOUNDATION AND THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY BY ADDING
MORE VALUE TO THE AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION IN THE VALLEY.
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING THAT AS
GROWTH IN THE STATE CONTINUES
COME INTO THE VALLEY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE FOCUS ON
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
HEALTHCARE AND AN EDUCATION
SYSTEM THAT WILL MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY CITIZEN IN THE VALLEY HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR GOOD JOBS IN
THE VALLEY.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN SOME EARLY
SUCCESSES AND HOW THE BALLY WITH
THESE EIGHT COUNTIES HAS BEEN
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER.
I TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
TO PRIORITIZE AND BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE COMPETITIVE PROCESS THAT
WAY.
IF IT'S OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A SUPERVISOR KEY SUCH MAKE
TO SEACM
COMMITMENTS YET WORSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR. SO THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY'S VERY
CHALLENGED BAY AREA TO SAY THE
LEAST AND THE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE RECESSION HIT US
HARDER. AND HAS BEEN SLOWER TO
RECOVER IN THAT AREA I CAN TELL
YOU THROUGH THESE COLLABORATIONS
BETWEEN THE EIGHT VALLEY
COUNTIES. ON TRANSPORTATION WE
TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE AIR
QUALITY WATER QUALITY IF
SOMEBODY WATER QUALITY ISSUES
ALONG WITH WATER QUANTITY ISSUES.
HIGH SPEED INTERNET FOR ALL
WHICH COMES THE EDUCATION
COMPONENT BUT WORKING TOGETHER
THAT THROUGH THE COLLABORATION
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY A
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE I FIVE THE
TRADE QUARTERS.
SOME CORTES AND STICKING
TOGETHER WE KNOW. AND WE KNOW
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF WE
STICK TOGETHER WE CAN MOVE
MOUNTAINS I SAY THAT ABOUT THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ALL THE TIME.
GLAD TO HAVE THE SECRETARY ON
BOARD SHE'S BEEN A STALWART
SUPPORTER OF THIS. AND AGAIN
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO THE THE RISING TIDE TO LIFT
ALL BOATS AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A. ONE TIME FUNDING AS WE
TRANSITION TO A NEW FUNDING
SOURCE.
THANK YOU.
ALEJO.
AT IT WITHOUT THEM PREJUDICE OF
THE MASS OF THE PROPOSAL IS JUST
ANCHOR TO US BY FINDING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO ENABLE
THAT CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP. FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY TO
DEVELOP A PERMANENT FUNDING PLAN
SHOULD SHOULD BE A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY. THAT INSTEAD OF
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBILITY ARE ARE I'VE.
NGOS WITHIN THE REGION APSA
ETCETERA JUST RECOMMENDING THAT
YOU WAY THIS GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AGAINST OTHER
GENERAL FUND.
PRIORITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU HAS A DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
JOHN FITZPATRICK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK.
FROM FINANCES PERSPECTIVE ONE
DYNAMIC ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT THE.
IN IN THE ABSENCE OF OF THE
PROVISION OF THESE FUNDS THE ON
GOING.
ADVOCACY OF THE.
OVERALL.
EFFORTS WOULD BE IMPACTED SO
THIS IS REALLY.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE SOMETHING
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
MAINTAIN.
EFFORTS AT THEIR CURRENT LEVELS
AND HAVE THE IMPACT IN THE
REGION THAT THEY'RE SEEKING.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
I HAVE ONE AND WE HAD A NICE A
AYE INTERCHANGE AROUND AND
EARLIER ACRONYM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
PRONOUNCE THIS ACRONYM FOR ME.
WHICH ONE NOT FARMERS CPS JV.
OF THE ONE THAT HAS ALSO VAL'S
YEAH THAT THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THIS ENVIRONMENT
HOW IT USED AND I ALWAYS START
OUT AND WALKING THE ALLEY ME
YEAH YEAH I CAN'T I CAN'T
PRONOUNCE IT BUT I CAN TELL YOU
WHAT IT'S TO AND THROUGH.
HUNDRED A HEAVY DEL. VALLE. I
THINK WE SHOULD RENAME ITS OF
QUEBEC'S.
WHO WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THAT?
VIA TO.
DF A.
ITEMS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF THE GRASS
AND WATER DISTRICT WERE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE.
FIRST PROPOSAL THE REQUEST TO
DEAL WITH THE INVASIVE PESTS
NUTRIA. I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THOUGH THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME TIGHTER. COORDINATION
BETWEEN.
CDFA IN CDF W. AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S ALREADY OCCURRING BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE MAP WHERE THE
IDENTIFIED SIGHTINGS AND
CAPTURES OF TAKING PLACE. MANY
OF THEM ARE CARRYING IN THE
GRASS AND ECOLOGICAL AREA WHICH
IS A SEASONAL WETLAND THAT IS
MANAGED FOR BOTH A SUMMER AND
FALL WETLANDS AND THAT'S EXACTLY
THE TYPE OF HABITAT WHERE THIS
AQUATIC RODENT LIKES TO HANG OUT
SO. WELL WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE IMPACT TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY WE'D LIKE
CITY OF W'S FULL PARTICIPATION
IN ENNIS IN ASSESSING.
IMPACTS ON BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE WETLANDS AQUATIC HABITAT
CENTER LOCATED THERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE A MAJORITY
OF THE SIGHTINGS ARE ACTUALLY
TAKING PLACE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ROBERT GORE FROM
THE WITH A LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY. WHERE WE THINK
OF NUTRIA NOT AS A NUTRITIONAL
SUPPLEMENT BUT AS A AS A
VELOCIRAPTOR?
AND AND. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE SECOND ITEM ON
BEHALF OF THE WEST HILLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
THE CAMPUS IS IN COALINGA WILL
MOURN FIREBAUGH WHERE OUR
STUDENT BODIES TWO THIRDS
DISADVANTAGED AND IN DIRE NEED
OF CONTINUING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE SMALL
APPROPRIATION TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM GOING THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BOB READ WITH REAP
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTED THE NUTRIA REQUEST.
IS GOING TO BE A VERY BAD
SITUATION WITH RESPECT TO. THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR LEVEE SYSTEMS.
IF THIS SITE. ALLOWED TO PLAY
FOR RATE.
THANK YOU.
DIRECTOR ROSS SAM.
THE AT THE.
.
ISSUE WAS RAISED.
AROUND COORDINATION OF.
CDF FANCY THE F. W..
.
YEAH IS THAT SOMETHING THAT IS
OCCURRING NOW OR THAT IT IT IS
KIND AND FLAG DFW IS THE LEAD.
THEY ARE VERY MUCH WANTED TO
HAVE OUR PARTICIPATION BECAUSE
WE HAVE ACCESS TO PRIVATE LANDS
TO MAKE SURE.
PASSED WE KNOW TO NOT RESPECT
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
CLOSELY. A COORDINATED EFFORT
THAT HAS STARTED SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO. AREN'T THEY THEY ARE THE
LEAD AGENCY BUT OUR ABILITY TO
BE IN PLACES WHERE THEY CAN'T BE
FOR SURVEY AND DETECTION WORK
WILL FEED DIRECTLY INTO THEM.
SO I I DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THAT UNLESS THERE'S
SOMETHING SPECIFIC THAT.
ACROSS LANCE'S.
ACOSTA.
IF IT HELPS THIS THING'S BEEN
UNFOLDING VERY QUICKLY YOU KNOW
AND THAT'S WHY WE PUT IT INTO
THE MAY REVISE. ON BUT AS OF
YESTERDAY WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS AND WE HAVE A
MEETING SCHEDULED WITH CDF W..
TO JUST BASICALLY COORDINATE
WHERE WE'RE AT AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS BUT ALSO TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY NEXT STEPS ON OUR
COLLABORATION OUR COMMUNICATIONS
PLAN. AND THEY HAVE AN INCIDENT
COMMAND SYSTEM SET UP THAT'S
MORE TACTICAL DATA DATA DEAL
WITH THE PASSED OUT IN THE FIELD
WILL DEFINITELY WE ARE PLUGGED
INTO THAT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PLUGGED INTO THAT. BUT OUR
INTENTION GOING FORWARD IS TO
SET UP AN EXECUTIVE STRUCTURE SO
THAT THE TWO AGENCIES CAN
COMMUNICATE ON A CONSISTENT
BASIS GOING FORWARD. SO THAT
BOTH OF OUR EFFORTS ARE
COORDINATED AND THAT IS TO GET RID OF THIS
THING.
AND I I WOULD ASK YOU TO.
ALSO CONFER WITH STAKEHOLDERS
SAID.
SO THAT JUROR AND BEING CERTAIN
THAT YOU HAVE THEIR INPUT AND TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR CONCERNS
MIGHT BE YES WE DO HAVE IS A
ROBUST UP PROGRAM AS POSSIBLE.
AT AS AS YOU SAY THE.
OF THE PAST ISN'T IT.
EXISTING ONE PLACE OR ANOTHER
JUSTICE GOING BECAUSE. OF BACK
AND FORTH FREELY AND THE SOUNDS
LIKE A PRETTY SERIOUS ISSUE THAT
WILL BENEFIT TO A.
OF BOTH AGRICULTURAL LAND IN
OUR.
.
OTHER. WELL THERE IS.
YESTERDAY WE HAD A NEW TREE
HEARING THE SENATE AG COMMITTEE
AND.
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR FROM THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY PROJECT FLEW OUT
HERE TO PRESENT SOME INFORMATION
AND THEN AFTERWARDS WE MET FOR
ABOUT TWO HOURS AND DISCUSSED
WITH HIM SOME OF THE CHALLENGES.
AND THAT WAS ONE THING HE
MENTIONED TO US WAS STAKEHOLDER
OUTREACH AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO A VERY GOOD EFFORT NATTEN
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER SO THAT
EVERYBODY HAS A COMMON PURPOSE
AND WHAT THE RULES ARE IN THE
EFFORT.
THANK YOU.
WE.
APPRECIATE PRESENTATIONS AND
WILL MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION NOW
WE HAVE FOR.
THREE ISSUES
.
WELCOME BACK THANK YOU.
PLEASE WE'RE GONNA TRY AND PICK
UP THE PACE HERE A LITTLE BIT TO.
.
NOT ANYBODY'S FAULT I PROBABLY
THAN ASKING TOO MANY QUESTIONS.
AND MAKING TOO MANY COMMENTS.
BUT TO WENT BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER SIX.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU AND
YES I CAN TAKE THE HINT TO MOVE
ALONG SWIFTLY AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO DO THAT JACK KEMP HIM WHAT
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE. ARE AND
WITH ME IS OUR STATE FIRE
MARSHAL DENNIS MATHESON.
I ISSUE NUMBER SIX CAL FIRE IN
THE MAY REVISION REQUEST TEN
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FIFTY TWO POSITIONS STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
PROVIDE. HEAVY EQUIPMENT
MECHANICS VEHICLE MAINTENANCE
FUNDING AND ASSOCIATED
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT STAFF.
WELL AS YOU KNOW TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WAS.
UNPRECEDENTED.
FIRE SEASON IN CALIFORNIA AND.
WAS REALLY A CONTINUATION OF
WHAT'S BECOME THE NEW NORMAL IN
TERMS OF ELEVATED FIRE
CONDITIONS IN ACTIVITY. ARE AT
THE END OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN.
CAL FIRES FIRE ENGINES WERE
STILL ACTIVELY BEING MOVED
AROUND THE STATE IN ACTIVE FIRE
SUPPRESSION OR MOVING IN
COVERING FIRE STATIONS ALL OVER
THE STATE.
WE WERE NOT ABLE AND DID NOT
HAVE THE STAFF TO KEEP THOSE
VEHICLES MAINTAINED.
AND FOUND OURSELVES SIGNIFICANT
BEHIND IN MAINTENANCE AS WE NOW
ENTER INTO THE NEW FIRE SEASON
SO THE VEHICLE MAINTENANCE AND
AND TWENTY FIVE HEAVY EQUIPMENT
MECHANICS AS PART OF THAT
REQUEST. ARE SIGNIFICANT NOW IN
NEED OUGHT TO SUPPORT OUR BILLY
TO KEEP UP WITH THE NEW A
WORKLOAD. UP THE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT POSITIONS
ARE MOSTLY A CONTINUATION OF OUR
CAL CARD SUPPORT POSITIONS THAT
WERE FUNDED THROUGH. OTHER
DROUGHT AUGMENTATION I'M THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE TWENTY ONE
POSITIONS.
THAT WERE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY TEN BUDGET PROPOSAL
THOSE POSITIONS WERE TO MEET THE
INCREASING WORKLOAD AND DEMAND A
DAY TO DAY BUSINESS.
IN CAL FIRE TO PROCESS.
REGULAR I ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD IN DOCUMENTS THAT THESE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ARE
CRITICAL WE HAVE ALMOST ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN INVOICE IS
BEING PROCESS JUST FROM LAST
YEAR. OF THIS IS TO PAY ALMOST A
THOUSAND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THE COUNTY OF KERN WHICH JUST
HAD TO TAKE OUT A LOAN TO MEET
PAYROLL WHILE THEY WAITED FOR
CAL FIRE.
AND OTHER ENTITIES TO REIMBURSE
THEM FOR ALL THE RESOURCES THEY
SENT OUT OF COUNTY. TO SUPPORT
US SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR ABILITY TO
PAY OUR BILLS AND SUPPORT. OTHER
OPERATIONS GOING ON.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS WE MEET TO THIS NEW
CHALLENGE THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
THE ONGOING CHALLENGE. OF FOR
CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE.
LET'S HEAR FROM THE OHIO THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF ASH SCENES
OF THE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE DID LOOK OVER THOSE WE JUST
HAVE FROM SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS. IN THE
WORKLOAD JUSTIFICATION FOR THEM
OF THEY HAVE PROVIDED US SOME
INFORMATION BACK WITHOUT AND
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY REVIEWING
AND WHAT IF THE COMMITTEE AS WE.
LOOK FARTHER.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE
NOTHING. ISSUE NUMBER.
.
SEVEN.
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AT YOUR BLOOM IN
THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO MY
NAME'S DENNIS MATHESON YOUR
STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
THIS PROPOSAL STEMS FROM AN
ONGOING MISSION BASED REVIEW THE
DEPARTMENT A FINANCES PERFORMING
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL.
SPECIFICALLY THEIR.
WE'VE EXAMINED ALL OF THE
WORKLOAD AND CAPACITY OF OUR
FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY DIVISION
OUT TO MEET OUR MISSION TODAY IN
AND OUT ON INTO THE FUTURE.
SO AT THIS POINT CAL FIRE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S
REQUESTING APPROVAL OF AN
INCREASE.
OF OF FOUR MILLION A.
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY AND
FIFTEEN POSITIONS TO SUPPORT OUR
FIRE LIFE SAFETY DIVISIONS
INCREASED WORKLOAD. RELATED STE
ADD TO ITS PLANNER VIEW.
DESTRUCTION INSPECTIONS AND
MANDATED PERIODIC INSPECTION
ACTIVITIES.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE WE
WILL PROVIDE THE MUCH NEEDED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS
IDENTIFIED BY THE MISSION BASED.
REVIEW PROCESS
TO SUPPORT CURRENT AND FUTURE.
WORKLOAD FOR THE FIRELIGHT
SAFETY DIVISION.
WITHIN OUR OFFICE AT THIS TIME
I'D BE UP HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SEEN NONE LA THOUGH WE
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS THANK YOU
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS.
LET'S IT MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT FIREWORKS PROGRAM.
IT'S BEEN LONG IN THE.
IN THE MAKING.
YES IT HAS.
.
WHEN I WAS AYE I WAS FIRST
APPOINTED STATE FARM MARSHALL
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO.
I REALIZE THAT THIS.
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING A LONG TERM
I ISSUE. AND.
WE'RE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND SIT DOWN AND.
TO.
WORK OUT A SOLUTION
SO THE PROBLEM OR QUICK.
USE AND SALE OF ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS TO SKYROCKET IN
CALIFORNIA.
FUNDING FOR ENFORCEMENT
EDUCATION.
IN DISPOSAL HAS BEEN INADEQUATE.
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT OF.
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS HAS TO
CONTINUE DISH BEEN A CONTINUE
ISSUE THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ARE
REQUIRING A MAJOR OVERHAUL OF
HOW CAL FIRE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. ADDRESSES AND
DISPOSES OF DANGEROUS AND
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS.
EACH YEAR TO GIVE ME AN IDEA OF
THE CAPACITY OR THE VOLUME.
THAT WE DEAL WITH EACH YEAR.
WE.
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE.
AT THE SEIZURE OF APPROXIMATELY
OR IN EXCESS OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND POUNDS.
OF.
SEIZED ILLEGAL AND DANGEROUS
FIREWORKS STATEWIDE.
WITHOUT A STABLE FUNDING SOURCE.
FOR DISPOSAL THE CONFISCATION
OF ILLEGAL AND DANGEROUS
FIREWORKS.
HAS CREATED SIGNIFICANT IT.
HAZARD TO THE ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE SOLUTION.
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED OF FOR
THEY A IN A ADDRESSES INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC EDUCATION AS
WELL AS FUNDING FOR DISPOSAL.
DEVELOPED THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
COORDINATED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE A IN INCLUDED SEVERAL
STAKEHOLDERS THE FIREWORKS IN
HIS INDUSTRY. CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES
CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
CORRESPONDING A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
WILL CREATE A NEW RELIABLE
FUNDING MODEL INVOLVING A
NONPROFIT FIREWORKS STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION WHICH WILL PARTNER
WITH THE THE OFFICE OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. TO MANAGE SEIZE
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE FIREWORKS
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS. THIS WORKS BY
ALLOWING THE FIREWORKS INDUSTRY
TO REPURPOSE COMMERCIALLY VIABLE
OF FIREWORKS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS REDUCES THE VOLUME OF
REMAINING SEIZE FIREWORKS TO TO
BE DISPOSED OF AS HAZARDOUS
WASTE THEREBY RE REDUCING COSTS.
FOR THAT DISPOSAL ULTIMATELY.
OUR GOAL.
WITH THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS
SAID TO PROVIDE A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE A FUNDING SOURCE TO
SUPPORT THIS.
OUR ARMED ARE MANDATORY
OBLIGATIONS RELATED TO ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS.
I REDUCE UP POTENTIAL RISK THE
PUBLIC AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS ENTERING THE STATE.
A PROVIDE A STABLE FUNDING
SOURCE TO SUPPORT.
OUR EFFORTS IN IRAQ TO KEATING
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
AND DEALING WITH DISPOSAL.
SUPPORTING LOCAL FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE IN
THEIR ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
AND PROVIDE A ROBUST PUBLIC
EDUCATION SAFETY CAMPAIGN.
SO WITH THAT SAID CALL FOR
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
IS REQUESTING APPROVAL OF ONE
TIME FINDING A THREE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE OR. YEP PLATE FUND FOR
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ONLY.
TWO ONGOING POSITIONS TO OVERSEE
THE PROPOSED FIREWORKS
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM INCLUDING.
INCREASING THE STATE'S.
ABILITY TO REDUCE THE INFLUX OF
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS.
ONGOING FIREWORKS FUND
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY OF TWO
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS DOLLAR
STARTING IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY.
AND LASTLY OUT TO THE ADOPTION
OF NECESSARY TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SHUT TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
QUESTION JUST BONTA.
OF THEM AND MAYBE THE LA OKAY
AND CAN ANSWER THIS AND AND IN
HER COMMENTS BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF THE PROP
FORTY SIX APPLICATIONS.
A VOICE EXCITE BOMB.
IN TERMS OF THEM MANAGEMENT
CHARGE OR THE FEE OR THE LOBBY
Y. COLLEGE THAT TAX IN TERMS OF
WENT ON ON FIREWORKS.
DOES THIS TRAILER BILL REQUIRE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
.
AND OUR AIR THEREFORE IF NOT HOW
DO HOW THEN DOES THIS CHARGE OR
FEE OR TAX GET IMPLEMENT.
STEVEN BENSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO
LOOK INTO THAT OUR INITIAL
ASSESSMENT OF THE PACKAGES IS
PUT TOGETHER WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT E WE
BELIEVE THAT IT FITS THE DEFEAT
DEFINITION. BUT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S KIND OF AN AGREEMENT ON
THAT. IF THERE'S PIVOTS NEEDED
THEN YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY
TALKED CERTAIN SO JUST TO
CLARIFY IF IF IT DOES FIT THE
FEE DEFINITION THEN PROP TWENTY
SIX DOES REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS
VOTE ON THIS WOULD THIS.
BUDGET TRAILER WOULD THEN BE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
IF IT DOESN'T FIT A FEE IF IF IT
NEEDS TO BE A TAX LIKE A THIRD
IF PEOPLE CONCLUDED ATTACKS AND
SUPPOSED TO FEEL THAT IT WOULD
NEED A TWO THIRDS.
ARE ASSESSMENT WAS THAT IT FIT
THE BILL OF THE FEE AND DIDN'T
NEED A TWO THIRDS BUT WORKS THAT
WERE STILL HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH OTHERS.
ABOUT THAT MATTER FOCUS OF SO
IT'S STILL UNCLEAR.
THERE'S STILL SOME CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON ADMINISTRATION FELT
LIKE IT WAS.
WE'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES
OBVIOUSLY INVOLVED IN THE
GETTING THEIR PROPOSAL PUT
TOGETHER SO WE'RE TALKING TO
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY AGREE AND WE GET
CONSENSUS AROUND THAT SO THAT IN
TERMS OF I IF I COULD ASK THAT.
THE ASCAP ARE HOW DOES THIS.
REVENUE BUT AS A GUESS AT HOW
DOES THIS.
.
CHARGE GET ASSESS.
THE THE CONCEPT IS THE THE.
THE STEWARDSHIP ENTITY ITSELF
WHICH IS SOME MADE UP OF.
THE MEMBERS OF THE FIREWORKS
AND.
INDUSTRY ASSESSES IT ITSELF.
A FEE THAT IT DETERMINES IS
APPROPRIATE TO TO REIMBURSE OUR
COST TO.
TO.
IN TO CONDUCT FOR ENFORCEMENT
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND AND
DISPOSAL.
SO THE THE REVENUES.
FROM THE MANAGEMENT FEE.
DO NOT COME TO THE STATE THEY
GO TO THE STEWARDSHIP.
PROGRAM WHICH THEY ASSESS
THEMSELVES.
AND AND THEN THAT MONEY THEN WE
GET GO TO REIMBURSE THE STATE.
CORRECT OR ARE COSTS FOR.
FIRED DEALING WITH ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS ISSUE.
DOES THE FEE SHOW UP IN THE
POINT OF PURCHASE TRANSACTION
WITH PEOPLE WHO BUY ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
WOULD WORK ISN'T THAT A TAX.
I DON'T KNOW OUR INITIAL AS
MISTER BENSON MENTION OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT WAS SET.
ASIDE THIS GENTLEMAN IS THE FIRE
MARSHAL NOT DEAD LEGAL ANALYST
IF EXCEPT I DON'T THINK IT'S
QUITE A FAIR QUESTION TO ASK.
CLUE MAKE CLUE YET ON THAT AND
I'LL JUST REITERATE WHAT MISTER
BENSON SAID IS IS THE IN OUR
INITIAL ASSESSMENT AS WE SAT
DOWN WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. WAS
AT THIS SUMMIT THE TO THE
DEFINITION OF A OF A FEE.
AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THAT'S
NOT THE CASE THEN OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD WE WOULD GO THE
APPROPRIATE ROUTE TO. ADDRESS IT.
I AGAIN I.
WASN'T.
THAT I THINK PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY HERE IS TO FIND
OUT PRECISELY WHAT THE
TRANSACTION IS.
AT THE TRANSACTION IS IMPOSED ON
A POINT OF SALE TO CONSUMERS OF
LEGAL FIREWORKS IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IS A.
SELF EVIDENT TAX.
SO I I DID.
FORGIVE THE QUESTION IT'S A
COMMENT.
.
WITH RESPECT TO GET AYE CURE.
CORRECTLY THAT.
I FEEL IT.
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NOT.
ALWAYS ILLEGAL IN OTHER STATES.
IS THERE A COLLECTION.
OF THOSE ILLEGAL CALIFORNIA FIRE
WORKS.
AND THEN.
WHAT?
PROVIDED FOR A THE A MARKET FOR
THOSE LEGAL FIREWORKS IN SOME
OTHER STATE WITH RESPECT I WHAT
I HEAR WITH RESPECT TO HOW.
LEGAL FIREWORKS
OTHER PLACES THAT ARE COLLECTED
IN CALIFORNIA ARE MANAGED TO
HELP REDUCE THE LOAD.
SO AT AT THIS MOMENT UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ALL FIREWORKS THAT ARE SEIZED
BY.
ANYBODY WHETHER IT'S LOCAL FIRE.
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR OR THE
STATE. THAT IS CONSIDERED A
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND THEREFORE
MUST BE DISPOSED OF.
AS SUCH AND SO THAT IS THAT IS
THE PROCESS TODAY AND IT IT IS
QUITE EXPENSIVE.
AND SO WHAT THIS.
A PROGRAM ATTEMPTS TO ESTABLISH
IS A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE.
WITH THE STEWARDSHIP OF
ORGANIZATION.
THE INDUSTRY TO ALLOW FOR RE
PURPOSING OF THAT COMMERCIALLY
VIABLE.
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS IN CALIFORNIA
SO THEY CAN BE REPURPOSED AND
OTHER STATES WHERE THEY MAY BE
LEGAL.
AND THAT THAT THE THE IT DOES
NOT THAT LOCK THEM UP AND SENATE
OTHER STATES ARE YOU GOING TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT.
PRODUCT IN STATE TO MAKE.
SAFE FIREWORKS OR LEGAL
FIREWORKS IN CALIFORNIA I'M I'M
GONNA KNOW WHAT DEFINED WE
PURPOSING REPURPOSE IN WOULD BE
THE THE STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION
WOULD TAKE WHAT IS WHAT WOULD
BE LEGALLY.
CAPABLE SELLING AND ON THE
OTHER STATES
A AND DOING THAT SO THEY WOULD
TAKE IT OUT OF THE STATE AND
SELL IT IN ANOTHER STATE AND
THAT HELPS US REDUCE OUR COSTS.
TO DISPOSE WHAT'S LEFT.
MISTER MULLIN.
SO YOU'RE TAKING STUFF THAT'S
ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALLOWING IT TO ACROSS STATE
LINES AND THEN BE USED ELSEWHERE.
ALRIGHT.
YES.
YEAH.
.
SO.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT LIBYA PLAN
WITH STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO REDUCE THE VOLUME
OF ILLEGAL FIREWORKS ENTERING
CALIFORNIA CAN GIVE ME A SENSE
OF.
IS HOW THAT MIGHT BE DONE I MEAN
MOST OF THIS ENFORCEMENT STUN.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT.
HOW CAN YOU GIVE ME?
IF YOU EXAMPLES OF HOW WE MIGHT
COMBAT THIS PROBLEM OF ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS I PERSONALLY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH FIREWORKS SO. I'M
JUST TRYING TO. UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA GET FOR FOR
THIS MONEY HERE HOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE A REDUCING
THE VOLUME OF ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
IN THE STATE AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT CROSS
STATE ISSUE? CHAIR OF THE TIME.
SO THEIR.
ON GOING FOR YEARS.
THERE ARE LOCAL REGIONAL.
.
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS THROUGH
LOCAL TASK FORCES.
TO TO ADDRESS ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
A PROBLEM SO I DON'T IDENTIFY
HOW WHAT'S COMING IN.
AND ALL THE WAY UP TO SEIZING
IT AND AND.
DEALING WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
SIDE HAVE BROADBAND OR SELLING
IT.
LA LOT OF THAT ACTIVITY HAS
WANED.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT MY
OFFICE NO DOES NOT HAVE THE
FUNDING.
TO.
COLLECT THE CEASEFIRE WORKS AND
DEAL AND PROPERLY DISPOSE OF IT.
I IN FACT.
IN A MEETING I WAS I HAD.
WITH SOME OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIRE.
BLOOM INDIVIDUALS.
MADE THE COMMENT THAT THEY WERE
REDUCING THEIR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
DID NOT WANT TO BE STUCK WITH
THE SEIZED
FIREWORKS SO TO ME THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
AND SO.
OUR OUR.
THAT THE
THE VISION.
WITH THIS PROGRAM IS THAT.
WE.
AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
FACILITATE.
EIGHT.
TASK FORCE.
THAT INVOLVES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
STATE AGENCIES.
AND WE WE WORK TOWARDS
SUPPORTING THOSE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL EFFORTS
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT CONDUCTING INTERDICTION
ACTIVITIES AT THAT STATE LINE.
BETWEEN.
NEVADA AND CALIFORNIA AS AN
EXAMPLE.
WORKING IN.
PORTS.
WITH THOSE THOSE LOCAL ENTITIES.
WHICH ARE ALSO ENTRY.
MODES.
INTO CALIFORNIA SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
VENUES AND AND METHODS THAT THE
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS AND HER.
DOES LOCAL AGENCIES ARE NO BASS
THIRTIES TOO USED TO IT. AND WE
WERE LEVERAGE.
THAT THE THE THE THE POWER OF
OF ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER
AND THE FUNDING THAT COMES WITH
THIS PROGRAM. TO ASSIST.
IN THOSE EFFORTS.
THERE BE A PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT HERE I'M SURE THERE
ARE YEARS WITH REGARD TO IMPACT
ON PAT'S AND SO FORTH WITH WITH
FIREWORKS AND.
.
EDUCATION AROUND HOW TO PROTECT
PET STE.
THE FOURTH OF JULY THOSE KINDS
OF ACTIVITIES.
YEAH YEAH I THINK WE CAN DO
BETTER BE HONEST WITH YOU.
I WAS A LOCAL FIRE MARSHAL FOR
MOST OF MY CAREER.
AND IN SO I RECOGNIZE THOSE.
THOSE ISSUES ARE FROM A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT I THINK WE.
MY VISION.
WITH WITH A UTILIZING SOME F
THIS FUNDING IS TO CREATE A
ROBERT A ROBUST PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN THAT WE CAN.
REACH EVERY.
INDIVIDUAL IN THE STATE TO
ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE HOW TO
PROTECT YOUR PETS WHAT'S LEGAL
WHAT'S NOT LEGAL IN YOUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
LA ODF COMMENTS YES THANK YOU.
.
WE WE AGREE THAT THIS IS A.
ADDRESSES A PROGRAMMATIC
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE
FOR SOME TIME.
BUT WE DO THINK IT COMING IN
THE MAY REVISION.
AND CREATING AN ENTIRELY NEW
PROGRAM A NEW FUNDING STREAM.
.
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO
WASTE ON THE MERITS OF THIS
APPROACH VERSUS OTHERS OBVIOUSLY
COMPLICATED AND THERE'S NOT
SAYING QUESTIONS ABOUT EXACTLY
HOW IT WOULD WORK.
AND SO WE THINK THE MY OWN
HOUSE THE DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW
WHY THEY THINK THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF A NEW PROGRAM SHOULD BE DONE
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AND AT
THIS. POINT IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
AND ALSO ONE ALTERNATIVE.
APPROACHES WERE CONSIDERED AND
WHY THIS ONE WAS WAS THE BEST
ONE IN THEIR VIEW.
THANK YOU ANEMIA ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
FONG I KNOW I'D PARA FINANCE S.
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT DO YOU
DOES ELIA HAVE ANALYSIS ON PROP
TWENTY SIX.
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
ANALYZE SPECIFICALLY WITH
REGARDS WITH WITH MAKING BUT
CERTAINLY LOOK OUT AND AND INTO
THEIR STUFF UP.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES
A SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT.
OF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RUSSELL NO ACT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN.
NEGOTIATING AND IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE THEIR
APARTMENT AND THE.
FIRE MARSHAL FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS AND THIS IS A.
AN APPROPRIATE SOLUTION AT THIS
TIME TO DEAL WITH SEIZURE
STORAGE AND DISPOSAL.
OF THIS MATERIAL.
WERE PROBABLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS I'M AARON
EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE ALSO HERE
TO COMMENT ON THE THIRD ITEMS%
FIREWORKS PROPOSAL. I'M ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
I'M AS YOU'VE HEARD IT'S A MUCH
NEEDED SOLUTION TO A LONG
STANDING PROBLEM AND WE SUPPORT
IT THANK YOU.
OTHER MATH BENDER DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM SEVEN THE STAFFING
AUGMENTATION FOR THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL PORTENT TO US THAT THEY
HAVE THOSE STAFF THAT THEY NEED
TO.
CONDUCTED A PLAN REVIEWS AND
INSPECTIONS IN A TIMELY MANNER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ON IT HAS BEEN I THINK
AND.
SEVERAL YEARS SINCE THIS FOR A
ISSUE FIRST DATA OF SURFACED AT
AT SUB THREE WITH RESPECT TO OF.
DISPOSAL OF FIREWORKS IN FACT I
REMEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
ASKING A LONG SERIES OF
QUESTIONS THAT THE LAST TIME
THAT IT THAT IT CAME UP AND.
.
IT'S
OUR OBVIOUSLY BEEN. A STRUGGLE
AND IT DIFFICULT COMPLEX ISSUE
OF FOR YOU TO COME UP WITH A
RESOLUTION AROUND I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE WORK IT MUST HAVE
TAKEN TO BRING ALL THOSE.
STAKEHOLDERS AROUND THE A THE
TABLE AND COME UP WITH A
RESOLUTION I WANTED I THINK THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
AS AS WELL FOR THEM FOR THEIR
EFFORTS IN THE.
GOTTA BRING THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD.
THANK YOU A THANK YOU FOR THAT I
ALSO WANTED A QUICKLY COMMENT
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT TO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
AND FOR PROTECTION ITEM A THERE
WAS AN ITEM ON THE.
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR FUNDING FOR
TWELVE HELICOPTERS THAT.
ALSO IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME AS
A DIRECTOR PIMLOTT TOES I'VE
BEEN. OF PUSHING AND PUSHING AND
PUSHING TO.
ACCELERATE THE PROGRAM FOR
ACQUISITION OF FOR HELICOPTER SO
THAT WE COULD REPLACE OUR OUR
FLEET NYSSA A COMMITTEE HAS SIR
A HAS ASKED FOR THAT I'M.
GRATIFIED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF.
A COME TOGETHER AROUND A
PROPOSAL THAT NOT ONLY GETS THE
PROGRAM STARTED BUT.
ENVISIONS.
ACQUIRING THOSE DOZEN
HELICOPTERS OVERHEAD ITSELF FOR
ERA TIME FRAMES THAT RIGHT.
SO THAT WILL A COMPLETELY OF
REPLACE THE CURRENT VIETNAM.
OF VINTAGE HELICOPTERS THAT ARE
RUNNING OUT OF SPARE PARTS.
AND THEY CAN'T FLY AT NIGHT
HAVE OTHER LIMITATIONS AND THE
THAT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE
OUR ABILITY TO. FIGHT FIRES IN
THE STATE MISTER PATTERSON
ADVOCATE PIGGYBACK ON THAT.
.
THE SOONER THE BETTER WE WE WE
GET THAT AIR FLEET.
MODERNIZED OBVIOUSLY.
I'M.
WOULD THESE.
BEN AND THE OTHER THING IS THE
HELICOPTER YOU CHOSE.
IS A SUPERB MACHINE.
I'M ARE WITH RESPECT TO. WILL
THE WILL THESE ASSETS BE.
PRE POSITIONED.
IN IN IN NEW OR DIFFERENT WAYS
GIVEN THE STUD SORT OF THE NEW
REALITY OF OF OUR FIRES WHERE
WHERE WILL THEY BE STATIONED AT
HOW WILL THEY BE.
PRE POSITIONED IT IN AN EFFORT.
TO GET UP IN THE AIR QUICKLY AND
GET TO THE FIRES.
CLOSE PROXIMITY WITH THE AIR
POWER.
VERY GOOD QUESTION I'M HELLFIRE
HAS AN EXISTING TEN.
HELLA TECH BASIS SPREAD ACROSS
CALIFORNIA NEAR VERY STRATEGIC
AND WHERE THEY REPLACED
ORIGINALLY BASED ON THAT THE U.
H. WHEN HUEY'S. UP YOUR INTENT
IS TO PUT THEM IN THOSE
LOCATIONS BUT THEY'VE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE BUT CERTAINLY WITH
THIS NEW A PLATFORMER CONTINUE
TO REEVALUATE.
WE HAVEN'T YOU HAD THIS
PLATFORM BEFORE IT WAS IT WAS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY WITH YOU KNOW
MAYBE FASTER FLIGHT TIMES IN
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES. THAT WERE
ABLE TO MAYBE LOOK AT SOME OF
THAT BUT IT BUT WE HAVE TEN VERY
EFFECTIVE TELETECH BASES WILL BE
LOOKING AT UPGRADES TO THOSE.
THROUGH THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROCESS UP BUT WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT MOVING FORWARD.
WITH IMPLEMENTING ND AS WE
SPEAK WE'RE PREPARING THAT TO
MAKE THE FIRST REQUIREMENT
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW WE ARE
BUDGETED.
IN THE CURRENT. YEAR AFTER THAT
FIRST PLATFORM AND SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO BE MOVING FORWARD AS
WE STUDY. THAT SO THAT THERE IS
THEY'VE THERE WILL BE OVER TIME
A. CONSIDERATION OF PERHAPS
REPOSITIONING.
A IF
THE BUT FOR EXAMPLE IF IF IF
URBAN AREAS ARE IN MUCH MORE.
SIGNIFICANT.
DANGER.
.
WHAT WOULD THERE BE OTHER?
MORE URBAN OUR CLOSE PROXIMITY.
.
AT AIRPORTS.
TO PLACE THEM I I THOUGHT I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT THAT'S A THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
THE POSSIBILITY OF.
OF POSITIONING WITH RESPECT TO
THE NEW CHALLENGES THAT WE AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE NEW.
PLATFORM PROVIDES IT WHAT WERE
ALWAYS EVALUATING NOT JUST WHERE
ARE AYE AVIATION ASSETS ARE WERE
ALL OF OUR ASSETS ARE AS. WELL.
URBANIZATION CHANGES AS FIRE
THREATENING MISSION DENSITY
CHANGE WERE ALWAYS REEVALUATING.
OUT WHERE YOU KNOW OUR LOCATE
OUR ASSETS ARE LOCATED WILL
CERTAINLY CONSIDER THAT.
WITH THE HELICOPTERS AS WELL
BUT AS I SAID RIGHT NOW WE'VE
GOT TEN VERY EFFECTIVE. HOW
ATTACK BASES IN IT WILL CONTINUE
TO TO UTILIZE THOSE BUT
REEVALUATE BUT AS WE GO FORWARD
TO IMPLEMENT THIS NEW HELICOPTER
APT AND I BY APPRECIATE?
HAVING A CONVERSATION AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD ON THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS WITH WHICH THEY BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A REAL POTENTIAL
THAT YOU CAN YOU CAN HAVE A
WHERE THEY PRESENTLY ARE IF IN
FACT THERE SPEEDIER QUICKER WITH
HIGHER.
CAPACITY SO THERE THERE'S A WAY
FOR POSITIONING TO BE AS
EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE BUT I
WOULD.
BECAUSE OF THE AREAS WE SERVE IN
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT TO THAT
WE'RE FACING.
.
BRIEFING MAYBE AT AS HOW THOSE
NEW. OPERATIONS GO WOULD WOULD
BE TERRIFIC AND OUT.
I WOULDN'T MIND RIDE ALONG ON
ONE OF THEM.
SPEAKER I THINK WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR THAT LEAD BRIDES
FACT THAT. THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
THIS. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SHARE BLOOM IN THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR THE SUPPORT THROUGH THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS I.
I I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT CALVARY THAT
DEBT WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS AND TO.
IT'S VERY PALPABLE THROUGHOUT
THE DEPARTMENTS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN A HENTAI WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION.
WELCOME HAVE HELICOPTERS COME
ONBOARD.
THE HELICOPTERS.
NO HELICOPTERS BUT SOME VERY
IMPORTANT CULTURAL A RESOURCES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
SMOG.
GOOD MORNING THE FIRST ITEM ON
YOUR AGENDA IS.
I REQUEST IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
RENOVATION OF THE WING OF THE
MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE AT THE SIMON
WIESENTHAL CENTER. THIS WOULD BE.
ABOUT HALF OF THE TOTAL COST OF
THE RENOVATION ON THE BALANCE OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS EXPECTED
TO BE RAISED THROUGH
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT BY THE
MUSEUM.
AND.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS ON
PROVIDES A STATEWIDE BENEFIT.
AS IT CAN AS THE MUSEUM MEAN TO
MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE A
CONTRIBUTES THE STATE'S DIALOGUE
ON HUMAN RIGHTS AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU LA THOUGH. I THINK
YOU'RE.
.
WE IS FOR THOSE UNCLEAR Y. THIS
PROJECT SPECIFICALLY WAS
SELECTED FOR DIRECT GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT.
TYPICALLY PROJECTS WOULD APPLY
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE THROUGH
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE USUALLY ON
A COMPETITIVE BASIS.
AND SO. WE THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
WANNA ASK THE DEPARTMENT WHY AND
JUST.
PROPOSAL WAS CONSIDERED A HIGHER
PRIORITY THAN OTHER PROJECTS ON
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES. AND.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT ON THE
BALLOT IN JUNE OF THAT.
IF SHOULD IT PASS WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR A PARKS AND RECREATION
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND SO WHETHER THIS MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT OR.
IF THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
COULD FREE UP. LOCAL MONIES FOR
THE STOCK.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL MCGINNIS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS THIS
PROPOSAL.
BASED ON THE MERITS THAT WERE
OUTLINED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION.
PROPOSITION SIXTY IT WAS
CONSIDERED AS A FUNDING SOURCE
BUT IT WAS DETERMINED THAT BASED
OFF THE TYPE.
OF THE DIRECT GRANT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO PROVIDE HERE THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON
ISSUE NUMBER TEN. TRICIA NUMBER
TONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN HERITAGE
CENTER.
KNOW BEFORE I BEGIN OF WITH ME
IS.
YOU INDICATED.
I AM CRISTINA SNYDER I AM I THE
TROUBLE ADVISER FOR THE GOVERNOR.
SO IT'S YOUR TURN A CALIFORNIAN
HERITAGE CENTER.
THE GOVERNORS ARE COSTING ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND.
TO HELP ESTABLISH A NEW INDIAN
MUSEUM ON IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT THE ENTIRE
BUILT OUT OF THIS MUSEUM IS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND WILL
BE WORKING WITH INTERESTED
PARTIES TO SECURE THE BALANCE OF
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
ON THIS IS YOU CAN SEE FROM YOUR
AGENDA IS BUILT OFF OF. AN
EFFORT THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING FOR
YEARS OVER MANY YEARS THERE WAS
A TASK FORCE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED THEIR SENATE BILL
TWENTY SIXTY THREE AND TWO
THOUSAND JAIL. THAT TASK FORCE
WAS COMPRISED OF VARIOUS.
TRIBAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
THEY WERE TASKED WITH LOOKING
AROUND THE STATE TO IDENTIFY ANY.
A ON LOCATION FOR A NEW MUSEUM
THAT WOULD BE WORTHY OF
PRESERVATION AND PROTECTING AND
CELEBRATING ON OUT OF NATIVE.
HERITAGE.
THROUGH THAT EFFORT THEY CHOSE A
LOCATION IN THE CITY OF LOS
SACRAMENTO. IT'S ALONG THE BANKS
OF THE SACRAMENTO RIVER IT'S AT
THE CONFLUENCE OF THE TWO RIVERS
WHICH PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
CULTURAL.
IT'S A LOT OF CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE ONTO THE NATIVE
PEOPLES.
WE ALSO NOTE IN OUR PROPOSAL
THAT THIS WOULD REPLACE OUR
EXISTING MUSEUM SORRY EXISTING
MUSEUM WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN
FORTY. IT'S CO LOCATED AT
SUTTER'S FOR WHICH.
IT.
IS IS IS CONSIDERED KIND OF A
CULTURALLY INSENSITIVE TO LOCATE
IT THERE ALONGSIDE CENTERS FOR.
WE HOUSE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TRIBAL OBJECTS IN OUR
COLLECTIONS LOCATED AT MCCLELLAN
AIRFORCE BASE IN ONE OF OUR.
IN OUR STATEWIDE MUSEUM
COLLECTIONS WAREHOUSE.
AND MOST OF THEM SET THERE
WITHOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ENJOYED BY THE PUBLIC.
AND I'M CONNECTING YOUTH WITH
THESE ARTIFACTS.
THE LOCATION NOW NOT ONLY IS IT
ANTIQUATED BUT IT'S VERY SMALL
SO WERE ONLY ABLE TO REALLY PUT
ON DISPLAY A VERY VERY SMALL
PORTION. OF WHAT.
IS UNDER THE STATE STEWARDSHIP.
THANK YOU ILIO.
YEAH AND WE HAVE TWO MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL OF
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS.
IT'S UNCLEAR THAT THE TWO ARE
MILLION COST ESTIMATE IS.
ACCURATE OF I KNOW THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME STUDIES DONE
MOVED DIRECTOR REFERENCED.
BUT. TWO THOUSAND AND TWO WAS
QUITE AWHILE AGO.
AND SAYS YOU LIKE OVERLOOKING
ANNOUNCED OF HIS LITTLE
CONCEPTUAL WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT
OF DETAILS ABOUT IT.
SO THEY'RE NOT THAT TO HER
MILLION DOLLAR AMOUNT IS RIGHT
AND THEN SECONDLY THAT.
BY PROVING THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OF THAT IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED I WOULD
AUTHORIZE ALL OF THE FUNDING AT
ONCE.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S DIFFERENT
FROM THE NORMAL CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROCESS WHERE YOU SEE A PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING AT EACH STAGE DURING
THE PROCESS. OF AND SO WE THINK
IT REMOVES A CERTAIN LEVEL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT FOR A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DOLLAR AMOUNT.
.
SO WE THINK THAT IF YOU DO WANT
TO. MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
PROJECT THAT WOULD MAYBE MAKE
MORE SENSE TO JUST FIND WHAT'S
NEEDED IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
FOR SOME OF THE INITIAL PHASES
OF THE PROJECT.
IF YOU WANT TO CHOOSE A SET
ASIDE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THE PROJECT.
YOUR HOPE OF SOME OF THE
FUNDRAISING THAT THEY MENTIONED.
A MEAL YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO
STILL MOVE OVER IN TO THE
SPECIAL FUND.
WE JUST THINK. IF YOU MOVE IT
OVER YOU SHOULD AUTHORIZES.
ALL OF IT ONCE NECESSARILY.
.
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO OVERSEE
THIS AS IT DEVELOPS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
UP THE CRYSTALS ON A FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AYE WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT PROJECT FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR CALIFORNIA
TRIBES AND WE'D LIKE TO RE
ITERATE A FEW NOTES.
I'M FIRST A GENERAL FUND FUNDING
FOR.
FOR THIS PROJECT DEMONSTRATES
THE VARIOUS HERE SERIOUS
COMMITMENT UP FROM THE STATE. UP
FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT PROJECT
THAT WAS FIRST INITIATED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO.
SUCH AS SECOND OF THE FUNDING
STRATEGY PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL ALLOW PARKS
TO. LEVERAGE FUNDS COMMITTED BY
THE STATE TO MAXIMIZE THE OF
FUNDRAISING NECESSARY FOR
PROJECT COMPLETION.
I'M AND LASTLY AT THE PROJECT
WILL STILL BE SUBJECT TO SEE
OVERSIGHT BY THAT THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU AS ERNIE OF PUBLIC
COMMENT ON.
ANY OF THE.
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS RECREATION
ISSUES NINE TEN ELEVEN AYE YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY BROKE KAMI
HALF OF THE I WOULD CALL THE
INDEPENDENT WE INDIANS IN PALM
SPRINGS. WERE ONE OF A HUNDRED
NINE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
IN THE STATE. THINK THIS IS A
REALLY WORTHWHILE PROJECT I
REMEMBER WORKING ON THIS BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO TIME FLIES WHEN
YOU'RE HAVING FUN.
SO WE'RE VERY VERY GRATEFUL FROM
MOVING THIS PROJECT FORWARD AND
HOPE YOU ADOPT THIS. THIS THIS
REVISION REQUEST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I I ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL THREE ITEMS. WITHOUT HAVING
HEARD THE THIRD ITEM YOU
COULDN'T STOP MAKES.
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE HERE TO GET
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT ON THE
THIRD ITEM THEN WILL WITHHOLD
THAT UNTIL AFTER.
IT'S BEEN PRESENTED BUT IF
YOU'RE HERE YARDI STANDING ON
THE OTHER TUITION CSUS.
CAMANCHE MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF LARRY MYERS ON THE.
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIAN HERITAGE CENTER
FOUNDATION. AND I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THE TASK
FORCES CREATE HOUSE MEMBER THE
TASK FORCE.
AND THOSE MEMBERS OF THE TASK
FORCE OF ALSO SORT OF TRANSITION
OF FOUNDATION.
AND LET ME JUST JUST EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS PROJECT
IS TO THE INDY COMMUNITY WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FORTY PLUS YEARS
FOR THIS. AS THINK ABOUT FORTY
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN TALKS FIRST
STARTED DEVELOPING ABOUT
DEVELOPING AND INDEED.
MUSEUM A WIDOW ONE COLOR MUSEUM
WATER QUALITY HERITAGE CENTER WE
WANNA BE ALIVE LIVING PLACE THAT
IT WILL HAVE OUR FACTS BUT ALSO
WILL HAVE MORE THAN THAT IT WILL
HAVE DOCUMENTS OF OF A PLACE.
FOR HIM HE'S A NON INDIAN IS TO
COME AND WE WE SEE THIS AS BEING
SEVEN THAT CAN REACH OUT AND.
AND CREE RELATIONSHIP FOR THE UC
SYSTEM OF THE STATE UNIVERSITY
OF PROVIDENCE PRIVATE MUSEUMS
SHARE INFORMATION TO TO BRING
EVERYONE ON THE SAME PAGE I
THINK THIS WOULD BE. A GREAT
BENEFIT ALL THE CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO WITH
THAT I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROJECT THANK YOU.
JIMMY SON WEEK THAT MORNING MY
NAME'S MORNINGSTAR CALLING HIM A
MEMBER OF THE I. JAMALI BAND OF
PAPER EVER. AND SERVED AS THE
TRIBAL HISTORIC PRESERVATION
OFFICER FOR FOREVER TRIED FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS.
I HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
EDUCATING SCHOOL BOARDS.
TEACHERS AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
ABOUT CALIFORNIA TRIBAL NATIONS
A HOME AND SO THESE COMMONLY
NAME. THESE COMMONLY.
NO NAMES SUCH AS FREMONT CIDER
AND
HOME YOU KNOW GINA PARA SARAH
DOT ARE KNOWN I'M TO HAVE
ENSLAVED AND. I'M MURDERED
CALIFORNIA TRIED TAKING THOUGHT
IT IS THE DUTY FOR OUR GENERAL
PUBLIC TO KNOW WITH THE NAMES OF
OUR OF OUR TRIBES.
CHEST AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
MORNING MOUNTIE QUIT US WITH THE
CANTON A CRUISE COMPANY ON
BEHALF OF RAMONA THE VA HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY INDIANS AND HAVE A
MENTAL PROBLEM UPPER LAKE. ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT ON ISSUE
NUMBER TEN FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBBIE TREADWAY I
AM A MEMBER OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A HERITAGE CENTER.
THANK YOU I I WOULD JUST ADD ONE
COMMENT ON ON ON THIS ITEM A
WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING IT
OPEN AND AND COMING BACK TO IT.
AT A AT A FUTURE MEETING AND I
HOPE IN THE INTERIM.
AYE AYE MEANS WILL BE FOUND TO
TO PROVIDE A MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT BECAUSE
THE WAY THE PROPOSAL IS.
IS WORDED RIGHT NOW THE MONEY
IS FUNDED AND IT.
OVERSIGHT TO WILL RESIDE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE.
AGENCY WITH NO FURTHER REVIEW
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND.
.
BUT. I THINK THIS IS OF GREAT
INTEREST TO OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
THE LEGISLATURE SHORT CERTAINLY
WILL HAVE A AN INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS.
HERITAGE CENTER.
WHICH I THINK WE ALL.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE MAXIMIZE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
TO. CONTINUE TO.
HAVE A RESPONSIBLE OVERSIGHT TO
OVER PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE
TALK.
I ENCOURAGE. YOU TO WORK ON THAT
TO WITH THE BUDGET STAFF.
MR MON. THEY MISS CHAIR. BY
CONCUR WITH THOSE COMMENTS I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE PROJECT
JUST TO CLARIFY THE LA JOH.
YOU SAID THAT THESE ESTIMATES
ARE OLD MAKE CLEARLY IS PROJECTS
EVERYDAY OF TALK ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO.
BUT YOUR IS YOUR CONCERN THAT
THE OVERALL COST MAY EXCEED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OR YOU JUST CONCERNED THAT IT'S
AN OUTDATED ESTIMATE WE JUST
OVER THAT NOW WHAT THE FINAL
PRICE TAG.
WOULD BE YEAH I THINK MORE OF
OUR CONCERN WAS WAS JUST BAD YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S BASED ON SOME
SOME REPORTS THAT WERE OLDER AND
WE JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
DETAILS ON EXACTLY WHAT THIS.
PROJECT WOULD LOOK LIKE.
YOU TYPICALLY WE WOULD SEE
PROJECTS AND PHASES THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS THE COMEBACK
WITH THE DESIGN PHASES
EMPLOYMENT OF XTERRA.
BECAUSE THIS IS STILL KIND OF
THE OUTFIT WE JUST.
DON'T HAVE THAT AND SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR IF TO UNDER
MILLION IS IS THE RIGHT.
AMOUNT.
YEAH.
.
RIGHT BRAIN DO ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE A QUESTION AS STATE PARK
SELECTED RESPONDED THAT.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE DID A.
FAIRLY COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
INCLUDES A DETAILED ESTIMATES.
FLOOR PLANS AND AREAS AND SET
SUCH FOR THAT FOR THE BUILDING
SO. WHEN WE SAY THIS IS
CONCEPTUAL.
.
THE IDEA IS IS WE HAVE SOME
COMMUNITY OUT OF REACH TO FINE
TUNE THE SCOPE BUT THE MAN TO
THE PROJECT IS DONE.
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE THE THE
OPPOSITION THE CONFIGURATION OF
THE BUILDINGS THE PROGRAM AREAS
BETWEEN THE BUILDINGS MAY SHIFT
SLIGHTLY. BUT THE THE CONCEPT.
REMAINS.
VERY VERY FIRM IN AND VERY
DETAILED.
AS FAR AS THE COST THE COST
REDUNDANT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
WE BASICALLY THOSE TO TODAY'S
DOLLARS AND THEN PROJECT IS
ABOUT TO START CONSTRUCTION FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW SO WE'RE WE'RE
VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE. AMOUNT
OF FIVE FUNDING IS SUFFICIENT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE SCOPE THAT'S A
CONTAINED IN THIS IN THIS IN
THIS DOCUMENT. SO WE DO WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AND
TRAVEL COUPLE GROUPS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FINAL PLAN REFLECTS OUR
STATEWIDE VISION AND. AND A
PRIORITIES.
SO WE DON'T HAVE A A FIXED IDEA
OF EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GONNA
BUILD BUT IT'S VERY SOLID AND WE
LOOK FOR THE WORKING FOLKS TO
FINE TUNE A FURTHER.
I'VE. I'VE MISSED PATTERSON NOT
IT GO AHEAD AND THAT ALL. I JUST
MAKE MY POINT.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE AND THE CHAIRS
CONCERNS.
CERTAINLY THERE IS A PATHWAY
HERE TO GET THIS PUT TOGETHER SO
THAT IT COMES BACK TO US PRETTY
SOON WE CAN WE CAN APPROVE IT I
WANT TO I WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS.
SO WHAT WHAT OF THAT. WHAT KINDS
OF ASSURANCES DOES ALEJO NEED IN
ORDER? AT AND THE CHAIR NEED.
IN ORDER TO GET PAST THAT DEAD.
THE P. APPARENT.
UNCERTAINTIES.
FIVE QUESTION YEAH I THINK
EARLIER YES WE'RE JUST CONCERNED.
THE OUT WITH WITH THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT IF WE AUTHORIZE ALL
THIS AT ONCE SO.
YOU KNOW OUR RECOMMENDATION WAS
CONSIDERED JUST AUTHORIZING WITH
NEEDED IN THE BUDGET YEAR OUGHT
TO KEEP IT MOVING FORWARD AND
THEN.
HAVE THEM COME BACK NEXT.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT HE WOULD
FOUR FOR A TYPICAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY POSTION.
PROCESS FOR IT BENEFIT AND ARE
YOU ARE YOU SAYING THAT.
THE MONEY UP FRONT.
YOU'RE WELL PREPARED TO TAKE IT
AND GET IT OUT AND CONSTRUCTIVE
QUICKLY.
IT'S I DON'T WHAT WHAT WOULD
PARTIALLY IT OUT SLOW YOU DOWN.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISTER CHAIR
I THINK.
WHAT WHAT I HEAR IS THAT THERE'S
COLLECTIVE IN SPIRIT SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROJECT IT WAS NEVER OUR
INTENT IN CRAFTING IN THIS
MANNER TO SOMEHOW ON DIMINISH
OUR LESSONS LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT? SO I THINK IF YOU
GIVE US A CHANCE TO GO BACK
SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IT'S NOT
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE STATE THAT
WE WOULD APPROPRIATE ALL OF THE
FUNDING UP FRONT I'M WITH
GENERAL FUND THERE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES OF WHERE REACHED ON THE
ON THE STATE. AND SO WE CAN KIND
OF GO BACK THERE AND LOOK AT
SPECIFICALLY HOW WE DID THAT BUT
I THINK WE'LL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE THE NEXT
HEARING.
RON YOU OPEN THE TRUST FACTOR
CAN GO WAY WAY UP HERE AND THAT
WE CAN MOVE ON TO GET THIS TO.
GET THIS DONE I WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE ON THIS.
WHO?
AND I.
I'M NOT IT'S TROUBLED BY THE
ALLOCATION OF THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH I.
DO UNDERSTAND FOR US.
A PROJECT OF THIS NATURE WILL
UP.
HELP LEVERED SHUT.
OF CHARITABLE DONATIONS THAT
WILL.
HELP FILL OUT THE REMAINDER OF
THE BUDGET I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT AND I'M SURE THIS IS.
UNDERSTOOD BUT IT.
WERE RELYING ON.
A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WORK THAT
WAS DONE ON THE ON THE PROPOSAL
AND BEFORE THAT TWO THOUSAND TWO.
I HAD TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IS ALL
IS A DECADE AGO OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS UTILIZED AND.
FACILITIES LIST NATURE HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY EVEN IN THE
LAST
DECADE AND I HOPE THAT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A FACILITY AT
EIGHT HERITAGE CENTER THAT WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF THE
GREAT TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE. OUT UTILIZED AND.
MUSEUMS AND OTHER CULTURAL
HERITAGE.
OF.
SITES.
.
THAT THAT ARE THAT ARE SIMILAR
SO THAT WE ARE.
WITH THIS KIND OF MONEY.
ULTIMATELY BUILDING OUT A WORLD
CLASS.
A HERITAGE CENTER THAT WILL BE.
LOOK TO AROUND THE WORLD AT
SAID.
AT BEST.
THE INTENT IS THAT WITH THIS
PROJECT.
ON END WITH PARDONING WITH THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY IT'S NOT JUST
FROM THE PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT
ASPECT BUT ALSO THAT WILL BE
PARTNERING WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES IN DESIGNING THE
INTERPRETIVE PROGRAMS.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME IT'S
REALLY ALLOWING US TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM THAT ALLOWS
THE NATIVE.
STORIES TO BE TOLD A NATIVE
VOICES SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABSOLUTELY KEY.
I AM GLAD THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
THE NOTION OF TECHNOLOGY THE WAY
PEOPLE AND VISITORS WANT TO
INTERACT AND MUSEUMS. ON TODAY
IS VASTLY DIFFERENT THAN KIND OF
THE STATIC EXPERIENCES THAT WE
GREW UP WITH AS KIDS SO OUR
INTENT WITH THIS PROJECT IS THAT
YOU WILL SEE MORE OF AN INFUSION.
OF TECHNOLOGY WE WILL BE LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY AND HAVE BEEN AT
THE SMITHSONIAN.
MUSEUM AT NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY WE WILL ALSO BE LOOKING
AT OTHER.
OTHER MUSEUMS OF THAT STATURE
AND GETTING A SENSE AND LEARNING
ABOUT WITH LEARNING FROM THEM
ABOUT WHAT'S WHAT'S WORKED AND.
AND WHAT HASN'T WORKED AS WE
WORK WITH THE TRIBAL COMMUNITY.
WHEN QUICKLY FOUGHT THE DEFENSE
DO IT DID I UNDERSTAND THAT IS
GOING TO BE ON A RIPPED THE
RIVER FRONTAGE WILL IT BE A OF
RIVER FRONTAGE.
I'LL AT THE CONFLUENCE OF THE
AMERICAN IN THE SACK CRACKED.
THAT THAT THE WONDERFUL SITE.
THANK YOU AND DOES NOT BEEN
BACKED UP FOR A QUICK SECOND ON
THE MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE A
PROPOSAL.
I I I I KNOW THE FOLKS THERE
WITH MUSEUM IS IN MY DISTRICT I
VISITED IT MANY TIMES.
AND I KNOW THE INTENTION THERE
IS TO INCORPORATE INTO A TOP
RATE TECHNOLOGY ALSO.
SO THAT THE MISSION OF THAT
FACILITY CAN BE ACHIEVED AT ITS
HIGHEST LEVEL.
AND.
LET'S TAKE ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
ON THE FOR. ROSS CULTURAL TREND.
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO THE FORT
ROSS STATE HISTORIC PARK IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT INTERPRETS.
A TWENTY YEAR PERIOD IN WHICH.
THAT THE RUSSIAN MERCANTILE
PERIOD WHERE THERE IS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH I'M VARIOUS
NATIVE PEOPLES ALONG WITH THE
RUSSIANS THAT RESIDED THERE FOR
TWENTY YEARS. WHAT YOU DON'T SEE
AS ANY FOR?
PHYS PHYSICAL MANIFESTATION AND
INTERPRETATION OF THE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE NATIVE
PEOPLES ON DURING THAT TIME AND
AND ALSO PRE DATING.
THE ARRIVAL OF THOSE GROUPS AND
SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO WOULD
ESTABLISH A CULTURAL TRAIL IT'S
ROUGHLY THREE MILES LONG IT ALSO
WOULD COMPLETE A SEGMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL TRAIL.
IT WILL BE DONE THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY.
IN THAT AREA PRIMARILY THE TEST
SCIENTISTS WHO HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN A SIGNIFICANT INTEREST AND
WORKED VERY HARD AND HELPING TO
COLLABORATE WITH US AND ALREADY
DEVELOPED AN INTERPRETIVE
PROGRAM. AND ALSO WE WOULD
PARTNER WITH A PROFESSOR AT UC
BERKELEY PROFESSOR CAN'T MIGHT
FIT. WHO HAS BEEN?
HAS HAD DECADES OF PARTNERSHIP
AND INTEREST IN THAT PARTICULAR.
IN THAT PARTICULAR PARK.
SPEAKING OF TECHNOLOGY THE
INTENT IS THAT THIS WOULD NOT
JUST BE A TRAIL TO WALK BUT THAT
THERE WOULD BE.
INTERPRETIVE NOTES SO AS YOU GO
INTO THE VISITOR CENTER PERHAPS
YOU CAN DOWNLOAD A PODCAST THAT
AS YOU AND WALK ALONG THE TRAIL
THAT THERE WILL BE EASY THESE
INTERPRETIVE STATIONS. AND YOU
MAY HEAR.
A SONG IN THE NATIVE PEOPLES
SUNG BY A TRIBAL ELDER ON YOU
MAY HEAR SOMEONE ON FROM THE
ALASKA NATIVE GROUPS WHO UP
PARTICIPATED VERY HEAVILY DURING
THAT THAT THIS HISTORIC TIME. ON
AND MAYBE ONE OF THEM TELLING
THEIR STORY SO IT'S GOING TO BE
A PLATFORM FOR NOT JUST A NORMAL
AT A TYPICAL STATE PARKS TRAIL.
BUT REALLY KIND OF INFUSING
MODERN TECHNOLOGY AND BEING.
MARCELLA PRETORIA OF NATIVE
PEOPLES.
FANTASTIC BELIAU AYE WE HAVE AT
RISK.
THANK YOU AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE
I WENT PART OF THIS PART.
EXCELLENT A.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE IS.
I GET FOR BEING PATIENT. NO
WORRIES HI MY NAME IS HOLLY
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION OUR
FOUNDATION IS A WORKS ON BEHALF
OF. AND MANY PARK PARTNERS AND
OUR MEMBERSHIP TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
A STATE PARKS AND CAN EXPERIENCE
THE TRANSFORMATIVE AND
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY PRESENT. A WE'RE HERE TO
SIT SHOW OUR SUPPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR ALL THREE ITEMS
AND AS YOU CAN TELL FROM FROM
THESE PROPOSALS AT THE CULTURAL
HISTORICAL. OPPORTUNITIES TO
REALLY ENGAGE CALIFORNIA'S TO
UNDERSTANDING THE HISTORY OF OUR
STATE THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
PARKS IS SOMETHING WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO SEE AT WANT TO SHOW
OUR SUPPORT AND SO THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM VERY A
QUICKLY MENTIONED TO HER THE A
COASTAL TRAIL AND TO PERHAPS
SOMETIME IN THE.
NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE A IT WOULD BE.
OF GREAT INTEREST TO ME AND I
HOPE OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND IT.
PROBABLY OTHER COMMITTEES AS
WELL TO HEAR A PRESENTATION ON
JUST WHERE WE STAND WITH
BUILDING OUT THE ENTIRE.
A CALIFORNIA COASTAL TRAIL
WHICH HAS BEEN A OF A AN
ASPIRATION FOR MANY MANY YEARS
NOW.
AND PERHAPS DEVELOP A STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR A ABOUT COMPLETING THE
TRAIL BASED ON THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU PROVIDE US.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY.
WILL.
.
PICK UP NOW WITH DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION WE HAVE ONE
ITEM.
TWELVE
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
TO GO INTO IT.
FIFTH FLEET IS THAT OKAY ARE
GOING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVE ME TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
BRIAN LEAHY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
WITH ME IS KEN SPENCE DIRECTOR
OF UP POLICY AND LEGISLATION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
AGENDA TODAY A MAY REVISE
FINANCE LETTER.
TO PROVIDE POSITIONS FOR THE
PESTICIDE REGISTRATION PROGRAM.
WHICH HAS BECOME NECESSARY A TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT AND PROVIDE A MORE
TRANSPARENT SCIENTIFIC
REGULATORY PROCESS.
DPR WITH THREE POSITION.
AND FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND I'M GOING
FROM THE PR FUND. TO ENHANCE THE
PUBLIC'S A. ACCESS TO
INFORMATION REGARDING DP OURS
PESTICIDE EVALUATION PROCESS AND
FINDINGS.
TO MEET OUR SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS
DVR PUBLISHES NOTICES
POST AND FINAL DECISIONS A
PESTICIDE REGISTRATIONS.
WE PROPOSE TO EXPAND THESE
NOTICES TO INCLUDE.
A MORE THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE
SCIENTIFIC EVALUATIONS.
SUPPORTING THESE DECISIONS AND
SHOW HOW THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW OF EACH DECISION MEETS
THE SUBSTANTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW REQUIREMENTS OF SEQUEL.
AS PART OF THIS EFFORT DPR WILL
BE REVISING A. THE PROCESS
RELATING TO THE.
PUBLIC NOTICE OF PROPOSED.
AND FINAL DECISIONS
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS THEM.
THANK YOU.
SEEING KNOW QUESTIONS THE ILIO
NO ISSUES AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
SHAKING THEIR HEADS NO.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE.
IT'S PAST AN EXPECTED UPLOAD
TOWERS WITH PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK SUPPORT WE.
WE BELIEVE
I'D AND SUPPORT DEPARTMENTS
EFFORTS TOWARDS AND HANDS TO A
TRANSPARENT SCIENTIFICALLY
RIGOROUS REGISTRATION ROCESS
THAT THAT MEETS THESE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SEIGE.
THANK YOU.
CONCLUDES ITEM APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING HERE TODAY. AND.
WE'LL HEAR NOW FROM DEPARTMENT
OF RESOURCES RECYCLING IN
RECOVERY.
CALVET GOLD.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING.
SCOTT SMITH KLINE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING RECOVERY WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY.
I DO HAVE BRIEFED BY NOTES ON
EACH ONE OF MOVE THROUGH THEM
EXPEDITIOUSLY IN ORDER THAT
WORKS.
YES.
THE FIRST ITEM.
IS.
DISASTER RECOVERY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM CONSISTENT WITH.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
PLAN IN PREVIOUS ASSISTANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING RECOVERY REQUESTS.
SIX PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS AND AUTHORITY TO
CONTRACT WITH THE SUPPORT
CONSULTANT.
AND ONE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
FROM THE INTEGRATED WASTE
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT TO.
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REQUEST FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE WHEN
DEVELOPING DISASTER RECOVERY
PLANS.
AND FORMALLY ESTABLISHED A TEAM.
STAFF AND A SUPPORT CONSULTANT
TO MOBILIZE AND SUPPORT COVER
CYCLES RESPOND TO EMERGENCY
DECLARATION MISSED MISSION
TASKING. FOR STATE OPERATED
DISASTER DEBRIS REMOVAL PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES A WIDE
ARRAY OF DISASTERS THAT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES OF DEBRIS
THAT MUST BE REMOVED PROPERLY
RECYCLED OR DISPOSED OF AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE.
THE POTENTIAL FOR WIDESPREAD
TOXIC EXPOSURES AND LASTING
THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ENVIRONMENT IS POSED BY
DEBRIS LEFT IN THE AFTERMATH OF
MAJOR DISASTERS.
TO BE MANAGEMENT IS COMPLICATED
AND IT'S CHALLENGING FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND STATE AGENCIES
RD AFFECTED BY A DISASTER
BECAUSE OF THE NEED FOR ADEQUATE
AVAILABLE AND TIMELY RESOURCES
AND PERSONNEL WHO CAN CONDUCT
CRITICAL ACTIVITIES.
IN RESPONSE TO A GOVERNOR'S
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
ASSISTANCE REQUEST FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AS REGULARLY TASKED COVER CYCLE
TO SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE MANAGEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION.
DEBRIS MOVE REMOVAL OPERATIONS.
THE RECENT INCREASE.
AT THE RECENT INCREASE IN
FREQUENCY.
CHIU MET THE SAME THING IS THAT
THE RECENT FREQUENCY AND
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA RESULTED IN CAL
RECYCLE BEING TASKED YEAR OVER
YEAR SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
STILL DO DELIVERED TO BELIEVE A
DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATIONS IN THE
FIELD.
THE RESULTANT REDIRECTION OF
STAFF HAS HINDERED OUR ABILITY
TO PERFORM SOME OF OUR STATUTORY
MANDATED OBLIGATIONS.
WE HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
NUMBER OF APPROPRIATELY
QUALIFIED AND TRAINED
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNT RECYCLED
WEAPON WILLING AND ABLE TO
REPEATEDLY STAFF THE NECESSARY
FIELD OPERATIONS BUT THIS IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE IS AN APPROPRIATE TEAM TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN TASK WE CAN
CONTINUE TO CONSISTENTLY DELIVER
SAFE. AND EFFECTIVE DEBRIS
REMOVAL OPERATIONS
AS WELL AS ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEIR INDIVIDUAL.
EMERGENCY PREPARATIONS.
EDU.
ALEJO.
THINK YOU ACTUALLY AS OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M. WE RECEIVE
THIS PROPOSAL RECENTLY WERE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING AND NOW I'M IN WILL BE
UPDATING THE COMMITTEE HAS WERE
ABLE TO DO GOT.
BUT SOME OF THINGS THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
ARE WHAT THE IMPACT OF THE STOCK.
I WILL HAVE ON THEIR ABILITY DO
DEBRIS REMOVAL CLEAN UP
SPECIFICALLY.
MAYBE WHAT SOME OF THE RECENT
FIRES WHAT DIFFERENCE IT MIGHT
HAVE MADE A WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK
LIKE WITH HIS ADDITIONAL STAFF.
PRESUMABLY STILL NEED TO BRING
IN THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
TO FAST. AND.
WHAT KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BE PROVIDED TO LOCAL
SPECIFICALLY?
THANK YOU GOD DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU JULIETTE MARS HYMIE
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THIS THIS PROPOSAL IT
ALSO AS IT.
TIES INTO THE OVERALL STATEWIDE
EFFORTS ON EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
AND.
NOTABLY LAST YEAR WE HAD SO MANY
OF THE FIRES THAT WE KNEW THAT
REQUIRED AND A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF DEBRIS REMOVAL. ACTIVITY.
AND.
AFTER WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
IT WAS DETERMINED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ACTUALLY IT COULD
RESULT IN SOME COST AVOIDANCE IS.
IF WE HAD SOME OF.
LIKE A STRIKE TEAM BASICALLY.
TO BE OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THINGS GO A
LITTLE BIT SMOOTHER DOWN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WHEN THEY'RE NOT
RESPONDING TO THE DEBRIS REMOVAL
EFFORTS THEY COULD WORK WITH THE
LOCALS IN DEVELOPING.
PLANS. AHEAD OF A DISASTER.
TO MAKE IT GO THAT MUCH SMOOTHER
IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU BOB AND I JUST.
I FELT INTRODUCE.
NEXT ME I IT THIS MORNING IS
KENDRA'S A CHEAP DIPPY DIRECTOR
FELLERS LIKE.
TO SEE.
AND I WITH RESPECT TO THE LA
DOES.
A COMMENTS MEDIA ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED.
HALL JUST TO ASK THAT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR CONFERRING CHO ON
THOSE ISSUES WITH BUDGET STAFF.
OF WITH A VIEW TOWARD SILVA A
SING AT THAT CAN BE RESOLVED BE
HAPPY TO DO SO SALUTE THANK YOU.
NEXT UP IS SAID THE PLASTIC
MARKET DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING RECOVERY REQUESTS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
REAUTHORIZE THE PLASTIC MARK
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO.
WE REQUEST FIFTEEN MILLION FROM
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FUND FOR FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND TEN MILLION PCR
ANNUALLY FOR NINETEEN TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TO TO SUPPORT PAYMENTS TO
PLASTIC RECLAIMER TO
MANUFACTURERS.
THE A AB TWENTY TWENTY
ESTABLISHED THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM IT
HAS SUCCESSFULLY INCREASED THE
RECYCLING RATE A BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS TO OVER SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM DATA HAS SHOWN THAT THE
COMBINATION OF CONSUMER
RECYCLING INCENTIVES AND
CONVENIENT RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE RESULTS IN
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING A
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING.
IN ADDITION FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE PLASTIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
PROVIDER PAYMENTS TO PLASTIC
PROCLAIMERS AND THOSE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO. ARE RECEIVE THE
COLLECTED BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
AND CLEAN AND WASH INFLATE THEM.
AND MANUFACTURES IN AN EFFORT
TO DEVELOP CALIFORNIA'S MARKETS
FOR RECYCLED EMPTY PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS.
THE PLASTIC MARK DEVELOPMENT
PAYMENTS FACILITATED THE
CLEANING OF TRANSFORMATION A
PLASTIC FOR REUSE AND REPURPOSE
REMANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA.
CLOSING THE LOOP UNCOLLECTED
RECYCLED MATERIALS IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL BETH BENEFITS WE
DERIVE.
FROM RECYCLING ACCRUE ONLY ONCE
WE REDIRECT THE COLLECTED
MATERIAL BACK INTO THE STREAM OF
COMMERCE.
IN RECENT MONTHS THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMODITY MARKETS
FOR RECYCLING MATERIALS HAVE
BEEN DISRUPTED SO SEVERELY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST ITS ABILITY
TO MOVE MANY RECYCLED MATERIALS.
OUT OF THE STATE.
WE ARE EXPERIENCING A BACKUP OF
SEVERAL TYPES MATERIALS.
ON THE MAGNITUDE.
OF THIS BACK UP IS UNPRECEDENTED.
THIS IS LARGELY DUE TO IMPORT
RESTRICTIONS.
.
PUT ON A INTERNATIONAL TRADE BY
CHINA IN THIS POLICY IS KNOWN AS
NATIONAL SOARED.
AND THE SEVERITY AND THE
ULTIMATE LONGEVITY OF THIS
POLICY IS UNKNOWN.
SO WHAT WE A STRUGGLE TO ADDRESS
THIS PARTICULAR BACKLOG A BILL
MATERIALS ACROSS THE STREET.
ONE MATERIAL PARTICULAR HAS NOT
BEEN A PROBLEM THAT IS PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS.
THIS IS DUE IN LARGE PART TO THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED IN THE PLASTIC
RECLAIMING AND MANUFACTURING
INFRASTRUCTURE VIA THE PM DEBT
PAYMENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST SIGNIFICANT
PROCESSING CAPACITY OVER RECENT
YEARS. IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
PROTECT OUR CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MANAGE THESE
MATERIALS WE GENERATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROPOSAL HELPED ENSURE WE
DO NOT TAKE A STEP BACKWARDS.
THANK YOU.
.
LTO. AYE YES THANK YOU.
AT THE TIME OF THE ANALYSIS WE
HADN'T SEEN.
AYE THE CITY OF US OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATED THEY DO.
HAVE SOME OF THE BACK OF
INFORMATION THAT WE EN ELSEWHERE
AND SO WILL ANALYZE THAT AND GET
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE.
THANK YOU OUT POINT OUT ON BOTH
THIS ISSUE AND THE UPCOMING
ISSUE THE.
.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT'S
PROPOSED HAS WHO WAS NOT
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME THE AGENDA
WAS PUBLISHED BUT HAS BEEN
RECEIVED SUBSEQUENTLY I DON'T
THINK IT'S BEEN FULLY ANALYZED
BY. ANYBODY AT THIS POINT BUT
WERE HOLDING THE ITEM OPENS WILL
HAVE TIME TO DO THAT.
UNDERSTOOD.
SMOKERS MAKE THE SAME COMMITMENT
COMMUNICATORS.
THANK YOU ISSUE FIFTEEN. COVER
CYCLE REQUESTS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENABLE FURTHER
ENFORCEMENT ON ILLEGAL
REDEMPTION OF IMPORTED
CONTAINERS BY PROVIDING SPECIFIC
AUTHORITY TO THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL TO ENFORCE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM PROVISIONS.
THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
SPECIFIES THAT NO REFUND VALUE
OR OTHER RECYCLING PAYMENT SHALL
BE MADE TO ANY PERSON FOR
IMPORTED OUT OF STATE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS. THAT ANY PERSON
PARTICIPATING AND CONDUCT
INTENDED TO DEFRAUD THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM
SHALL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
COVER CYCLE HAS EXISTING
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE ILLEGAL IMPORTATION AND
REDEMPTION OF USED BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS AND COORDINATE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AT BORDER
STATIONS. TO INTERDICT ILLEGAL
LOADS OF CONTAINERS.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS ARE OFTEN PRESENT AT
BORDER STATIONS IN A PROVIDED
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM COULD ASSIST IN
ARRESTING INDIVIDUALS ILLEGALLY
TRANSPORTING. EMPTY CONTAINERS
ADDITIONALLY IF TRANSPORTERS
ATTEMPT TO BYPASS THE BORDER
STATION BY USING ALTERNATIVE
ROUTES MONITORED MONITORED BY
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS.
THE HIGHWAY PATROL COULD STILL
CONDUCT AN INSPECTION AND ARREST.
THIS PROPOSAL ADDS.
FORMALLY ADDS THE HIGHWAY
PATROL TO THE TEAM OF AGENCIES
AND FORCING BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM.
AND WILL FURTHER OUR EFFORT TO
LIMIT FRAUD AGAINST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ILIO AT SIMILAR TO THE
LAST COMMENT YES WORKING.
TO ANALYZE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WOULD SITTA
DITTO RIGHT. ABOUT HIM AND.
A DEPARTMENT FINANCE IN THE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
DOES THIS PROPOSED TO GIVE.
BROADER.
HIGHWAY PATROL AUTHORITY FOR.
ANY KIND OF.
.
AND.
BEVERAGE CONTAINER.
.
THE LEGALITY.
OR IS IT JUST NARROWED TO THE.
FRAUDULENT.
YEAH IMPORTATION TO THIS.
STATES THE NARROWER OF THE TWO
IT IS AND THAT WILL BE SIX.
S. THAT IS SPECIFIED IN THE
LANGUAGE I BELIEVE IT IS YES
OKAY THANK.
DIRECTOR OF SMITH LINE YOU POINT
OUT THAT.
OUR.
A RECYCLING IS A SIGNIFICANTLY
DIMINISHED.
.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
OUR RATES ARE DOWN AT SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT THE GOAL IS EIGHTY
PERCENT I THINK IT'S BEEN A FIVE
PERCENT REDUCTION OVER THE. A
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND IT TO A.
AT IT.
IN ADDITION TO.
THE.
A SITUATION WITH CHINA.
A MAJOR CAUSE OF THAT THE
REDUCTIONS THE CLOSURE OF EIGHT
HUNDRED. RECYCLING LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
GIVEN THE A. S. SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE LOSS OF RECYCLING
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PUTTING
FORWARD SOMETHING IN AN ATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AND.
AT AT AS YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REINSTATE THE PLASTIC MARKET
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IS SOMETHING
THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE INCLUDED
IN OUR BUDGET RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS SO
GRATIFIED THAT IT'S FINALLY
GETTING IN BUT THAT THAT SAID TO
A DOES THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE A.
POSITION ON THE OTHER ELEMENTS
OF THE BOTTLE BILL FIX THAT WERE
PART OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS LAST YEAR AND.
HAVE BEEN INCORPORATED INTO
SENATOR GLAZERS SP FOUR TWENTY
FIVE.
MOBILE WE I DON'T HAVE.
I'M NOT PREPARED JUST WE'RE NOT
PICTURED OPINION ON ON ANY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AS WE SPEAK BUT
WE CERTAINLY.
CONTINUE TO.
MONITOR THE OTHER ITEMS THAT
YOU REYES PARTICULARLY THAT LOSS
OF.
RECYCLING CENTERS IS OF
IMPORTANCE TO US ONE OF THE.
ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
ANALYZE A IS WHAT EXACTLY IS THE
CAUSE OF THE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING. THERE ARE MANY
FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
THAT ARE REDUCED RATE THAT
REDEMPTION RATE. ON ONE OF THEM
IS.
SIMPLY THE AMOUNT OF BEVERAGE
CONTAINER SALES.
AS THAT IS A RATE OF REDEMPTION
OVER SALES AND WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER SALES AND SO THAT IF
WE DON'T HAVE A. CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN REDEMPTION THAT.
LOWERS THE RECYCLING RATE IN
THE.
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
ALSO INCREASED ARE EFFORTS ON
AND ON FRAUD ENFORCEMENT.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT WE HAVE
REDUCED.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR.
.
ILLEGAL REDEMPTION ABOUT OF
STATE BEVERAGE CANNOT CONTAINERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD ALSO DRIVE DOWN THE
REDEMPTION RATE BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION WE ALSO HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT FINDING THAT PROPER LEVEL
OF CONVENIENCE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE VERY FOCUSED ON
IMPLEMENTING AS BEFORE FIFTY
EIGHT.
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF
PROVIDING REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR CONSUMERS IN THE STATE THAT
WE THAT WE IMPLEMENT THAT
PROPERLY WELL.
.
THANK YOU FOR.
REALLY ACT A IN A VERY CONCISE
WAY.
TALKING ABOUT THE.
I VARIOUS COMPLEXITIES OF THIS
ISSUE IT'S NOT SIMPLE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE CAUSES IN MULTIPLE
FACTORS THAT INVOLVED IN THE.
DROP IN OUR RECYCLING RATES BUT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR US
TO.
TACKLE.
AND I AND WE REALLY HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE DO SO OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS IT'S TIME THAT WE
HAVE. A MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
TOWARDS THAT. THAT AND IS THERE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON.
A COVER CYCLE SO THREE ITEMS
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AFFECTING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
MURRAY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIA'S GETS WASTE.
ITEMS I SPEAKING I THINK TO
ISSUE FOURTEEN.
AND THAT THE CHAIRMAN HAS
ARTICULATED THE PROBLEM THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE WITH REGARD TO.
THE CLOSURE OF RECYCLING CENTERS
THE DROP IN RECYCLING RATES.
THERE MAY BE MANY FACTORS BUT I
THINK IT'S
IT'S FAIRLY TRANSPARENTLY
OBVIOUS WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHEN
THE CLOSURES OCCURRED. AND WHEN
THE DROP IN RECYCLING RATE
OCCURRED IT CORRESPONDS WITH A
TWENTY PERCENT REDUCTION IN THE
THE PAYMENTS THE GO TO RECYCLERS.
AND I THINK THERE IS.
GENERAL RECOGNITION THAT THE
FORMULA FOR CALCULATING
RECYCLING COSTS THE SURVEY
METHODOLOGY.
IS IS BASICALLY A SURVEY OF
EXPENDITURES AND WHEN THE WORLD
OF RECYCLING IS IN A BAD PLACE
RECYCLERS DON'T SPEND AS MUCH
MONEY. AND THAT IS THEN
REFLECTED IN A LOWER SURVEYED
COSTA RECYCLING LOWER PAYMENTS
PER CYCLE RECYCLERS WEEKS KIND
OF SEEN THIS DEATH SPIRAL OCCUR
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS AND
AND IN TOTAL. THAT DEATH SPIRAL
HAS COST THE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR.
AND YOU KNOW I I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT THIS MAY BE COMPLICATED BUT
WHAT WE'RE UP WERE SEEN THE
EXACT SAME THING HAPPENED THIS
YEAR.
WE'VE SEEN THE COSTA. FOR PT
BOTTLES
STILL REMAINS TWENTY PERCENT
BELOW THE THE COST BASIS THAT
WAS IN PLACE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
BEFORE ALL THIS DROPPED OCCURRED.
THE PROCESSING PAYMENT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE COST
RECYCLING AND SCRAP VALUE BUT
THE SCRAP VALUE THAT'S BEING
USED.
THIS IS NOTHING THE APARTMENTS
DOING WRONG THEY'RE JUST
FOLLOWING THE STATUTE IT'S THE
STATUTE THAT NEEDS TO BE UPDATED.
THE SCRAP VALUE THAT THEY'RE
USING FOR THE PROCESSING PAYMENT.
IS.
NOT THE ACTUAL SCRAP VALUE THAT
THE RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
RECEIVING THE ACTUAL RECYCLING
THE ACTUAL SCRAP VALUE THAT
RECYCLERS ARE RECEIVING IN THE
MARKETPLACE TODAY. IS THIRTY
THREE PERCENT BELOW.
SCRAP VALUE THAT WAS USED FOR
THE CALCULATION SO WORK WE'RE
KIND OF BACK IN THAT THE US
BROUGH SPIRAL WITH REGARD TO PT.
SO.
PROPOSAL THAT THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WAS DEVELOPED AND
ADOPTED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE LAST
YEAR HAS ALL THE PIECES
THE PLASTIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
MEANT.
IT PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE YOU IS
ONE OF THOSE PIECES AND WE
SUPPORT THAT AND YOU KNOW I I DO
WANT OF KNOWLEDGE THAT CAL
RECYCLED. THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF ROOM TO MOVE IN THIS AREA BUT.
IN THOSE AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE
SOME ADMINISTRATIVE FLEXIBILITY
IS THEY'VE TAKEN ACTION
WE TOOK ACTION AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS YEAR TO.
TO ADJUST THEIR REGULATIONS TO
PROVIDE A REASONABLE FINANCE
RETURN OF ELEVEN PERCENT FOR
RECYCLING CENTERS THAT WAS A
VERY GOOD THING THAT THEY DID.
ON JUST YESTERDAY THEY ANNOUNCED
A BOMB USING THEIR EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO FOCUS THE LIMITED
GRANT RESOURCES THEY HAVE. ON
THIS RECYCLING CLOSURE CRISIS
AND ON THE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS KIND OF
ALTERNATIVE BY BACK
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I THINK
THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY CAN WITH
THE TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE.
I JUST THINK THAT THE STATUTE
NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED ARM TO FIX
THESE PROBLEMS TO INCREASE
PAYMENTS ON YOU HAD THAT IN YOUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL LAST YEAR.
PASSED BE PART OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
IF THERE SAID NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR REMARKS TODAY AND.
CALL UP THE OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND THE AS THE DEPARTMENT IS SIR.
TAKING IT SAYS SEE TARA OUT
BEFORE YOU BEGAN AYE.
WANTED.
JUST MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT ON THE
AGENDA TODAY BUT.
THAT THAT'S THE A. A AND ISSUE
THAT WAS RAISED IN A. A WITH
THIS DEPARTMENT ALMOST A YEAR
AGO BACK IN JUNE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BONTA AND TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND SENATOR DODD. A
REGARDING THE MALLARD FORMS
CONSERVATION BANQUET OPPROBRIUM
AND. OTHER CONCERNED THAT
THERE'S BEEN A A LITTLE PROGRESS
ON OUR ON THAT PROGRAM.
.
THEY ALSO HAVE HAD LITTLE OR NO
RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND
SO THEY ASKED.
ME TO MAKE AN INQUIRY I DID
THAT SEVERAL MONTHS AGO AND
THERE'S BEEN VERY LITTLE
RESPONSE TO ME OR MY STAFF.
AT AT THAT AT THIS POINT AND SO
ARE A. ARE REGRETTABLY HAVE TO
EXPRESS AND FRUSTRATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE. LACK OF
RESPONSE
ON THE ISSUE IN ASK GOD THAT YOU.
OF.
PLEASE THE.
OF MAKE SURE THAT CHAD.
THERE'S A A A SPECIFIC RESPONSE
ON THE PROGRESS OF FLOOD A OF
THAT PROGRAM AND WHAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE. TO. MOVE IT FORWARD.
MR HIRES A POSSIBLE TO RESPOND
TO THAT AND HAVE A HORSE RATE
THINKS WE OPPORTUNITY AND
CHRISTOPHER TRAIL DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES.
WE WILL ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMUNICATION ISSUE IS
RESOLVED AND. APOLOGIES FOR THAT.
I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT WHILE
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION THERE'S BEEN NO
LACK OF. WORK ON THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN A LOT OF GOOD PROGRESS MADE
MORE THERE HAS BEEN IN YEARS.
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT HABITAT
RESTORATION OPPORTUNITY THE
PROVIDE RESOURCES IS IN THE
BUSINESS OF HABITAT RESTORATION
IN THE DELTA RIGHT NOW WE ARE
ALL IN ON THIS KIND OF WORK. AND
A LOT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
WITH THE MALLARD FARMS AND
OWNERSHIP GROUP. AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES AND OTHERS AND I
THINK WE'RE ACTUALLY ON A SOLID
PATH TOWARDS AND A PROJECT SO
WE'LL GET THOSE DETAILS TO YOU
IN LOOKING FOR TO MORE. AND
COMMUNICATION IN THE NEAR TERM
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT OF THE COMMENTS.
AND TO KNOW IT KEPT.
FIVE ISSUES WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENT SO LET'S
DIVE RIGHT IN.
IS NUMBER SIXTEEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
MY NAME THEIR COKE ON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FLOOD
MANAGEMENT DAM SAFETY. ALONG
WITH DEPUTY TRAIL HERE WILL KIND
OF BE BOUNCING BACK AND FORTH AS
WE RUN THROUGH THESE ISSUES
ALONG WITH SOME STAFF THAT WILL
BRING OUT. GREAT CENTER OF THE
DAM SAFETY TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL LANGUAGE THAT
BASICALLY CLARIFIES THE PROCESS
FOR DAM OWNERS BUT THERE IS AN
EXISTING OR PARTIAL EAP ACTIONS.
OR EMERGENCY ACTION PLAN WHERE
INNOVATION MAP AS OF MARCH FIRST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PARTICULARLY IN
REGARDS TO THOSE DAMS THAT HAVE
CRITICAL PERTINENT STRUCTURES.
THIS CHANGE ALSO REQUIRES THAT
DAM OWNERS WITH THESE PARTIAL
EP'S. AND INNOVATION MAPS THAT
THEY DEVELOP A TIMELINE BY WHICH
THEY WILL SUBMIT.
THERE COMPREHENSIVE EAP THEN DID
IT INUNDATION MAPS INCLUDING
THOSE WITH THE PART AND
STRUCTURES AT IT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. AND THAT'S BASICALLY
WHAT IT DOES IT JUST CLARIFIES
LANGUAGE FROM LAST YEAR.
GREAT AT HIGHS I DON'T THINK LA
OF HAS THE COMMENTS ON THIS PAGE
AND THERE'S NO CONCERNS THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO LET'S
MOVE ON ISSUE SEVENTY.
THE ONE MOMENT WHERE IN CALL
STAFF STEP PERSONNEL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
COMEY ARGUE VECI I MANAGE
STATEWIDE INTEGRATED WATER
MANAGEMENT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
AND I'VE BEEN SPONSOR.
MANAGEMENT SPONSOR OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT.
WATER DATA ACT OR ALSO KNOWN AS
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE.
THE REQUEST.
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU IS A
CONTINUATION. OF EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS AND THEN A BASELINE OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF.
THIS OPEN WATER DATA PLATFORM.
THE EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IT WILL BE ALLOCATED AMONGST
THREE OF THE NAMED A.
AGENCIES IN THE ACT.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
WOULD GET FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND.
DOT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND THIS IS THE SAME
ALLOCATION. WELL AS LAST YEAR
AND ALL THIS FUNDING WOULD BE
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE FUND.
THE THE WORK WITH THE THE
FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO.
ASSIST THE AGENCIES TO
TRANSFORM AND BEGIN POSTING DATA
ON. THE PLATFORM THAT HAS BEEN.
UNDER DEVELOPMENT WE WILL
CONTINUE.
ESTABLISHING PROTOCOLS AND
STANDARDS.
A AND WE WERE THEY ONGOING
FUNDING THE BASELINE FUNDING
WOULD BE FOR THE ONGOING
MAINTENANCE.
OF THE PLATFORM
I JUST WANTED TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WHILE THE W.
OUR IS MAKING THIS PRESENTATION.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
COLLABORATIVE MULTI AGENCY
PROCESS IN FACT THIS.
BUDGET REQUEST WAS COORDINATED
BY THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH AND THEOTHER.
STATE AGENCIES.
AND I'D ALSO IN CONCLUSION LIKE
TO.
TAKES OPPORTUNITY TO NOTE THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY ARE CCSD
HAS SCHEDULED A BRIEFING ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FIVE.
AT THE NOON HOUR TOMORROW HERE
IN THE CAPITAL.
GREAT THANK YOU LEO DO YOU KNOW
CONCERNS EXPRESSED.
GREAT THANK YOU ISSUE EIGHTEEN.
IF ANYTHING.
ON THE JOINT OPERATION CENTER
ONCE AGAIN WHEN ASKED BECAUSE
SOME.
JOINING HIM TO COME UP AND TALK
ABOUT IT.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN OF CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME SHAUN ACHES FROM WITH
PART WATER RESOURCES EXECUTIVE
OFFICE.
I DID A REYES REQUESTING NAINA
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND. OF THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO ENTER
INTO A BILL TO SUIT
POLICE.
GOC IS OF A SILLY THAT HOUSES
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL.
ENTITIES AND IT'S.
CLEVERLY CLUB REALLY MANAGES
AND OPERATES THE.
FEDERAL WATER PROJECTS AND
RESPONSES THEY QUITE EMERGENCIES.
.
THESE GROUPS HAVE COLLABORATED
SINCE THE SIXTIES THEY REALIZED
IN THE EIGHTIES THAT IT WOULD BE
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF NOT
ONLY THEIR PROGRAMS BUT FOR THE
STATE TO. ACTUALLY.
BE HOUSE THAT ONE LOCATION.
THAT DID OCCUR AND THE EARLY
NINETIES OF MID AND FORCING WAS
JUST AN INTRO LOCATION
AT THAT TIME I DID NOT MEET THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICE NEEDS FOR. THE
DIVISION OF FLOOD MANAGEMENT.
.
IN ADDITION TO THE CENTRAL
SERVICE NEEDS
OF SENSE OF THE EARLY NINETIES
WE HAVE.
.
BASICALLY HOMELAND SECURITY
REGULATIONS ARE TO COME INTO
PLACE THAT.
AFFECT OF MANY OF OUR
OPERATIONS THERE AND. REQUIRED.
NEEDS FOR NOT ONLY SPACE BUT I
T. PROTOCOLS THAT HAVE MADE IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO CONFORM.
AT THAT LOCATION.
THANK YOU. ELLIOTT. HAD JUST A
HIGHLIGHT AS IS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA WHILE THE REQUEST BEFORE
YOU IS RELATIVELY MODEST LESS
THAN A MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
TO ENTER INTO A LEASE AND. TO
BUILD OF A BUILDING THAT WOULD
BE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE. AND
YOU'LL HAVE FIVE FIVE YEARS.
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS THEY'RE
ANTICIPATING SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION A YEAR A YEAR IN ANNUAL
COSTS AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT
MOVING COSTS SO IT IS IT IS OF.
A BIGGER DECISION THAN JUST
ABOUT WHAT IS.
BEFORE YOU TODAY THAT YOU'D BE
SETTING IN MOTION WE LOOKED INTO
THIS PRETTY CAREFULLY AND FELT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE
DUE DILIGENCE AND LOOKING AT ALL
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES AND OPTIONS
FOR. UP PURSUING THIS IT IS
SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED AND WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL PARTNERS AND IS
A VERY SPECIALIZED BUILDING HAS
A LOT OF REALLY. UNIQUE
REQUIREMENTS SO WE DO THINK THE
REQUEST IS JUSTIFIED BUT TO
PUT JOHN NOTICED THAT THAT NEW
WILL HAVE FUTURE REQUESTS FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER AMOUNTS OF
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROJECT. CONSIDER MYSELF
NOTIFIED.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ADJACENT
HOUSE DEPARTMENT INANCE WE KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE'S WHERE THE
SPENT A LONG TERM MULTI A
PROCESS TO GET THIS PROJECT
READY AND WE FEEL CONFIDENT WE
FINALLY FOUND THE CRACK PATH
FORWARD AND WE SUPPORT PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU AND THERE'S A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS IN THE STAFF REPORT
WHICH I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO.
GET INTO DETAIL ABOUT HERE.
TODAY BUT ALAS THAT.
TO THE EXTENT IT'S A.
REQUESTED BY.
BUDGET STAFF THAT TO BE IN
COMMUNICATION OF THOSE ANSWERS
BE PROVIDED CONSERVE HAPPEN WERE
PRETTY. QUICK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE.
GREAT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF CHRIS
TRAIL FROM THE DEPARTMENT ONCE
AGAIN.
SO AS YOU ARE.
VERY WELL AWARE DEPARTMENTS IN
OUR OTHER AND SISTER AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS THAT THE STATE
WHETHER IT'S THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD OR OTHER.
.
OTHER PARTNERS MAKE A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS IN WATER
CONSERVATION RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER IT'S FAR
WATER USE EFFICIENCY WHETHER
THROUGH WATER RECYCLING. AND THE
KINDS OF BIG CAPITAL TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS THAT I'M A REALLY
NECESSARY TO MAKE AYE
CONSERVATION JULIA CALIFORNIA
WAY OF LIFE.
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
WATER ACTION PLAN.
AND ONE OF THE PIECES THAT'S
REALLY FUNDAMENTAL THAT
SOMETIMES DOESN'T GET AND.
AS MUCH AIR TIME AS MAYBE AND
SOMETHING THAT I SHOULDN'T AM SO
TO SPEAK IS THIS THIS THIS OTHER
FUNDAMENTAL PIECE AND THAT IS
PUBLIC EDUCATION PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
HOW DO YOU CHANGE PUBLIC
BEHAVIOR IN APPRECIATION FOR
AROUND?
WATER CONSERVATION WATER USE
EFFICIENCY AND BOTH THOSE PIECES
WHETHER IT'S THE THE
PREPARATIONS THAT YOU ALL MAKE
WITH US FOR FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT.
PAIRED WITH PUBLIC EDUCATION
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TO
MODEST ONGOING INVESTMENT. THREE
UNDER THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND.
AND TO THE DEPARTMENT TO A MOVIE
A SAFE CALIFORNIA WATER.
PROGRAM IN HOUSE IN THE WHOLE
IDEA HERE IS THAT THE STATE
LEVEL IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE
COORDINATED AND CONTENT CREATION
IF YOU WILL WHAT'S THE MESSAGING
AROUND THIS AND WHAT WHAT ARE
THE FACTS WITH THE FIGURES YOU
WANT TO GIVE OUT. AND THEN
PARTNERING WITH OUR LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES THAT THEY CAN THEN TAKE
THAT INFORMATION AND USE THEIR
LOCAL DOLLARS. TO RUN ANY SORT
ABOUT CAMPAIGN THAT THEY THINK
IS APPROPRIATE GIVEN THEIR
PARTICULAR REGION'S NEEDS
AND SO REALLY THIS IS A.
CONSOLIDATION IF YOU WILL OF
THE EFFORT IT'S ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS OLD.
AND INSURERS AND ONGOING
INVESTMENT AND FOCUS ON AGAIN
THIS BEHAVIORAL.
AND AND PUBLIC AWARENESS ASPECT
OF REALLY MAKING AND WATER
CONSERVATION MORE OF MORE WAY OF
LIFE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT'S THE GIST OF IT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU COULD AGREE WITH YOU MORE
THINK THAT MESSAGING THE
MARKETING OR IF YOU WILL AROUND
FTA WATER CONSERVATION AND.
IS ONGOING IT CAN'T STOP WERE
UPON YOU KNOW FIGHTING AGAINST
THINGS LIKE TODAY IT RAINS AND
PEOPLE START TO THINK OF. NOT
SUCH A PROBLEM
IT'S AN ONGOING PROBLEM AND IT
TO.
BEARS REMINDING EVERYONE.
TO EVERYONE.
.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS ALEJO NO
CONCERNS OF THAT PART OF THE
FINANCE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR LAST ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY. IT ONCE AGAIN
ERIC COPE WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
DVRS REQUESTING GENERAL FUND
ADDRESS HIGH RISK URBAN AREAS
FOR THE USE OF BOND FUNDS IS
LIMITED.
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY AND
EIGHTY FOUR HAVE ALL BEEN
ALLOCATED TO EXISTING PROJECTS.
AND BOND FUNDS ARE LIMITED.
MOVING FORWARD THE CURRENT CAN
OPPOSED FUTURE BOND FUNDS ARE
LIMITED UP FOR THE USE OF URBAN.
PROJECT THAT WE DO WITH THE
UNITED STATES ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS IMPROPER REGION AND
MAINTENANCE BECAUSE THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE NOT USUALLY MULTI
BENEFIT NATURE WHICH THE NEW
BONDS. REQUIRE.
SO DELIVER REQUESTS INCLUDES
UNDER SEVENTY MILLION FOR FIVE
YEARS FOR HIGH RISK URBAN AREAS
THESE FUNDS ALLOW US TO PARTNER
WITH THE UNITED STATES ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS ON FEDERALLY
LED PROJECTS. THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
TWO HUNDRED YEAR LEVEL FLOOD
PROTECTION.WILL ALSO LEVERAGE
AN ESTIMATED SIX HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
WE ALSO REQUEST ONGOING FUNDS OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION YEAR TO
MAINTAIN THE FLOOD SYSTEM.
TIMELY MAINTENANCE IS CRITICAL
AND HELPS PREVENT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
A IN THE FUTURE THESE FUNDS WILL
PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR COST
SHARING WITH LOCAL MAINTAINING
AGENCIES.
THE FUNDS WILL ALSO BE AVAILABLE
FOR PRIORITY PROJECTS THAT
REDUCE POTENTIAL STATE LIABILITY.
I HAVE FINALLY THERE'S A ONE
TIME REQUEST FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CENTRAL
IF A PROTECTION BOARD WHICH WILL
COME OUT OF THE FIRST YEAR OF
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
.
TO ASSESS AND DO A FEASIBILITY
STUDY ON.
THE SACRAMENTO WORKING DRAINS
DISTRICT AND ITS AUTHORITY TO
POTENTIALLY LEVY FEES IN THE
FUTURE.
.
BUT THAT.
HAPPEN ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU LA JOH. ESOS NOTED
THERE ARE REALLY TWO COMPONENTS
OF THIS PROPOSAL A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FROM THAT WOULD BE
USED TO LEVERAGE SIGNIFICANCE
AMOUNT OF SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING SO WE THINK THIS
IS A. GOOD USE OF ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND THAN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ANG. FOR MAINTENANCE ON
THE STATE FLOOD SYSTEM FOR WHICH
THE STATE HAS RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR MAINTAINING AND LIABILITY
WHEN IT'S NOT MAINTAINED SO CAN
WE THINK THAT'S A WORTHWHILE.
AND USE OF FUNDING THOUGH IT IS
ONGOING AT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SOME INTERESTING IDEAS THAT
THEY'VE EXPRESSED ABOUT TRYING
TO USE THAT TO TO LEVERAGE AND
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR LOCAL
MAINTAINING AGENCIES ON THAT
PORTIONS OF THE STATE SYSTEM
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES ARE ARE
HELPING TO MAINTAIN. SO THAT'S
SORT OF A NEW EFFORT IT'S IT'S
INTERESTING AND ENCOURAGING I
THINK PROBABLY SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CHECK BACK IN ON NEXT YEAR TO
SEE HOW THAT'S GOING AND.
WHETHER THERE ADDITIONAL STEPS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT
TO TAKE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT
FOR NOW WE THINK THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE PROPOSAL.
IF YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FATE.
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL
FIVE OF FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES ISSUES.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN ROBERT COR
FROM THE LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY WHERE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS ITEM AS AS YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE. UNTIL AT SOME
DETAILED LA O. THIS DOES
LEVERAGE NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
OF A BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. AND.
THIS IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY RATE
PAYERS A FEE INCREASES WHICH
HAVE BEEN ENACTED OVER THE LAST
A COUPLE OF YEARS.
THROUGH THROUGH POPULAR OF VOTE
WE.
ALSO HAVE SUBMITTED A LETTER.
AND WE ENJOY SUPPORT FROM THE
FLIGHT CONTROL CAUCUS
NOW AND WE THOROUGHLY AGREE WITH
THE LA OR IS ANALYSIS IN THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE A REPORT
WHICH WAS SUBMITTED YESTERDAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN NOT
COMMITTEE HOW MY NAME IS GILBERT
CHO SEALED WITH THEM BECAME
ENGINEERS.
WHERE FLOOD CONTROL CONSULTANTS
TO THE US CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
CONTROL ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUAL?
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS AND FLED
AGENCIES IN THE DELTA AND US
EGGMAN VALLEY AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE THIS MEASURES HAVE
JUST EXPLAINED BY MISTER GORE
IT'S CAN LEVERAGE A LOT OF MONEY.
AND ALSO IT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
DELTA AND SOME OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE'VE RUN INTO DELTA SOME A
STATE FUNDED. NON THE IT THE
LOCALS COME UP WITH A LOT OF
MONEY WHICH AND IN ZEPA
PARLAYING SOME OF THEIR. MONEY
INTO A HIGHER FLOOD CONTROL
LEVELS THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT CLOSES
OUT OUR DISCUSSION ON THE DEED
OF YOURS ISSUES AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
WE GOT THE CDC UP NEXT
ONE ISSUE.
MORNING MR MORNING AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'M LARRY GOLD'S VENOM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION.
A IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
YOU WILL FIND A THREE POINT ZERO
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR B. CDC
TO RELOCATE ITS OFFICES FROM THE
STATE OFFICE BUILDING IN SAN
FRANCISCO. TO THE NEWLY RE HAVE
BEEN REHABBED METRO CENTER ALSO
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO.
METRO CENTER WAS CONSTRUCTED BY
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS AND THE.
LOCAL AIRPORT AND ALSO HOUSE
THE SAN FRANCISCO ESTUARY
PARTNERSHIP.
ALL FOUR REGIONAL AGENCIES AND
BC
SEE OUR PARTNERS ON ANY NUMBER
OF PROJECTS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
MAINLY RELATING TO RISING SEA
LEVEL AN ADAPTATION ALONG THE
BAY SHORE LINE.
AND A A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WHEN
THIS PROJECT STARTED THE
COMMISSION. A DECIDED TO MOVE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IF POSSIBLE
INTO THAT BUILDING. A WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS MERIT SUPPORT FOR TWO
REASONS FIRST OF ALL FROM A
POLICY ISSUE.
RBC DC STAFF WORK ON A DAILY
BASIS WITH EACH OF THEM WITH
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF OF EACH OF
THESE REGIONAL AGENCIES AND TO
BE IN THE SAME BUILDING.
PROVIDES TREMENDOUS LEVERAGE
TREMENDOUS ENERGY
SECOND IF BE CDC IS ABLE TO MOVE
TO THE METRO CENTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD THEN
EXPAND. ITS FOOTPRINT DIRECTLY
INTO BC DC'S CURRENT SPACE AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS IN
TERRIBLE NEED OF X. OF EXTRA
SPACE IN SAN FRANCISCO SO THAT
WORKS OUT VERY WELL.
FOR THE SECOND BASIC REASONS
BASIC ECONOMICS.
OAKLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
REST OF THE BAY AREA A COUPLE
YEARS AGO BECAME THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLACE NOT ONLY TO LIVE
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT ALSO TO
WORK.
TRYING TO FIND SPACE AND IT WAS
A.
FOR WHICH WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE
BY THE WAY.
.
BUT ALSO IT'S ALSO CERTAINLY TO
WORK.
COMMERCIAL SPACE IS NOT ONLY AT
A PREMIUM BUT YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE COST
B. CDC WILL RECEIVE BELOW MARKET
RATE AT. OF THE NEW HEADQUARTERS
AND IT'LL LABELS DOJ NOT TO HAVE
TO GO OUT AND TRY TO FIND SPACE
FOR ITS STAFF AT WHAT WOULD BE
NO DOUBT VERY VERY EXPENSIVE PER
SQUARE FOOT RATES.
THANK YOU ALEJO. YES SO WHILE
THE PROGRAMMATIC BENEFITS FOR BE
CDC TO BE CO LOCATED WITH THEIR
PARTNERS ARE VALUABLE WE DIDN'T
THINK THAT WAS ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY
THIS EXPENDITURE ON ITS OWN SO
WE LOOKED INTO A QUITE CAREFULLY.
AND LOOKED INTO DOJ'S OFFICE
NEEDS AND ASSOCIATED COSTS AND
DID FIND THAT OVERALL THIS
APPROACH IS THE LEAST COSTLY.
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE STATE WHEN
YOU ENCOMPASS THE NEEDS OF BOTH
AGENCIES BE CDC AND HAD DOJ SO
WE DO FEEL THAT THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE HE WAS JUST FINE.
THANK YOU I I THINK I THINK IT'S
A REALLY GOOD THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS HOLISTICALLY AND NOT
JUST TO A IN THE AREA KIND OF A
SILENT APPROACH.
YOU CAN LET BERMAN FINANCE CHAIR
ENDED UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DID.
IN DEPTH PURPLE OR COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
FROM STATEWIDE BASIS.
AND ALSO BE CITIES IN THE OJ
BASIS MAKES THE MOST SENSE OF.
WITH IT WE HAD TO A MEETING OR
TWO GO A CONVERSATION WITH THE.
COASTAL COMMISSION AND
SUGGESTED THAT.
THEY MIGHT.
DO BETTER.
IF THEY WEREN'T IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
ANY LONGER I REALIZE YOU'RE
CRINGING IN THAT.
CARRIES WITH IT SOME.
A SOME IMPLICATIONS.
BUT THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
AVAILABLE REALLY TO.
IN THE SAME WAY TO BE CDC WHICH
THAT IS CORRECT BECAUSE NEEDS TO
BELONG. BCD SI IN ADDITION TO
BEING BY STATUTE REQUIRED TO BE
IN SAN FRANCISCO SIMPLY TRYING
TO FIND SPACE IN ANY OF THE NINE
COUNTIES IS REMARKABLY DIFFICULT.
AND UNDERSTOOD THE MISTER MULLIN
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT AS A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE NPC. WHEN THERE'S
A BUILDING WITH SOME CONTROVERSY.
WAS NOT ACTIVATED AND REALLY
THAT VISION WAS TO BRING ALL
THOSE REGIONAL AGENCIES UNDER
ONE ROOF. A IN ONE LOCATION AND
ITHINK IT'S GOING TO PROVE TO
BE SO CERTAINLY OVER THE LONG
HAUL A BY A BENEFIT.
OFFER ALL OF THOSE ENTITIES AND
OUT ULTIMATELY OFFER THAT FOR
THE TAXPAYERS AS WELL GIVEN THE
VALUE OF REAL ESTATE IN DOWNTOWN
SAN.
DISCUSS I APPLAUD.
YOUR EFFORTS. IN THAT REGARD
THERE'S A REFERENCE IN THE STAFF
REPORT ABOUT MTC.
HAVING SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE.
COSTS FOR TEN IMPROVEMENTS IN
SOME ISSUE THEY HAVE THEIR COULD
YOU JUST. VERY BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
WHAT THAT IS BUT I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH OF COURSE WITH
MOVING FOR.
SO DTS HAS A BASIS FOR PROVIDING
A COST PER SQUARE FOOT PRETEND
IMPROVEMENTS SINCE A REGIONAL
BASIS.
AND SAN FRANCISCO THAT IT'S A
HUNDRED FORTY DOLLARS PER SQUARE
FOOT.
.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH THAT AND.
.
THAT'S WHERE THIS REQUEST COMES
FROM.
MISTER KALRA.
BUT I JUST WANTED. THOSE IN
RAMONES COMMENTS I WAS CHAIR
THAT AREA ERIC BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AT
THE TIME AND THEN ON THE BOARD
AT THE TIME THAT. SOME THESE
DECISIONS ARE MADE CONSOLIDATION
THAT ALTHOUGH HE UNDERSTOOD. I
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF START UP
COSTS REALLY CREATE. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF BOTH
FISSION SEASONAL LONG RUN WITH
ALL THOSE AGENCIES.
CLICK YOU.
AND TAG YOU GIVE ME AN OPENING
SO.
I WILL USE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT YOUR
WORK FORCE.
FACES A DAUNTING CHALLENGE WHEN
IT COMES TO FINDING AFFORDABLE
PLACES TO LIVE AND DEATHS OF THE
A HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
IS PLAYING OUT IN REAL TIME. IN
IN YOUR WORLD BUT THE.
THE.
COROLLARY OF THAT TO WHICH IS A.
EXTREME PRESSURE ON COMMERCIAL
OF A PROPERTY BECAUSE OF.
FRANKLY THE SUCCESS OF THE STATE
AND PARTICULARLY. THE BAY AREA A
BAY AREA.
IS A PRESSING NEED AS AS A
PRESSING ISSUE AS AS WELL.
AND ADVISER ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS ITEM.
CHAIRMAN DUNCAN EFFECTORS
REPRESENT METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION ON
VERGE COMMITTEE HOLD THIS OPEN
SO THAT COMMISSION STAFF
CONTINUE TO HAVE DIALOGUE WITH
BERMAN FINANCE IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. TO ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE REIMBURSEMENT OF FOR
TEN IMPROVEMENTS THAT IS SPACE
PROVIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOU
DIDN'T URGE WERE GOING TO HOLD
IT UP.
AND THAT WAS THAT WILL MOVE ON
NOW TO YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT TO A.
COMMISSION THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
HOUSE ONE ITEM BEFORE US.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
NAP.
IT IS THE NO IT'S GOOD MORNING
ALRIGHT.
KNOWS TWELVE A AT.
THIS IS TWO MINUTES
SLOW.
THE ORAL SCREWED UP HERE GOOD
AFTERNOON TODAY I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON.
CARE BLOOM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CALLING CONNOR AND THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO IT'S A REQUEST
FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE LAKE TAHOE
SCIENCE AND LAKE IMPROVEMENT
ACCOUNT. TO CONTRACT FOR A
CONSULTANT FOR INDEPENDENT STUDY
OF RENT SETTING METHODOLOGIES.
FOR LEASES OF SOVEREIGN LAND AT
LAKE TAHOE.
THE BED OF LAKE TAHOE ON THE
CALIFORNIA SIDE IS STATE OWNED
SOVEREIGN LAND USES SOVEREIGN
LAND FOR THINGS LIK COMMERCIAL
MARINAS PRIVATE RECREATIONAL
PEERS AND MORNING. SHE'S A
MOORING BUOYS REQUIRES A LEASE
FOR THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY LEASES AT LAKE
TAHOE. THE GREAT MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE FOR PRIVATE
RECREATIONAL PEERS AND MORE
EMPLOYEES.
AND NO RENT FOR THESE PIERS
EMPLOYEES SET THROUGH YOU SAID
BENCHMARK RENTAL RATES.
BENCHMARKS ARE USED TO ESTABLISH
UNIFORM RENTAL RATES IN SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS WITH LARGE
CONCENTRATIONS HAVE SIMILAR
FACILITIES SUCH AS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA THE DELTA THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER IN THE COLORADO
RIVER.
THE USE OF BENCHMARKS IMPROVES
CONSISTENCY AND TRANSPARENCY
THROUGHOUT A GEOGRAPHIC REGION.
IN CROUP IMPROVE STAFF
EFFICIENCY IN SETTING AND
ADJUSTING RENT FOR LARGE NUMBERS
OF LEASES AND SAVES TIME AND
MONEY FOR BOTH THE APPLICANT AND
THE STATE.
THE BENCHMARK RENTAL RATES ARE
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION STAFF AND
ARE UPDATED EVERY FIVE YEARS.
DEVELOPING THE APPROPRIATE
METHODOLOGY FOR DETERMINING A
FAIR MARKET RENTAL VALUE FOR
SOVEREIGN WATERCOLOR COVERED
STATE PLANTS IS INHERENTLY
CHALLENGING. THERE IS NO OPEN
MARKET FOR SOVEREIGN LAND AND
THUS NO DIRECT COMPARABLE SALES
FOR APPRAISAL PURPOSES BECAUSE
IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY PROHIBITED
TO SELF SOVEREIGN WATER COVERED
CA PLANTS.
THEREFORE THE COMMISSION
HISTORICALLY HAS UTILIZED A
COMPARISON OF RENTS FOR OTHER
SIMILAR LAND OR FACILITIES AS
ALLOWED FOR UNDER EXCLUSION
REGULATIONS.
TO DEVELOP THE BENCHMARK
METHODOLOGY AS A MOTIVE MOST
EQUITABLE APPROACH TO DETERMINE
FAIR MARKET RENTAL VALUE.
RECENTLY DURING COMMISSIONS LAKE
TAHOE BENCHMARK UPDATE THERE
WERE SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS
RAISED FROM A NUMBER
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHETHER THE
CURRENT BENCHMARK METHODOLOGY
WAS THE MOST APPROPRIATE. WE
ALSO HEARD THERE IS PROBABLY
HELD BELIEF FILE THAT
STAKEHOLDERS FOR A THOROUGH.
EVALUATION OF THE VARIOUS
METHODOLOGIES AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMISSION TO ASSESS RENT FOR
PEERS BUOYS AND OTHER STRUCTURES
LOCATED ON STATE PROPERTY. TALK.
THIS REQUEST
IF FUND COMPREHENSIVE THIRD
PARTY STUDY THAT WILL INCLUDE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS CONDUCTING
LITERATURE RESEARCH REGARDING
VALUATION LEASING A SUBMERGED
LAND. INTERVIEWING AGENCIES OR
ENTITIES INCLUDING THOSE AND
OTHER STATES THAT LEASE
COMMERCIAL LAND AS TO THEIR
PRACTICES AND RENTAL RATES.
INTERVIEWING LAKE FRONT OWNER
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS AND
GROUPS OF LAKE TAHOE.
INTERVIEWING S. B. SIX THIRTY
STAKEHOLDERS
SOLICITING INPUT FROM INDIVIDUAL
LASSIES OTHER STAKEHOLDERS LAKE
TAHOE.
RESEARCHING RELEVANT MARKET DATA.
COMPILING A DESCRIPTIVE LIST OF
POTENTIAL PRINT SETTING
METHODOLOGIES WITH THE STRENGTHS
AND WEAKNESSES OF EACH.
IDENTIFYING THE BENEFITS TO
UPLAND OWNERS AFFORDED BY APPEAR
ON LEASED LAND.
ATTEMPTING TO QUANTIFY THE VALUE
ENHANCEMENT TO THE UPLAND
PROPERTY OWNER BY THAT LEAST
PEER.
THE CONSULTANT WILL ALSO BE
ASKED WITH TO ATTEND PUBLIC
MEETINGS OF PROVIDE OUTREACH TO
RESPOND QUESTIONS FROM LET'S SEE
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES.
AND FINALLY PREPARE FINAL STUDY
MAKING PRESENT AND MAKE YOUR
PRESENTATION A PUBLIC PUBLICLY
NOTICE COMMISSION MEETING.
POST STUDY IS EXPECTED TO TAKE
ONE TO TWO YEARS TO COMPLETE.
THAT CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ALEJO NO CONCERNS AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DYESS IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION ONLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU.
EXCEPT FOR A STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AGAIN WITH ONE ISSUE.
CHAIR BLOOM AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AYE MANDY SAWYER
ASSISTANT CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
THIS ITEM INVOLVES THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND NINE POSITIONS.TO PROVIDE
FOR AND ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE WITHIN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
PROVIDING QUALIFIED AND
IMPARTIAL PROFESSIONAL HEARING
OFFICERS FOR ADJUDICATIVE
PROCEEDINGS.
I ESPECIALLY ENFORCEMENT MATTERS
PART IN WATER RIGHTS.
LAST SESSION THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED
AB THREE THIRTEEN WHICH WERE
PROVIDED FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING OFFICERS BUT HAD SEVERAL
PROBLEMS AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED
THE BILL.
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE FOR GOVERNOR
DIRECTED THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL. AGENCY TO REPORT
BACK ON THE POTENTIAL FOR.
THE USE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING OFFICERS ARE IN WATER
RIGHTS MATTERS IN THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THIS PROPOSAL IS THE EFFECTUATE
XIN. A OF THAT RECOMMENDATION.
I INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ESTABLISH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS OFFICE.
AND ESTABLISH PROCEDURES FOR
USE OF ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
OFFICERS AND TIMELY DECISIONS
ARE IN THOSE MATTERS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES FOR FUNDING
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR A GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE.
THESE ARE ONGOING PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES NOT A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE MAKING THE USE OF
GENERAL FUND A INAPPROPRIATE.
THE EXISTING FEE STATUTE FOR
WATER RIGHTS A PROVIDES FOR
ANNUAL ADJUSTMENTS
TO ADJUST THE FEES BASED ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
FROM THE WATER RIGHTS FUND BUT
WITHOUT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT COULD BE USED FOR ONLY
ABOUT SEVENTY PERCENT.
OF THE COST OF THIS PROPOSAL
THAT'S BECAUSE THE EXISTING FEE
STRUCTURE CHARGES.
ABOUT ONE CLASS OF WATER RIGHT
HOLDERS HOLDERS OF WATER RIGHT
PERMIT TEASING LICENSEES OF BUT
NOT OTHERS. WHOSE ACTIVITIES DO
CREATE THE NEED FOR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS THAT
THIS WOULD FUND ARE AND WHOSE
RIGHTS ARE ALSO BENEFITTED. OF
BY HAVING A FAIR AND EFFECTIVE
HEARING PROCESS.
ALL THE WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
BOTH THOSE CURRENT ASSEMBLY TO
THE CURRENT FEES AND THOSE WOULD
BE SAID IT THE NEW FEE WHICH I
WOULD ADD IT'S JUST FOR THE COST
OF THIS PROGRAM. NOT OVERALL
COSTS OF WATER RIGHTS.
DIVERT AND USE WATER WHICH BY
LAW IS PROPERTY OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE THEY PAY NOTHING FOR
THE PROPERTY ITSELF. THIS IS
JUST SUGGESTING THAT THEY SHOULD
PAY A FEE TO COVER THE COST.
FOR AN ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
PARTIES ALL WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
GET FAIR AND EFFICIENT HERE.
SO IF I UNDERSTAND THAT.
CORRECTLY CURRENTLY THE.
THE BOARD ITSELF.
HERE'S ALL OF THESE COMPLAINTS
THAT'S RIGHT BUT HEARING PROCESS
PROVIDES THAT EVEN OF THE FULL
FIVE BOARD MEMBER HERE'S A HINT
MATTER OR AN INDIVIDUAL BOARD
MATTER MEMBER. AS HEARING
OFFICER HERE'S THE MATTER AND
THEN PRESENTS THE RECOMMENDED
ISN'T DECISION TO THE FULL BOARD
WHICH VOTES ON THE MATTER AND
THE PROCESS THAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING TO US TODAY WOULD
REPLACE THE EXISTING CA. HEARING
SYSTEMS THAT RIGHT FOR SPECIFIC
WATER RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT MATTERS
IT WOULD HAVE THE HEARING
OFFICER. OF ISSUE A DECISION
THAT IS FINAL BUT SAID IT TO
RECONSIDERATION OF AN AGGRIEVED
PARTY CAN SEEK RECONSIDERATION.
BY THE FULL STATE WATER SOURCES
CONTROL BOARDS FOR OTHER MATTERS
THE HEARING OFFICE WOULD ASK ACT
AS THE HEARING.
OFFICER.
TAKING TESTIMONY HANDLING THEY
THE DECISION BUT WOULD PREPARE
RECOMMENDED DECISION TO THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD WHICH WOULD VOTE TO VOTE
ON THE MATTER BASICALLY SOME OF
THE SIMPLEST MATTERS. WOULD BE
DECIDED BY ORDER OF THE HEARING
OFFICER IN THE MORE COMPLEX ONES
THE HEARING OFFICER WOULD ACT AS
HEARING OFFICER BUT PRESENT THE
HEARING OFFICERS DRAFT ORDER. TO
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD IN EITHER CASE OF
VERRES APRILIA PROHIBITION
AGAINST EX PARTE CONTACTS WHICH
WOULD PREVENT THE HEARING
OFFICER FROM HAVING.
DISCUSSIONS WITH BOARD MEMBER
SO EVERYTHING'S TRANSPARENT.
THANK YOU.
A ALEJO JOHN MARTIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
AS NOTED IN THE ENGINE DE THIS
PROPOSAL RELATES TO AB THREE
THIRTEEN WHICH WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR LAST YEAR AND THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES A DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE. FOR HEARING WATER
RIGHTS ACTIONS THAN AB THREE
THIRTEEN ESTABLISHES A NEW
PROGRAM AND AT ONE WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE'S RECENTLY DEBATED
THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS. TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THIS PROPOSAL
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED IN THE
POLICY COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU AYE DEPARTMENT PLANTS.
SURE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
HOLD DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE BECAUSE
THE PROPOSAL WAS IN RESPONSE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE.
I ONCE THIS PLAN BECAME READY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES WERE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET ACT.
AND TRAILER WILL BE NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THAT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROBERT OR FROM
THE BALK A GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE KINGS RIVER WATER AUTHORITY
WHICH IS THE STATE'S LARGEST
PRIVATE RIGHT HOLDER. KERN
COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS.
THOUGH THE IDEA OF A WATER
RIGHTS HEARING OFFICE IS A GOOD
ONE IT DESERVES TO BE VETTED AND
ANALYZED ARE THOROUGHLY IT'S A
COMPLEX ESSENTIAL ELEMENT. IN AS
THE LA O. NOTES IT'S PERHAPS A
GOOD A GRIST FOR THE UP POLICY
COMMITTEE. MIL OF OUR CLIENTS
AND.
MOST OF THE WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO BEING
THE SOURCE FOR FUNDING FOR THIS
IT'S A STATEWIDE FEE. INCREASE
TO PAY FOR REGIONAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC ACTIONS THERE IS NO
NEXUS. THAT WATER RIGHT
ENFORCEMENT.
ACTIONS LIKE ANY OTHER
ENFORCEMENT ACTION SHOULD BE
PAID FOR BY BAD ACTORS AS PART
OF THE SETTLEMENTS. ALSO WOULD
NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA WATER
CODE AND YOU HAVE THE SECTIONS
IN THE LETTER WE SUBMITTED.
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY
FOR GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES TO GATHER AND
ADMINISTER WATER RIGHTS RELATED
FEES OF THERE IS NO ADEQUATE
JUSTIFICATION IN THIS PROPOSAL.
WE WERE ALSO NOTE THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE APPROVED TO BE CP FROM
THE WATER BOARD. A TO ADDRESS A
BACKLOG IN WATER RATES.
S. BACKLOG INCLUDED OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE PERMITS OR
FOURTEEN YEARS WORTH. A THREE
HUNDRED FOUR REGISTRATIONS ARE
NINE YEARS WORTH FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT PETITIONS
EIGHT YEARS WORTH SIXTEEN
HUNDRED LICENSES AT FORTY FOUR
YEARS. STAKEHOLDERSOF MY CHAIR
HAVE HAVE CONSISTENTLY ASKED FOR
AN UPDATE ON THIS WE HAVE NOT
YET HAD ONE.
AND SO THE COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO
INQUIRE ABOUT THE PRIOR BICU
CP IN THE PROGRESS.
THEREIN THIS BY THE WAY HAS
NEVER BEEN FLOODED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE NO INPUT IN
THIS MATTER THANK YOU.
GIL DEL HELP WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
JUST ADDING TO MY COLLEAGUES
AND CONCERNS OF.
THAT CORRELATION BETWEEN AB
THREE ONE THREE AND THIS HAD
TRAILER BILL.IS THE STRUCTURE
DOESN'T LOOK.
THAT MUCH DIFFERENT.
THREE ONE THREE WHICH WE
SUPPORTED.
.
WAS MORE OF AN INDEPENDENT SIDE
THAT WAS NOT OVERSEEN BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
AND SO I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER
THAT AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS
BE CP IN THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION NAKAL
REPRESENTS WATER DISTRICT'S
WATER COMPANIES.
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS AND
COMMUNITIES IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTERS ON A NUMBER OF POINTS.
I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT.
YOU KNOW WHERE WE CONTINUE TO
CLOSELY REVIEW THE LANGUAGE
WHICH WAS FIRST MADE AVAILABLE
ON FRIDAY.
WE DO THINK THAT THE UNDERLYING
INTENT OF BOTH PREVIOUS POLICY
ABOUT MATTERS OUTPUT PRODUCED
PULSE BILLS ON THIS ISSUE AND
THIS TRAILER BILL ON HAVE MERIT
WE DO THINK THAT THEIR ROOMS
WAYS TO MAKE THE. A WATER RIGHTS
ADJUDICATORY MATTERS GENERALLY
ARE MORE EFFICIENT AND FAIR AND
WE ARE INTERESTED IN PURSUING
THAT.
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO
THIS LANGUAGE WE DO THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE I WERE INTERESTED
IN THINGS LIKE ENSURING THAT ANY
HEARING PROCESS.
HAS IS CLEARLY DEFINED THAT WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RULES OF
EVIDENCE ARE ON IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER DETAILED MATTERS WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THIS COMMITTEE
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO ON A
I I I TAKE IT THAT OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
WHICH IS.
RATHER SWEEPING IN A IN A SANTA.
IMPACT.
HAS THE LANGUAGE HAS ONLY BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR A FEW DAYS. A
SINCE FRIDAY.
.
SO.
STAFF CAN HAVE TO TAKE SOME TIME
TO DIGEST AND.
.
UGH AND CONSIDERATE.
I I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED NOW
THOUGH BUT I'M CONCERNED THAT
THAT TO ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC SAID THAT THERE HAD
NOT BEEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
STAKEHOLDERS SET TO BE INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS IS THAT ACCURATE.
YES WE.
THE BUDGET PROCESS IS
CONSIDERED CONFIDENTIAL WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO SHARE BUDGET CONTROL
UP BUDGET PROCESS OUTSIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION IN TELE PROVE ALL
WHICH. AND THEN IT WAS POSTED AS
SOON AS APPROVED. OF THE PROCESS
FOR SETTING FEES OUT WILL HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
.
AND WE ALL CRAMMED WILL HAVE
THAT INPUT AS WELL AS PUBLIC
HEARINGS BEFORE WE SET FEES OF
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
WE'LL START.
BASICALLY NOW ESPECIALLY WITH
ENACTMENT OF THE B. BILL W.
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS FOR ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
COOL WELL.
OKAY.
BUT WITH THE STRUCTURE ALREADY
SET IN PLACE.
BY THE BUDGETARY ACTIONS THAT
TO. HAVE THAT THAT THAT WE TAKE
SO THAT WOULD LIMIT THE ABILITY
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO ACTUALLY HAVE
AN IMPACT ON.
OF HOW THIS ALL COMES TOGETHER
WITH THE LEGISLATURE DECIDES IN
OUR FEE SYSTEM LEGISLATURE
DECIDES HOW MUCH OF THE PROGRAM
BEFRIENDED BY FEES.
AND HOW MUCH THE PROGRAM WILL BE
PAID FOR BY THE GENERAL FUND.
AND THEN THE STATE TAKES THAT
DIRECTION
TO DECIDE HOW TO SPREAD THE THE
FEES BUT YOU'RE RIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES.
IN ITS ANNUAL BUDGET.
HOW MUCH OF THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
COVERED BY FEES?
OKAY UM WE HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT I I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THE POINT TOO MUCH.
HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF THIS I AM
GOING TO BE HELD OPEN AND OUR
STAFFS WILL LIVE A GIVE US SOME.
US SOME FEEDBACK OF.
.
I JUST WANT PLEDGES A HIKER TIME
YOU KNOW NEURO EYES WANNA OF ICE
ONE ECHO OF THE CHAIRMAN'S
CONCERNS.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
WELL THE STAKEHOLDERS WERE NOT
INVOLVED IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER
THAT. THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD ESTABLISH
SOMETHING AND AND.
THE FEES WOULD THEN BE THAT
WOULD THAT THE FEES THAT WOULD
ENGAGE THE STAKEHOLDERS.
IT WOULD THAT BE THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE WHEN YOU THAT WHAT THE
SINGLE INVOLVE NATIONAL.
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM BEFORE
WE ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN A FEW
DISCUSSION I AGAIN I THINK IT'S.
I THINK IT'S GOOD MOVE
LEGISLATURE'S PREROGATIVE TO
DECIDE
HOW MUCH TO FUND THE PROGRAM?
HOW MUCH OF THAT SHOULD BE
GENERAL FUND HOW MUCH THAT
SHOULD BE FEE SUPPORT?
WE TAKE THAT DIRECTION AND WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO DECIDE
HOW TO ALLOCATE THE FEES.
BUT IT'S NOT WITHIN OUR PURVIEW
TO OVERRULE THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION LEGISLATURE'S
DIRECTION AS TO HOW MUCH OF THE
PROGRAM SHOULD BE COVERED BY
FEES ARE SPECIAL FUND. AND HOW
MUCH SHOULD BE.
COVERED THUG COVERED BY GENERAL
FUND.
OKAY OKAY I'LL EITHER I KNOW
INFLATED BY EITHER I UNDERSTAND
THE GENERAL FUND THOUGH THAT OUR
JOB IS THAT FROM A BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT BUT IN TERMS OF FOR
BUDGETING. SOMETHING EIGHT WE'RE
BUDGETING A PROGRAM AND THE
PROGRAM ITSELF.
STAKEHOLDERS RENOWNED BOUGHT AND
DEVELOPING THE PROGRAM IS THAT
CORRECT.
YEAH THAT'S CORRECT.
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR OF THE INFORMATION THE
PRESENTATION.
WILL TAKE THAT UNDER SUBMISSION.
AND THE.
CONSIDERATE AND FUTURE HEARING.
WE HAVE JUST ONE DEPARTMENT LEFT
DEPARTMENT OF FOR A TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
WITH A.
NINE I COULDN'T GO AT THAT COUNT.
IF THE.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BARBARA LEE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
APPEARING WITH ME TODAY IS
FRANCESCA NEGRI DTS HE'S CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR DTS HE'S BUDGET
FOR FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AS YOU KNOW DETAILS HE
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
IMPLEMENTING REFORMS AND
IMPROVEMENTS IN RESPONSE TO
INPUT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE LEGISLATURE AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. IN ITS FINAL
REPORT DTS HE'S INDEPENDENT
REVIEW PANEL RECOGNIZED OUR
PROGRESS AND UNDERSCORED THE
NEED FOR DTS YOU TO PERSEVERE IN
THESE EFFORTS.
THESE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED TO SUSTAIN DTS
SEES PROGRESS IN CRITICAL
PROGRAM AREAS THEY WILL SUPPORT
DTS SEES ABILITY TO MEET ITS
MISSION. TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM THE HARMFUL
EFFECTS OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED REFLECT
DTS SEES COMMITMENT TO CLEAN UP
CONTAMINATED SITES INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND MAXIMIZE COST
RECOVERY FROM RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
DTS SEE TO MAKE TOUGH CHOICES
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES ON THESE
PROPOSALS.
IN SUMMARY DTS HE IS REQUESTING
EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY NINE
POSITIONS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
SUSTAIN EFFECTIVE COST RECOVERY
FUND THE STATE'S MATCH
OBLIGATIONS ON NATIONAL PRIORITY
LIST SITES AND CONTINUE WORK ON
STATE ORPHAN CLEAN UP SITES.
TO ENSURE CONTINUED PROGRESS ON
THE CLOSURE OF THE EGGS I
TECHNOLOGIES BATTERY RECYCLING
FACILITY IN VERNON CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CLEANUP OF TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES
PARKS SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE
FACILITIES IN THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN HAVE
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD IN
THEIR SOIL. AND THE GREATEST
RISK TO SENSITIVE INDIVIDUALS
AND FINALLY TO IMPLEMENT
INVESTIGATION AND CLEANUP OF
OTHER PROPERTIES CONTAMINATED
WITH LEAD THAT THE DEPARTMENT
REASONABLY SUSPECTS ORIGINATED
FROM THE RECYCLING. OF LAST LEAD
ACID BATTERIES.
I AM PREPARED TO WALK THROUGH
THE PROPOSALS FOR YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE ON PLEASE LET ME KNOW
WHAT COMMITMENT COMMITTEES
PLAGIARIST I HAVE FILE ITEM
MISTER KALRA HAS SOME QUESTIONS
AND I DON'T.
I I WANTED TO LEAD OFF WITH A.
A QUESTION OR CONCERN REALLY
ABOUT.
.
CDVA.
SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR A NUMBER OF
THESE PROPOSALS I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS.
PROJECTED TO BE IN THE RED IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
.
AND NEEDS TO FIND OUT OF. A
PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING BUT
IN THE MEANTIME IT LOOKS LIKE
THE.
LEAD ACID BATTERY FUND WHICH IS
A NEWLY ESTABLISHED FUND IS IS
GOING TO BE TAPPED FOR THAT
PURPOSE. AND I FRANKLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT.
IS.
.
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE VERY VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE
ENABLING LEGISLATION FOR THE FOR
THE FUND.
I APPRECIATE OF THE TEARS
CONCERNED.
.
I I WON UNDERSCORES I SAID IN MY
OPENING REMARKS THAT A DTS HE
WORKED ON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AYE TO MAKE SOME
DIFFICULT CHOICES ON THE USE OF
SCARCE RESOURCES I THINK I'M
HEARING THAT YOU WOULD LIKE ME
TO ASK THAT QUESTION OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALLIED I
DO THAT.
YOU MISTER CHAIR JULIANA
MORRISSEY ME WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WHEN WHEN WE LOOKED AT.
OVERALL BUDGET FOR DTS SEE.
WE WERE WE HAD OUR OVERALL
APPROACH.
WERE.
THAT WE DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE ANY
BUDGET REDUCTIONS AT THIS POINT.
WE WANTED TO LIMIT PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS TO THOSE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE ONLY FULLY SUPPORTED BY
EXISTING RESOURCES.
WE ONLY WANTED TO CONSIDER FEE
INCREASES WE KNOW THAT
EVENTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO ADDRESS THAT. BUT WE WANTED
TO COME WITH A MORPH.
COMPREHENSIVE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
AT AND LIKE MY QUESTION. WHICH
IS.
.
THE GOD OF LEAD ACID BATTERY
FUND HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED. AS.
THE RESOURCE FOR THESE SET UP
VARIOU.
A ISSUES.
AND A.
MY READING OF THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION FOR THAT FUND. IS
THAT IT CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
SPECIFIED PURPOSES NONE OF WHICH
OUR UP.
APPEAR TO BE APPROPRIATE FOR
OUR OTHER PROPOSED.
LET LET ME ACT UP READ THE
LANGUAGE.
.
RICHARD IF THE RIGHTS OF.
THE THE OF THIS IS A.
ARE FROM MY AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE THE.
.
SELECT CHARMER IN THE RIGHT
SECTION.
I HAVE.
AND I HAD IT TO EMERGING
AFFECTED LA OLYMPIA AND. ASK YOU
TO READ THE LANGUAGE.
AND OKAY SO READING HAMMER IF.
FROM TIME SECTION TWENTY FIVE
TWO ONE FIVE POINT FIVE.
LEAD ACID BATTERY FEES COLLECTED
PURSUANT TO THIS ARTICLE SHALL
BE MANAGED AS FOLLOWS. THE BIRCH
AMEND AT THIS IS NUMBER ONE THE
BOARD SHALL RETAIN MANY IS
NECESSARY FOR THE PAYMENT OF
REFUNDS REIMBURSEMENT OF THE
BOARD FOR EXPENSES IN THE
COLLECTION THE FEES. NUMBER TO
THE REMAINING MANY SHALL BE
DEPOSITED INTO THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY CLEANUP FUND WHICH IS
HEREBY CREATED WITHIN THE STATE
TREASURY AND IT'S AVAILABLE UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE.
PURPOSES SPECIFIED THE SECTION
NOWADAYS AND LET ME PICK IT UP
FROM THERE IF IF IF YOU DON'T
MIND THANK YOU FOR HELPING ME
FIND MY PLACE HERE.
SECTION.
TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE TWO ONE
FIVE POINT FIVE.
SUBSECTION BE ONE BOB IS VERY
CLEAR BECAUSE IT SAYS.
THE MONEY'S IN THE FUND SHALL BE
EXPAND AT EXPENDED FOR THE
FOLLOWING ACTIVITIES
IT'S NOT OP AN OPTION THAT'S NOT
DISCRETIONARY IT'S SHALL BE
EXPANDED. AND THE A IF YOU READ
SECTIONS SAYS. A BNC OF THAT
SUBSECTION.
A IT THE WALL ABOUT LEAD ACID
BATTERY CLEANUP.
AND IT'S VERY VERY SPECIFIC
INVESTIGATION SITE EVALUATION
CLEANUP REMEDIAL ACTION REMOVAL.
BUT IT'S ALL SPECIFIC SPECIFIC
AND IT SAYS SHALL IT DOESN'T
REALLY GIVE ANY OF US DISCRETION
TO USE IT FOR SOME OTHER PURPOSE.
THERE THERE ARE ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE RELATED TO THE CLEAN UP OF
LEAD ACID BATTERY.
EXCITED EXCITED IS IS ONE OF THE
EXAM AND IT CAN BE IS FOR THOSE
BUT THERE ARE OTHER PURPOSES FOR
WHICH THE.
A FUND IS BEING UTILIZED AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN.
DO.
ARE YOU ABLE TO DISCUSS THAT OR
I'M HAPPY THAT YOU KNOW WELL
THIS IN ADVANCE WERE HOLDING THE
ITEM OPEN. BUT I WANTED TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT THAT'S A.
OF A CONCERN OF MINE MANAGED.
THANK YOU OF MISTER KALRA FIRST
AND THEN MISTER PATTERSON.
I THINK IT'S CHAIR. AND END UP I.
AGREE WITH THE WITH THE CONCERN
IN TERMS OF THE USE OF THE FUNDS.
I'M AND.
YOU KNOW I I IMAGINE THAT.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
UP BY SUGGESTING THIS PROPOSAL
YOU'RE NOT NICE THAT THE. THE
THE. THERE'S NOT A SUGGESTION
THAT THERE'S.
THAT WE.
I'M THAT ARE.
WHO DID BY USING THAT THAT THESE
FUNDS?
FOR NON THAT CLEANUP PURPOSES
ARE NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE HAVE
DONE ENOUGH HARM THAT
CONTAMINATION CLEANUP THERE'S
STILL WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO.
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATELY.
.
SO REQUIRED TO BE USED FOR.
RIGHT.
THAT IS CORRECT AND SO THAT'S
THE CASE ARM HARD W.. REMEDIATE
AT ABOUT HOW DOES THAT
REMEDIATION IT FUNDED IT FOR.
TAKING FUNDS THAT'S MOSBY'S Y.
REMEDIATION AND USE IT FOR OTHER
PURPOSES.
HIGHLY SUGGEST THAT WE GET THE
PROPER FUNDS TO ACTUALLY DO.
WHAT? OF THE BATTERY CANNOT FIND
HIS
MEANT TO DO.
I I I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ADD THE DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE A
PROPOSAL AND THE LAST PROPOSAL
ON YOUR LIST OF PROPOSALS TO
CONSIDER THE DOES SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS. ON THE IDENTIFICATION
AND A CLEANUP OF OF. SITES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT REASONABLY
SUSPECTS TO BE CONTAMINATED OF
BY V. RECYCLING OF LEAD ACID
BATTERIES. IN REGARDS TO.
.
AT THE OTHER USES OF THE FUN AS
I AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
THE DEPARTMENT.
DETAILS HE DID WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO. OUR
MAKE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS USING
SOME LIMITED RESOURCES.
THE AND SPEAK IN IN A WHO THANK
YOU FOR THE ANSWER BUT IT ALSO
TO SPEAKING OF THE OF OF THE
MAID ANSWERS OF THEM A DAMN
FUNDING.
RESOURCES OF THE TOP SUBSTANCE
CONTROL COUNT IS TO ANTICIPATED
BEING DEFICIT NEXT TO IT THREE
YEARS HOUSES DEPARTMENT OF
PAYING FOR THAT BUDGET SHORTFALL.
AND WHAT IS THE LIKELY
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACT ON THOSE
ACTIONS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
EVALUATING A AND CONDUCTING A
SERIES OF ANALYSES ON ITS FUN
CONDITIONS BOTH FOR THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT. AND
FOR THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT. I AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO PUT TOGETHER SOME FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE PACKAGES. TO ADDRESS
OTHERS FUNDING SHORTFALLS IN
FUTURE YEARS.
DOES DOES THE DEPARTMENT. OF. AS
WE STAND IS APARTMENT BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN MEET ITS
STATUTORILY AB REQUIRED MANDATES
WITH A SMALLER BUDGET.
AND IF NOT BUT RESPONSIBILITIES
MOST LIKELY BE IMPACTED BY LOWER
REVENUES IF.
WE DON'T IDENTIFY.
NEW FUNDS.
YOU'RE ASKING SOME VERY POINTED
QUESTIONS AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE CONCERN OF THIS BODY FOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S ONGOING
PERFORMANCE.
OUT.
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF IS.
UNABLE TO SECURE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN FUTURE YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE OBLIGATED TO
CUT SERVICES.
A WE ARE EVALUATING THE SERVICES
WE DO PROVIDE AYE TO ENSURE THAT
THE CUTS THAT WE MAKE. A WILL
HAVE THE LEAST NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
FROM EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL TOXIC
SUBSTANCES HOWEVER THERE WILL
NEED TO BE CUTS THE DEPARTMENT
IS CURRENTLY.
AT ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY ONE
STAFFING LEVELS AND.
FURTHER REDUCTIONS IN THE
STAFFING AT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CERTAINLY IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
MEET OUR MISSION.
BUT I AGREE WITH THAT. AND AND
THINK THAT WE NEED MORE FUNDING.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE
INSPECTIONS YOU UP UP AT THE I
THINK THAT. OTHER A LOT OF
PRIORITIES EVEN IN A SURPLUS
ENVIRONMENT FOR A LOT OF
PRIORITIES AND AND CERTAINLY.
IN I ONE HAS DIFFERENT IDEAS OF
WHAT TO DO.
WITH RESOURCES INCLUDING MAKING
SURE THAT WERE COGNIZANT THAT
YOU KNOW THE THE THE GLORY DAYS
ON LAST FOREVER AND THAT YOU
KNOW BOLSTERING OUR RESERVES
WHAT HAVE YOU BUT THAT BEING
SAID. UNDER OUR NEEDS I THINK
THAT NOT JUST EXCITED BUT A LOT
OF OTHER EXAMPLES AS TO. WHAT
MORE WE SHOULD BE DOING?
AND NEED TO BE DOING.
I KNOW THAT.
IN IN VETO MESSAGES OF TWO
BILLS LAST YEAR AB TWO FORTY
EIGHT MAYBE ELEVEN SEVEN NINE
THE GOVERNOR.
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE TASK COMPREHENSIVE DTS ERA
FORMED PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
ABOUT MEASURES OF IMMUNITIES BY
THE RESPECTIVE AUTHORS IN HOPES
OF SEEING ACTION ON THIS ISSUE.
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION AND.
MAINTAIN HIS WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS.
ISSUE THIS THIS YEAR AS
ARTICULATED.
OPEN IN THE PAST CERTAINLY IN
THE VETO MESSAGE.
I I I DO KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT SOME A
CONSIDERABLE EFFORT INTO
ADDRESSING THIS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. I'M AND I I BELIEVE WOULD
BE OPEN TO FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
AS APPROPRIATE.
OF AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK THAT THE MY.
NO MY MESSAGE CERTAINLY.
THEN WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
ISSUES FIRST OF ALL I DO AGREE
THAT THAT.
THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT.
USING THE FUNDS IN THE WAY THAT
I THINK ARE THE CHAIR
ARTICULATED.
HOWEVER EVEN BESIDES BEYOND
THAT I DO THINK THAT THERE. IS A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW.
A TO. TARGET FUNDS AND INCREASE
FUNDS IN THE WAY THAT WE HAVEN'T
DONE IN RECENT YEARS. THAT.
WELL WE CAN CERTAINLY IDENTIFY A
VERY CLEARLY THE NEED OF A AND
THE BENEFIT. OF OF ENSURING THAT
THOSE FUNDS OF THEIRS ON IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE INSPECTIONS
AND WHAT WE CAN DO MORE AND I
THINK WE CAN DO THAT WAY THAT'S
FISCALLY PRUDENT. AND EFFICIENT.
BUT I DON'T THINK I AM IT'S
ACCEPTABLE FOR US TO.
URBAN TO OCCUR EXCEPT GOING INTO
THE NEXT TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO
BUDGET SHORTFALLS IN AND.
DEPARTMENT THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS I
THINK YOU'D AGREE. WITH THAT.
OTHER ROOKIE DUES IMPORTANT THE
WORK THAT WE SUPPORT IS
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE. AND I THINK
THAT RECENT INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE FRANKLY. HAVE
INDICATED THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH.
BUT I AYE BUT I BELIEVE THERE'S
A PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T. I'M GET TO A DEFICIT.
SITUATION AND.
IT IS CERTAINLY IN THE TALKS
SENSES CONTROL ACCOUNT AS WELL
AS WITH THE OPERATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE CAN DO IT IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T. REQUIRE YOU KNOW
BOB FUNDS OVER THE PLAN TO BE
USING AND WAYS OTHER THAN THEIR
INTENDED. AND I THINK THAT'S
INCOMING UPON US AS A
LEGISLATURE.
AND AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR TO
MAKE SURE THOSE FUNDS ARE THERE
SO THANK YOU.
PATTERSON.
I YEAH I JUST.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR IN FRONT OF
THIS ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN IN FRONT
OF US IN ISSUE THIRTY IN FRONT
OF US ARE ALL DIVERSIONS FROM.
FROM THE BATTERY TAX.
IN THIS LOOKS LIKE.
.
THAT FUND IS
APPARENTLY AN EASY TARGET FOR
DIVERSION I'M I DON'T THINK
THERE IS ANY.
.
STATUTORY. OR ANY NEXUS THAT CAN
BE.
DEVELOPED THAT WOULD. ALLOW.
BUT IT A COMPLETE.
ABROGATION OF THE SPECIFIED
INTENT IN THE LANGUAGE.
IT WAS PASSED BY A SUPERMAJORITY
VOTE.
THE INTENTION AND THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE VERY CLEAR.
SO.
ARE.
THIS ISN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WE CAN DANCE AROUND THIS
IS A.
BLATANT DIVERSIONARY ACTION THAT.
THAT I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
PARTICULARLY.
CLEAR.
TESTIMONY HERE AS TO. WHERE DO
YOU GET THE AUTHORITY TO DO THIS
JUST BECAUSE YOU WANT TO DO IT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN'T?
AND AGAIN.
AS I STATED EARLIER I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON.
THE DEPARTMENT IS.
I DETAILS HE IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO MAKE A TOUGH CHOICES
IN A CONSTRAINED.
RESOURCE SITUATION.
FINANCE ONE AN EMAIL YEAH.
MEN ONLY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO.
.
THIS I A WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE POLICY.
IMPLICATIONS HERE AND.
AS WITH MOST BUDGET ACTIONS
THAT INVOLVE DIFFICULT TRADE
OFFS.
IN REGARDS TO USE.
MISTER PATTERSON'S.
DISCUSSION OF LEGAL AUTHORITY.
WHERE THAT COMES FROM REALLY IS
THE FACT
THAT THE?
LEAD ACID BATTERY TAX WAS
ENACTED AS A TWO THIRDS.
BECAUSE IT'S A TWO THIRDS THAT
MEANS THAT THAT THROUGH A
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION NINETY
THE BUDGET ACT.
YOU CAN THERE'S NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RESTRICTIONS ON
USING. WHAT'S ESSENTIALLY A TWO
THIRDS OF TAX REVENUE UP FOR
PURPOSES THAT DO.
FIT THESE PARTICULAR ACTIVITIES
AND SO WHAT WE ARE OF PROPOSING
TO YOU.
IS THAT.
GIVEN THE FISCAL CONSTRAINTS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT
TO KEEP.
THE.
DEPARTMENTS EXISTING PROGRAMS
HOLE.
THAT WE ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO USE A FINE. THAT.
HAS THE ABILITY TO FUND THESE
THINGS
BECAUSE IT'S TWO THIRDS OF FOR
THESE HIGH PRIORITY PROGRAMS
SO THAT'S WHERE THE AUTHORITY
COMES FROM. RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE ARE DIFFICULT FISCAL
POLICY.
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
WELL.
.
I I DON'T WANT TO GET A NEW
ALONG BACK AND FORTH WITH TO.
ó OVER THIS BUT I I HAVE TO
SAY JUST
SOME.
I'M JUST GONNA HOLD OFF
RESPONDING LA BECAUSE I WANTED
DIVE INTO THE SLOW BUT DEEPER
BUT I'LL DO THAT.
OUTSIDE OF THE.
OUTSIDE THE HEARING.
HOWEVER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
WROTE A LETTER ON MAY TENTH
THAT.
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE.
AND NEEDS APTLY EXCITED SITE
WHICH IS ONE OF THE ITEMS IT'S
ON OUR AGENDA.
ON AND RAISES A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ONE OF THOSE.
IS.
A DTS SEES DETERMINATION THAT.
PARKWAYS WON'T BE REMEDIATED.
AND I'M PARAPHRASING BECAUSE
PARKWAY AREAS IN FRONT OF HOMES
ARE LESS USED THAN OTHER AREAS
ON THE PROPERTY. AND IT A I CAN.
I HAVE TO ASSUME THAT THE REASON
FOR THAT DETERMINATION HAS MORE
TO DO WITH THE EXPENDITURE OF
FUNDS THAN IT DOES WITH THE NEED
TO CLEAN UP.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S ALL A LOWER
NEED SO IF WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS
OF LIKE THAT TO NOT SPEND MONEY
FROM THIS FUND.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME WERE
MOVING MONEY OUT OF THE FUNDS
FOR OTHER PURPOSES THERE TO ME
SEEMS TO BE A A A DISCONNECT.
SO.
AND I REALIZE THIS LETTERS ONLY
A BEEN OUT FOR A FEW DAYS I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE PREPARED TO
RESPOND TO THE ISSUES THAT. MS
CARILLO RAISES IF YOU'RE NOT
THAT'S
PERFECTLY.
UNDERSTANDABLE AT THAT AT AT
THIS POINT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO.
I ASK FOR A RESPONSE TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED IN THAT
MAY TENTH LETTER FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO IF NOT TODAY THEN
AND.
IN SHORT ORDER.
COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ASKED
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR WORK.
.
A REGARDING OTHER CLEANUP IN THE
COMMUNITY AROUND ON THE EXCITED.
FACILITY ON THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN.
ENGAGED IN CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES
THERE UP FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
NOW. WE'VE OVERSEEN THE.
TESTING OF ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED PROPERTIES IN THAT
COMMUNITY WE HAVE CLEANED UP
OVER THREE HUNDRED PROPERTIES IN
THAT COMMUNITY.
YOU ARE CORRECTTHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDING PARKWAYS AYE IN THE
CLEANUP ACTIVITIES. ON THAT ARE
OF BEING OVERSEEN AND THAT ARE.
SPELLED OUT IN THE CLEANUP PLAN
THAT WAS A APPROVED AND
CERTIFIED A WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS OF LAST YEAR.
WE MADE THAT DECISION BECAUSE AS
YOU HAVE OBSERVED ALL THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED.
A FINITE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
CLEAN UP OF THE UP PROPERTIES
WHERE THERE IS THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF LEAD AND THE GREATEST
POTENTIAL EXPOSURE TO. OUR
RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
LIVING ON THOSE PROPERTIES
AND THE.
THE DEPARTMENT DID AN ANALYSIS
OF WHERE EXPOSURES ARE MOST
LIKELY TO OCCUR. TO YOUNG
CHILDREN.
AND THOSE EXPOSURES ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO OCCUR IN THE PLAY
AREAS THAN THEY ARE IN THOSE UP
PLANTED STRIPS ALONG ROADWAYS.
AND SO WE HAVE MADE A DECISION
THAT.
IT IS THE BEST USE OF THE
LIMITED FUNDS TO INSURE THAT WE
CLEAN UP THOSE PLAY AREAS RATHER
THAN. THE.
PLANTED AREAS ALONG THE
ROADWAYS WHERE CHILDREN YOUNG
CHILDREN DON'T GENERALLY SPEND
EXTENSIVE AMOUNTS OF TIME
PLAYING IN THE DIRT.
BOB IT WOULD COST AN
APPROXIMATELY AN ADDITIONAL TEN
PERCENT.
ACT ACTUALLY THINK IT'S
THIRTEEN PERCENT.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT UNDERTAKE
CLEANUP OF PARKWAYS.
AND SO THAT WOULD BE A
CORRESPONDING REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF PROPERTIES WITH PLAY
AREAS THAT WOULD GET REMEDIATED
WITH THESE FUNDS.
IT'S A DIFFICULT CHOICE BUT OUR
COMMITMENT IS ABSOLUTELY TO
PROTECT THOSE VULNERABLE
CHILDREN FROM THE EXPOSURE TO
THE LEAD THAT WOULD HARM THEM.
IS THERE A REASON WHY YOU
COULDN'T ASK FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THE DEPARTMENT IS MINDFUL THAT
WE'VE BEEN ARE AWARDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
UNDERTAKE THIS CLEANUP.
OUT WE ARE DOING THIS WHILE WE
ARE A OVERSEEING THE CLOSURE AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION WORK OF THE
EXILED FACILITY ITSELF.
EXILED REMAINS RESPONSIBLE FOR
NOT ONLY CLOSING ITS FACILITY
SAFELY AND CLEANING UP THE
CONTAMINATION. ON THE SIDE OF
THE FACILITY BUT ALSO
INVESTIGATING CONTAMINATION THE
FACILITY MAY HAVE CAUSED OR
CONTRIBUTED TO IN THE
COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING THE
FACILITY. AND ENSURING THAT THAT
CONTAMINATION IS ADDRESSED AS
WELL.
SO THE CLEAN UP THE DEPARTMENT
IS UNDERTAKING RIGHT NOW IS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE PROPERTIES
WITH THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD
AND THE GREATEST POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE. EXPOSURES TO CHIU
INCENTIVE CHILDREN ARE CLEANED
UP QUICKLY.
WHILE WE MAKE SURE THAT EXACT
CARRIES OUT THE REST OF ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES SO I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE PARKWAYS WILL BE FULLY
ASSESSED AND ADDRESSED AS
APPROPRIATE.
THROUGH THE CORRECTIVE ACTION
THAT EXCITE IS REQUIRED TO
UNDERTAKE.
THAT I'D SWIM ACT TRY UNDERSTAND
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING THAT
EXCITED WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLEANING UP THE PARKWAYS.
.
BUT THE STATE WON'T UNDERTAKE
THAT UNDER THE.
.
A PROGRAM THAT TO ADD THAT YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS LEADING.
WELL WE HAVE CERTIFIED A CLEANUP
PLAN.
AND THAT CLEAN UP PLAN
SPECIFICALLY LAYS OUT HOW WE
PRIORITIZE TO THE PROPERTIES FOR
CLEANUP. CONSISTENT WITH THE
DIRECTION FROM THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS.
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF LEAD AND
THE GREATEST POTENTIAL EXPOSURE
TO SENSITIVE INDIVIDUALS. THAT'S
WHAT'S IN OUR CLEANUP PLAN WE'VE
LAID IT OUT IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
PARKWAYS.
SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT US
TO ADDRESS PARKWAYS WE WOULD
COME BACK WITH A PROPOSAL TO DO
THAT HOWEVER I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE. THAT.
THE EGGS I'D FACILITY THAT THE
COMPANY IS RESPONSIBLE UNDER
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
FOR ENSURING THAT.
THE FACILITY SITE IS
APPROPRIATELY CLEANED UP AND
IT'S CONTAMINATION. OFF SITE IS
ALSO APPROPRIATELY CLEANED UP. A
FIGHT AGAIN JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION AND.
I THINK MY UNDERSTANDING IS
CORRECT THAT.
EXCISE RESPONSIBILITY EXTENDS TO
ALL OF THE WORK.
INCLUDING THAT THAT'S BEING
DONE UNDER THE.
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS CORRECT.
HAD OBVIOUSLY A LOT MORE THAT WE
COULD BE A A DIVING INTO THE TO
THIS ISSUE MISTER PATTERSON DID
YOU HAVE IN A QUICKLY I'M I
HAVEN'T ADJOURNMENTS ART. AND
WHAT A PUBLIC ON THAT TO READ.
THAT'S. ONE O'CLOCK IT'S
PRESSING ME BUT AGAIN I'M
MENTION WE HAVE THREE ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE BROUGHT FORWARD ALL
THREE OF THESE.
.
ARE SIGNIFICANT DIVERSIONS AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT.
THE.
.
CONSENSUS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD BE NOT TO PASS THIS
THROUGH AND TO REITERATE.
AS FORCEFULLY AS WE CAN AND
THAT THE INTENTION FOR THE
BATTERY TAX WAS TO DO PRECISELY
WHAT THE LEGISLATION CALLED
FOREIGN.
AND.
IT JUST GONNA HAVE TO SEEK SOME
OTHER WAYS OF FUNDING.
THAT WOULD BE OUR I HOPE AND AN
OUTCOME THAT WE COULD AGREE ON
THAT SIR THANK YOU OF.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOT IN ADDRESSING WITH THE SAN
ANDREAS POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND I PULLED OUT A
COUPLE OF QUOTES FROM THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANELS AYE
LAST REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AYE DTS HE'S ACCOUNTS ARE ONCE
AGAIN IN STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WITH
DEPLETED RESERVES.
THIS PROBLEM IS EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE BASED ON PROJECTED
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES.
IT REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ATTENTION
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
BEGINNING TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET.
AND I CONTINUE TO BE VERY
CONCERNED. THAT WE ARE PASSING
THE BUCK YEAR BY YEAR LAST YEAR
I SEND FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
ARMED WITH A PLEA OF PROVIDING
MORE MONEY FOR ORPHANS SITES.
LAST YEAR DETAILS HE WAS NOT
ABLE TO COVER ALL OF ITS
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH ORPHAN
SITES.
I AND HAD AUGMENT ITS BUDGET
FROM OTHER AGENCIES.
AND THIS YEAR THERE ARE TAKING
MONEY FROM THE BATTERY FEE FOR
PURPOSE IT IS NOT INTENDED TO
PAY FOR.
IF WE DON'T TAKE
A SERIOUS LOOK.
AB HOW TO PERMANENTLY AND
SUSTAINABLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
FUND THE TSC AT AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL SO THAT ALL ORPHANS AS CAN
BE PAID FOR THAT THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
PROGRAM CAN BE PAID FOR FOR THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM CAN BE PAID FOR WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP COMING BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
I.
AND I COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO
SUFFER
SO IT PAINS ME TO SAY THAT I DO
NOT THINK THESE ARE APPROPRIATE
EXPENDITURES FROM THE BATTERY
FIND.
WHAT I DO THINK IS THAT WE NEED
TO FOLLOW THE ADVICE OF THE AYE
APPEAL ALSO SAYS?
IF DTC DOES NOT HAVE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO EXECUTE ITS
MANDATES THE HEALTH CALIFORNIANS
IN THE STATE'S ENVIRONMENT WILL
SUFFER.
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AT THAT COMPARTMENT
SHOULD BE IMPORTANT PRIORITIES
FOR THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE THEIR NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE ASSURANCES THAT RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS HAVE BEEN GOOD
INVESTMENTS.
WE CONTINUE TO ASK.
THAT THERE BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURES AT DTS
HE TO ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICITS AND THAT
WE HAVE A BODY THAT IS TASKED
WITH LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN MAKE
SURE. THE DTS USE SOLVENT AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE HEALTH
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
ACTED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANGELA BELOW MO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH
PROTECTION FOR LA COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
I I COULDN'T AGREE MORE MISTER
CHAIR WITH THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS HAD RAISED
ABOUT THE INAPPROPRIATE UP
PROPOSED USE OF THE BATTERY FEE.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IN
ADDITION WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE NEED
WITHIN.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS BATTERY CONTAMINATED
LAND.
IT'S A NEED THAT WE WILL NEVER
QUITE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
TO WHAT COMPLETELY ADDRESS.
AND SO THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE
NEED IS EXTREME.
AND I KNOW THAT WHEN THIS
BATTERY BE FEE WAS PROPOSED.
THE ADVOCATES AND AUTHORS OF THE
BILL INTENDED EXACTLY THE WAY
THAT THE MEMBERS HAVE JUST
EXPRESSED.
AND FOR US TO DIVERT THAT MONEY
INTO OTHER PURPOSES CONSUMER
PRODUCTS IS IMPORTANT IS THAT IS.
WOULD BE.
BASICALLY DENYING THAT
EXTREMELY THAT WE'VE GOT IN THE
PUBLIC NOT RIGHT NOW FOR
ADDRESSING THIS TYPE OF LEAD
CONTAMINATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU I'M A DIRECTOR LEE WE
KINDA JUMPED AROUND TO US
THROUGH A. A YEAR AGENDA ITEMS.
AND SO I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY IF CLAIRE I I THINK
WE.
MORE LESS COVERED EVERYTHING BUT
THE IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO ADD TO ANY OF THOSE ITEMS WHO
WANT TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO IT SINCE WE. DIDN'T QUITE
FOLLOW THE SAME FORMAT FOR YOU
THAT WE DID FOR.
OF THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY I'M
I I AM MERELY PREPARED TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THE
SPECIFIC ITEMS I GAVE YOU ARE. A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WERE
SOME SOME BIG ISSUES YOU WANTED
TO DISCUSS SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THING THAT I THINK OF BEST
ENOUGH QUESTIONS SIR.
FOR TODAY.
AND OF A CERTAIN LEGAL HAFTA.
.
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS TO BE
ADDRESSED TO A.
THAT WE CAN DO OUTSIDE OF THEM
OF THE MEETING IN PREPARATION
FOR.
ART ROCK AND FINAL.
REVIEW LITTLE BECAUSE UP COMING
IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I STRONGLY DID YOU ON ANYTHING
GUY ALEJO. SORE MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S HAD THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE US THE
FEEDBACK CA THAT THEY'RE WAITING
FOR ANSWERS I THINK THERE'S A
ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT MAIN
ISSUES WHO WISHES. TO RAISE I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TWO
THINGS ON THAT COST RECOVERY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATIVE MODIFY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
TO INCLUDE AT.
THIRTY GET NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT.
AND THEN ON THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION.
UP THERE WAS A REPORT
OUTSTANDING TO READ REJECTED
DATE ARE WOULD RECOMMENDED THE
YOU REJECT THE PROPOSAL HOWEVER
YESTERDAY WE RECEIVED THE REPORT
SOBRE WITHDRAWN THAT
RECOMMENDATION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF
THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER THAN.
.
WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY CLOSED UP
PUBLIC COMMENT I KNOW I
APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR BUT I
FORGOT TO COMMENT ON ONE OF THE
ITEMS THAT I THOUGHT WAS GONNA
COME SUBSEQUENT IN HOT SUNNY DAY
REAL AUTONOMOUS AGENT THERE.
THANK YOU.
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WANT TO
SPEAK ON ANY OF THE ITEMS. UNDER
UNDER THE SET TOPIC.
NOW WOULD BE THE TIME SO PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN JUST A
VERY QUICK COMMENT ON THE.
.
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR THE EXITE CLEAN UP.
ARE I WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE IN
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THAT
MONEY SHOULD DO A COMPLETE CLEAN
UP WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
ADDRESSING BOTH THE PARKWAYS.
THE YARDS AND THE HOME INTERIORS
THIS IS VITAL IF WE'RE GONNA.
LEAVE RESIDENTS WITH THE FEELING
THAT THEIR PROPERTIES HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP WE REALLY HAVE TO BE
IN A POSITION TO TELL THEM.
THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER.
ARE THEY NO LONGER HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT LEAD IN THEIR
HOME.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO ADDRESS ALL THREE OF THOSE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND THAT BRINGS US TO
THE CONCLUSION OF A VERY.
INTERESTING LENGTHY.
OF THAT IMPORTANT TO A PUBLIC
HEARING SO I THINK YOU OFFER
YOUR PRETTY
THE PATIENT.
WORDS ARENT